The End
Sir, just what are we facing here?
A relic of the old world.
Ready your men, Captain.
We will only get one chance.
And remember, when you hear the whispers, call for help.
Do not attack!
When you hear the whispers, what do you think he was on about?
It's Dorman, right?
Uh, yeah.
Then Dorman. Shut your damn mouth.
Why do I always get stuck with these rookies?
Hey, the kid's got a mean cleave. Give him a chance.
Quiet!
Come on.
Leave, eh, Captain?
A rookie can't even lift his own sword.
Captain Oren?
Captain?
It's here.
Rain! Send the signal!
What the fuck?
Rain!
On my back, we'll be laid off!
Come on, come on!
I'm ready!
It's a man!
No.
It's not!
Run!
Captain!
Captain...
Why are you here?
What is this?
Stop!
Humanity isn't ready.
On your feet, lad.
Sir...
The captain, I...
You'll be fine.
Here.....
What is it?
Get the body.
Stop.
Mortal.
It can still be contained.
You don't know what you have unleashed.
Your kind no longer control this world.
We cannot destroy your body, it's true.
But you will watch as we destroy everything you have built.
Bind him!
Feed.
Grow, my child.
I'll make sure you can eat your fill.
Oh, my child.
What?
Hi, I'm Jonathan Rogers, Game Director on Path of Exile 2.
Now, Path of Exile 2 is going into early access in around two weeks on December the 6th.
But even though it's early access, this isn't just some small taste.
The game is huge.
In this livestream we're going to be introducing everything you can expect.
So without further ado, let's roll the gameplay trailer.
Existence is a thing of beauty.
Precious, but impermanent.
Life and death are mortal enemies.
And yet, bound to one another.
The continuation of life must be protected at all costs.
Some have said, my methods are going to.
To this I say, there can be no salvation without sacrifice.
Gunfighterganal pometheus!
Satisfactionся!
Let's go!
We are faced with the end, and I will do what I must.
Those who obsess with death, let them soon be acquainted with it.
Now, as you just saw, even in Early Access, Path of Exile 2 is a big game.
It's actually been five years since we announced PoE 2, and over that time we've revealed a
lot, but it's been in bits and pieces.
It's pretty hard to keep track of it all, so today we're going to do a full rundown
of all the content that will be available at the start of Early Access.
Classes, character progression systems, and for the first time, a full overview of the
end game.
This is going to be a big one, so get comfortable.
For 20 years, Wraeclast has been free from any sources of corruption, but the Count of Ogham,
tempted by promises of power, intends to harness it once more.
The dead are rising.
Monsters are mutating, and madness is spreading.
Under the dark influence of corruption, the Count doles out sentences of death to any who
would question him.
One, two, three.
And this is where you find yourself at the start of PoE 2.
Explore the dark forests of Ogham.
Traverse the barren plains of the Vesteri Desert.
And delve into the jungle ruins of Utsal, an ancient Val city.
There are challenging monsters, hidden runes, lost camps and treasures, roaming merchants,
and, of course, unique bosses.
No two areas are the same.
It falls to you to track down the seed of corruption, the source of all this devastation.
On the way, you'll face fearsome monsters, meet strange characters, forge unlikely bonds,
and uncover lost civilizations.
But first, you'll need to pick a class.
Now, Early Access will initially have six classes available.
Let's have a look at them.
The Monk is a fast and furious melee fighter.
He dashes in and out of combat, and has mechanics that involve building up and keeping momentum.
Like all classes in PoE 2, you'll want to use a wide variety of skills to mix and match different combos.
To get new skills, you'll first need to find skill gems.
Using a skill gem will open the Gem Cutting menu, which shows all the active skills available in PoE 2.
You can choose an existing...
so many weapons that seem a toujours
looked like a herzlich foot.
And also the other thing about the
Thank you.
the jungle ruins of Utsau, an ancient Val city.
There are challenging monsters, hidden runes,
lost camps and treasures, roaming merchants,
and of course, unique bosses.
No two areas are the same.
It falls to you to track down the seed of corruption,
the source of all this devastation.
On the way, you'll face fearsome monsters,
meet strange characters, forge unlikely bonds,
and uncover lost civilizations.
But first, you'll need to pick a class.
Now, Early Access will initially have six classes available.
Let's have a look at them.
The Monk is a fast and furious melee fighter.
He dashes in and out of combat, and his mechanics
involve building up and keeping momentum.
Like all classes in POE2, you'll want
to use a wide variety of skills to mix and match different combos.
To get new skills, you'll first need to find skill gems.
Using a skill gem will open the Gem Cutting menu,
which shows all the active skills available in POE2.
You can choose an existing skill to level up,
or choose to engrave a new one.
Since this is a level 7 skill gem,
even if you pick a new skill, it will immediately be level 7,
so there's no harm in trying out something new.
The Monk primarily uses the Quarterstaff.
There are three skills of martial arts.
Lightning, Ice, and Wind.
But don't think you have to stick to just one.
The best combos are going to involve mixing elements of all three.
Let's try Killing Palm.
Like many Monk skills, this can be used to quickly take advantage
of a specific situation.
If there's an enemy on low life, you can use Killing Palm
to dash to them and kill them instantly.
This will provide a power charge.
Then we can use a different skill to consume that power charge
for a much more devastating attack.
The Monk also has powerful combo skills.
Tempest Bell, for example, is a skill that places a giant resonating bell.
Hitting the bell causes it to ring, dealing damage to all enemies around it.
You can also do things like freeze or shock the bell,
which will add elemental damage to the strikes.
The Monk also has a variety of abilities to empower his staff.
If an enemy is close to being stunned,
you can use Staggering Palm to punch them down.
After that, any attack you do will shoot out wind projectiles.
There are 21 active skills for quarter staves,
so this just scratches the surface of the options that you have.
By endgame, you'll be dashing from pack to pack,
spewing projectiles and obliterating screens of enemies
with huge combo attacks.
Now if you like a style of melee that's a little slower but hits much harder,
then the Warrior is for you.
He pounds the ground with big chunky attacks
and can shrug off the hits of small enemies with large amounts of armor.
Even though the mace slams are slow, you never lose control.
Longer attacks can be retargeted as you go,
and if you find yourself committed to a long attack,
you can dodge roll out of it at any time.
Among the skill options for maces,
you'll find a variety of slams, fire attacks, war cries and shield skills.
Here I'm going to slam the ground,
rending it apart with lines of fire.
Any slam skill will then cause these fissures to erupt with lava.
I can even run through them with a skill like Stampede
to do huge amounts of damage.
The Warrior can also use war cries,
which can empower your next skill.
Seismic Cry, for example,
will double any slams from the next attack.
The Stampede counts as a slam,
so it can double that for even more craziness.
If you want to go a little faster and be a little more defensive,
equip a shield.
In PoE 2, you can raise your shield at any time
to block all damage from the front, even spells.
While holding up your shield,
your stun meter will build as you take damage.
So be careful.
If it reaches 100%,
your stance will break and you will be vulnerable.
Some enemies also have unblockable attacks,
which are indicated by this red flash.
If you see one of these coming,
make sure to dodge out of the way.
Using a shield also gives you access to shield skills,
like Shield Charge,
which allows you to charge towards enemies and stun them.
While charging,
you're also blocking the whole time,
so you have full damage immunity from the front.
The Warrior also has access to totems.
Some totems have built-in abilities,
like Shockwave Totem,
which can be placed to stun nearby enemies
and trigger aftershocks like those from the Earthquake.
But you can also get Ancestral Warrior Totems,
which allow you to use any slam skill in your repertoire.
This is a meta skill,
which means that it's a skill you can put other skills into.
I can take a slam like Sunder and socket it into my Ancestral Warrior Totem.
Now when I summon him,
he'll sit there and slam the monsters from a distance.
There are 20 active skills for Maces,
so there's a lot more to try out.
But by endgame, you're going to be dropping Hammish from the sky,
leaping fearlessly into combat
and separating the very Earth you stand on.
Time for some ranged attacks.
The Ranger is primarily about the bow,
but we wanted to make sure that she feels agile as well.
In Pee-wee 2 you can shoot while moving.
Combined with all the skills the Ranger has
that allow you to jump around,
you'll have a lot of mobility in combat.
Bow skills have a variety of Lightning, Poison,
Ice and physical attacks.
Lightning attacks bounce around between targets.
You can also stick with cap at carduates
andatori so ninetyy 이런 calls.
You can also stick lightning arrows in the ground which explode when hit by the bouncers,
or electrocute enemies to take them out of combat.
Ice attacks are later slow and freeze enemies to keep them away from you.
Using poison, not only can you slowly damage your enemies from afar,
but also grow some interesting plants.
With 21 bow skills and all the mobility and combo tools the ranger has,
you can take advantage of every situation.
By endgame you'll be creating hundreds of arrows,
be they falling from the sky, bouncing around between enemies, or spraying out of tornadoes.
You might have noticed in the bottom left of the screen that the flask slots look a little different.
In Pee-wee 2 you have one dedicated life flask slot and one mana flask slot.
Flasks gain charges as you kill enemies,
and typically allow you to heal six or seven times if they're full.
But that's not the only thing you can use charges for.
Charms are a new item type that will automatically defend you from various debuffs or damage types.
Having trouble with getting frozen?
Equip a thawing charm.
When it's fully charged, it will make you immune to freeze for three seconds if you get frozen.
To recharge them, just kill more monsters.
You can gain more slots for charms by upgrading your belt.
The mercenary wields a crossbow that can be loaded with different ammo types,
offering versatility, power, and mobility.
All classes in Path of Exile 2 can be controlled with WASD,
which makes this class play exactly like a shooter.
For the crossbow, you will find skills that work like shotguns,
sniper rifles,
assault rifles,
and even grenade launchers.
But not only that,
there are a wide variety of more interesting elemental ammos too.
It's very fast to switch between ammo types,
so long as you already have them loaded,
which makes the mercenary able to combo abilities together for devastating effect.
Use Glacial Bolt to create walls of ice to separate enemies,
then switch to Fragmentation rounds to explode the ice,
dealing massive AoE damage.
If I come across an armoured enemy,
I could use armour-piercing rounds to break their armour,
and then high-velocity rounds to take them down.
Or perhaps I could fire a gas grenade to poison enemies
before detonating the cloud with an explosive shot for massive damage.
If you want to call in some suppressing fire,
you can summon artillery ballisters.
These have a minimum range,
so you'll want to prepare your position carefully before moving in.
There are 22 active skills for crossbows.
By endgame, you'll be calling destruction down from the sky
as you litter the battlefield with grenades
and pepper your enemies with your automatic shotgun.
If you're looking to take a backseat and let your minions do the work,
then the witch should be your choice.
She can call forth hordes of undead monsters to fight for her,
while casting powerful chaos spells that debilitate her enemies.
Occult skills are some of the most varied in the game,
with skeletons, noxious spells,
specialty minions, curses and sacrificial magic.
Before we talk about minions,
we'll have to talk about a new resource in Path of Exile 2 called Spirit.
This is a spirit gem,
which allows you to pick from a range of persistent skills.
All classes have a variety of these skills,
which can add some very interesting effects,
like Arctic armor,
which does cold damage to enemies that hit you,
or raging spirits,
which summon fiery skulls each time you cast a fire spell.
For the witch, though,
we'll want to be using our spirit to create permanent minions.
These minions will be revived automatically when they die,
so you don't have to worry about resummoning them all the time.
Here, I'm using the skill screen to allocate which minions I would like in my horde.
You can see the spirit cost of each one.
Skeletal warriors are cheap, but weak,
useful for tanking damage and distracting enemies.
But I want more heavy hitters in my army,
so I'm going to unsummon some warriors and instead add skeletal arsonists.
Permanent minions come with special active abilities called command skills.
You can order these guys to detonate your own minions for even more damage and air of effect.
If you want a bigger army, you'll need a scepter.
This new weapon type is imbued with even more spirit,
allowing you to summon even more friends.
And if you want an even bigger army than that,
you can take advantage of corpses to summon true hordes of minions.
But what can a witch do while her army is at work?
Well, she has a range of chaos spells to spread disease amongst your enemies,
or bone skills to impale them.
Or, you know, you could curse them to make them weaker so your horde can take them down.
There are 25 active occult skills.
By the endgame, you'll be the leader of a fearsome army of the dead,
consuming everything in its path.
The sorceress bends the elements to her will,
using them to unleash devastation on her foes.
This classic spellcaster weaves a flurry of elemental magic from afar.
The elemental skills have everything you might expect and more.
Fireballs, icy explosions, lightning storms, you get the idea.
Each spell is unique and has many different ways to build and combo with others,
even between different elements.
For example, flame wall conjures a burning line that not only damages enemies,
but also empowers all projectiles that pass through it.
If you place a wall and fire lightning sparks through it,
they'll gain extra fire damage.
It's a good idea to take advantage of the ability to automatically swap weapons when you use certain skills.
Having a special staff with bonuses to fire skills and another with bonuses to lightning skills can really power up a combo like this.
The sorceress can also take advantage of powerful trigger jams.
For example, you could grab the cast and ignite gem and use it with firestorm.
As you ignite enemies, a counter will go up in the top left corner.
When it's full, a firestorm will automatically be cast at the enemy that was ignited.
There are 25 active elemental skills.
By endgame, you'll be firing off projectiles left and right as you rain down elemental storms on your foes.
Now, those are the characters that will be available at the start of early access,
but we will be adding six more character classes with just as many skills and options as these.
There's a lot more to come.
There's one more important thing to mention about skills.
Even though we talk about them as belong to each class,
in reality, there are no restrictions.
You can use all these skills on any class so long as you have the attributes.
For example, a poison ranger might want to try out using occult curses to increase her poison damage,
or a monk might want to trigger elemental ice walls to use with his glacial cascade combo.
The possibilities for cross-class combos are practically unlimited.
We're looking forward to what kind of things you guys might find.
Now, Path of Exile is a game known for build customization,
and we haven't even scratched the surface of what is possible yet.
So let's talk about support gems.
Path of Exile 2 has a system of support gems that can be combined with your active skills
to dramatically change the way they work.
If you find a support gem, then right-clicking it will open up this screen.
Here you will find a variety of recommended support gems for each of your skills that you can pick between.
For example, this is a multiple projectiles support gem,
and can be used to add multiple projectiles to any skill.
Normally, when you fire a grenade, it'll look like this.
But if we add multiple projectiles, then you get three of them.
Once you have the gem, you can also freely move it between any of the skills on your character.
If you want to have a multi-shot sniper rifle instead,
then simply move the gem over to your high-velocity round skill.
Generally speaking, if it sounds like a support gem should work with a skill, then it will work.
So it's a good idea to experiment.
Note that you can only have one of each support gem on your character,
so you'll want to think carefully about which supports can be used best with each skill for maximum damage.
Now, if you want to stick to the recommendations, you should have a perfectly good time.
But if you want to experiment a bit more, then uncheck that recommended button,
and you can see the full list of supports that will work with your skill.
There are hundreds of support gems to choose from,
and even we don't know the results of all the possible ways these can interact.
Each skill can have up to five supports socketed into it.
And if you're clever, you can come up with some pretty interesting ideas.
Now, all of this is just scratching the surface.
You can make frost vortexes, break people's armor, make minions explode, make skills repeat.
Make enemies set each other on fire, cull enemies, or pin them to the ground.
Supports let you drastically change the behavior of your skills and create your own unique build,
or at least follow someone's OP build guide.
So, speaking of builds, let's talk about one of the most iconic Path of Exile systems,
the Passive Skill Tree.
Yes, it's huge.
There are over 1,500 nodes on there.
Now, a lot of people open the tree and can get a little intimidated at first,
but try not to be scared.
There are lots of options, but at its core, it's pretty simple.
Each level, you get one point to put into the tree.
Each class starts at a different location, but they all share the same tree.
Around your section of the tree, you'll find relevant bonuses for your character.
You should be safe in the knowledge that there aren't many wrong choices here.
Almost all the starting nodes will be useful for your character in some way.
But if you do happen to make a choice you regret,
you'll be able to respec any nodes you've taken by spending a little bit of gold.
Now, the tree is generally divided up into clusters which have similar themes.
In each cluster, you will find small nodes that give simple bonuses like increased damage,
but the real power comes from notables.
Notables normally have much more interesting bonuses,
and they tend to care a lot more about how your build works and what skills you're using.
For example, in the Mercenary area of the tree,
this one gives a 25% chance for crossbow skills to not consume a bolt.
And here's one that gives grenades a chance to blow up a second time.
This one gives a chance for projectiles to rebound off terrain,
as well as giving you some pierce chance to make that more likely.
Note that even though this is in the Mercenary section,
this would work with projectiles from all classes,
so there are often reasons to go to different areas of the tree.
In order to get between these clusters,
you will generally have to allocate nodes in the attribute highways.
Attribute nodes allow you to pick which attribute you would like to use,
so it's very easy to get points for any attribute that your gear might need.
You can change which attribute these nodes give you for half price at the respec vendor.
In addition to notables, you will also find even larger passives called keystones.
Keystones have both an upside and a downside,
and often require changing your entire build to design around them.
A great example is Giant's Blood,
which allows you to wield two-hand weapons in a single hand,
but doubles the attribute requirements of them.
You can use a two-hand mace with a shield, or even dual-wield them.
Or how about Mind Over Matter,
which makes all damage go to your mana pool first before your life pool,
but you lose 50% of your mana regen?
Skills like these can be tough to build around,
but if you're up for the challenge, they can be very rewarding.
As we showed you earlier on the Sorceress,
you can swap between weapon sets on the fly as you use certain skills.
One of the new features in Path of Exile 2's passive tree
is that you can choose to have your passive tree change
as you switch between weapon sets
to take advantage of specific bonuses on the tree.
For the Sorceress, you might want to change between
fire and lightning specialization.
Or you could switch between one-hand and a two-hand setup
in order to be able to block boss attacks
while following up with heavy hits from your bigger mace.
Or perhaps you could have a full curse setup on your witch
to debuff enemies before switching to a Chaos Degen build for maximum damage.
If you want to stick with just one weapon set,
you can just use these specialization points as bonus points
to invest however you like,
but creative players will find plenty of opportunities with this system.
You can get weapon specialization points throughout the campaign
from optional bosses and quests.
For example, if I manage to defeat the Crowbell,
I'll get a weapon specialization book.
There are lots of other permanent boosts available from the campaign too.
On the map, you can see icons that indicate
the many optional encounters you can find.
Some of them have permanent character boosts
and others have powerful items.
If you're having trouble getting past a boss,
it might be a good idea to explore and see what you can find.
For example, if you defeat Blackjaw the Remnant,
you'll gain a permanent increase to fire resistance.
One of the most important finds are spirit bonuses.
You can find the first one here in the canopy in Act 1.
Defeat the boss in this area to acquire a permanent addition of spirit.
The permanent buffs you gain from spirit are very powerful
and every class will find the use for them.
So make sure you hunt down these upgrades.
There's one in each act.
Now we haven't even talked about the most important element
of character progression, items.
That's why we're all here, right?
Items in Path of Exile can be broken down into four rarity groups.
Normal, Magic, Rare and Unique.
One of the things you're going to want to do as you play through the campaign
is upgrade the items you find, and you can do that with currency items.
An orb of transmutation will allow you to upgrade a normal item
to a magic item with one mod.
You can then apply an orb of augmentation to add a second mod,
then use a regal orb to add a third mod and upgrade it to a rare.
Finally, you can use some exalted orbs to add more mods to your rare
to a total of six mods.
One of the things we think is really important
is to make these options available to use as you play.
All the items that add mods are much more common than they were in Path of Exile 1,
so that you can use them throughout your campaign playthrough.
We want you to find things on the ground
that can be crafted into upgrades much more frequently.
As well as making the drop rates on these items much more common,
you can also get them by disenchanting unwanted gear at the magic item vendor.
If you disenchant magic items, you can build up to an orb of transmutation,
and by disenchanting rares, you can build up to regal orbs.
Another important area of crafting items in PoE 2 is sockets.
Some items you find will have sockets that can have ezomite runes placed in them
that add more mods to the item.
If I insert this glacial rune into my helmet,
it will give extra cold resistance.
This is a great way to solve problems that you have with your build,
like resistances or damage.
If you find socketed items that you don't have a use for,
you can take them to the salvage bench in town
to work towards an artificer's orb.
This will allow you to add sockets to your existing items.
Body armors and two-hand weapons can have up to two sockets,
while the rest of your armor and one-hand weapons can only have one socket.
You can also salvage items with quality
to create items like armor scraps or whetstones.
These will allow you to increase the quality of your items for an up to 20% boost.
If you don't want to disenchant or salvage your items,
you can always sell them for gold.
Gold can be used to buy items from vendors,
and we've tried to do a lot to make sure that the items they have for sale are actually useful.
Every time you level up, they get more stock,
so make sure to check back often.
Other vendors offer a gamble.
Pay a flat amount of gold, and you'll get a random item of a specific type.
This could be a great way to improve your gear, if you're lucky.
Gold is also used to respec your passive skills.
Take advantage of this system to experiment with your tree and rework it as required.
The other thing you might want to use gold for is the currency exchange.
This allows you to exchange currency items with other players on an open market,
in exchange for a small gold fee.
Now, all items in Path of Exile are freely tradable.
We never bind anything to your character, except gold.
Now, most gear in Path of Exile 2 is randomly generated,
but there's another type that isn't.
Uniques.
They are especially rare,
each with a handcrafted set of unusual mods,
which can dramatically change a character's build.
They're not just better rare items.
They can do much stranger things that can fundamentally change your character.
Corpse Wade will make any corpses you run through explode into clouds of poison.
The Sands of Silk is a body armor that changes your dodge roll into a blink,
morphing you into sand as you teleport past your foes.
And of course, some uniques are just pure hits of dopamine,
like Quill Rain,
which just turns your bow attacks into full auto by doubling your attack speed.
Each unique is something that you can build your character around.
We try to make sure that most unique items have a potential use at endgame,
even if you find them early on.
And as you can see,
every single unique item comes with custom art to match.
The last character progression system that you can do during the campaign is Ascension.
Starting in Act 2, you will come across Ascension Trials,
tests that you must complete to unlock your Ascension class.
We'll explain these trials soon,
but first let's take a look at what Ascending can do for your character.
Each class has access to three Ascendancy classes,
but at the start of Early Access, only two per class will be available.
Ascendancy classes are unique to each character class,
so choose wisely.
They can drastically affect how you build your character.
As a sorceress, you could become a Stormweaver,
a master of the elements.
Tempest Caller causes elemental storms to be summoned
each time you do a critical hit with a spell.
With Strike Twice, you can stack two copies of Shock for more damage,
and going deeper into the tree,
you can make all your damage types apply Shock.
Make a Shock build from any skill.
Alternatively, you could become a Chronomancer and command time itself.
She literally has the ability to stop time with Time Freeze.
Not only that,
but she has many other time manipulation abilities.
Using Temporal Rift,
she can teleport back to a previous location,
resetting her life and mana back to what it was.
Or with Time Snap,
she can reset all her cooldowns
and cast all her spells again.
On the Warrior,
you can choose between the Warbringer or the Titan.
The Warbringer channels the might of his ancestors
to gain tremendous power.
Using Answered Call,
you can summon Ancestral Spirits linked to each of your totems.
With Jade Heritage,
you can encase your body in a protective layer
that absorbs all damage until it breaks.
Warcaller's Bellow allows you to explode the corpses of your enemies.
And with Great Wolf's Howl,
you can ignore the cooldowns of your Warcries.
Let all that anger out.
The Titan class is all about hitting big.
With Earthbreaker,
every slam is a chance to create an aftershock.
With Crushing Impacts,
every hit becomes a crushing blow,
which will allow you to stun your enemies with ease.
With Surprising Strength,
you can take advantage of stunned enemies
to deal 40% more damage.
As a Ranger,
you might choose to be a Deadeye,
an expert markswoman who can take down foes with style.
With endless munitions,
every attack gains an extra projectile.
With Gathering Winds,
she gains a small increase to movement speed with every attack.
But be careful,
she loses them when getting hit.
With Eagle Eyes,
she will never miss,
allowing you to stop wasting all those passer points on accuracy.
Alternatively,
you could become a Pathfinder,
the master of flasks and poison.
She can choose from one of several throwable concoctions,
allowing her to spend her flask charges
to throw explosive bottles
that deal various types of damage.
A Bleeding Concoction will make your enemies bleed,
while a fulminating one can shock your enemies,
allowing you to do extra damage.
Contagious Contamination allows her to spread poisons between her foes,
while Overwhelming Toxicity doubles the number of stacks
they can be infected by.
Running Assault allows her to move much more quickly while firing,
while Relentless Pursuit makes her totally immune
to being slowed by enemies.
The Witch can ascend into the Infernalist or the Blood Mage.
As an Infernalist,
she can summon a loyal Hellhound companion.
The Hellhound sets enemies on fire,
as well as taking a percentage of the damage
if the Infernalist gets hit.
With Pyromantic Pact,
you can turn your mana into Infernal Flame.
As you cast more spells,
the Flame builds up,
and if it overflows,
you'll take damage.
Using Bringer of Flame,
you'll want to make sure you keep the flames topped up.
While your Infernal Flame is above 30%,
all damage from you and your minions will ignite enemies.
She can also transform into a literal demon.
While in demon form,
she takes an increasing amount of damage,
but her cast speed and damage increase rapidly as well.
So if you're planning on transforming into a demon,
make sure you stack a lot of life recovery.
She can also become a Blood Mage,
a master of life and energy.
All Blood Mages must pay the price
of making skills cost life as well as mana,
but in exchange,
every monster they kill will drop life remnants,
which allow them to quickly gain back that life.
With Crimson Power,
she can gain large amounts of extra life,
and with Vitality Siphon,
she can use her spells to leech life back as well.
Once you've got a significant amount of life,
you can use Gore Spike
to make your critical hits deal incredible amounts of damage.
A monk who is in tune with the elements
might become an invoker.
With elemental expression,
the invoker will create waves of elemental power
each time he does a critical strike.
With Faith as a Choice,
you gain the ability to meditate,
allowing you to double your energy shield.
Choose between I am the Blizzard or I am the Thunder
to specialize in Cold or Lightning.
And I Shall Rage will lay to turn into an unbound avatar.
Each time you apply a status ailment to an enemy,
you gain unbound fury.
When you have enough,
transform into an avatar
to deal way more damage
and inflict even more elemental ailments.
Some monks choose to reach into the darkness instead.
The Acolyte of Chayula
can exchange their mastery of spirit for darkness,
a resource that can be utilized
to both absorb and deal damage.
The Shroud of Darkness will protect you
from all damage incoming,
but if you take grasp of the void,
you will deal extra chaos damage
from all the darkness you have.
Their Dark Pact offers greatly increased resistances
to chaos damage
and can allow their mana leech
to not only happen instantly,
but apply to their energy shield as well.
Another node you can take is Waking Dream,
which allows you to see into the domain
of the Breach Demons.
There you will see the Flames of Chayula
that can be taken to gain life,
mana and damage.
The Mercenary has a job to do,
but which job suits you?
You might choose to become a Witch Hunter.
Obsessive Rituals will give you a Sorcery Ward,
allowing you to defend yourself against elemental hits
in exchange for less defense against attacks.
With Zealous Inquisition,
your enemies have a 10% chance to explode on death.
The chance has doubled against demons and undead.
With Judge, Jury and Executioner,
your initial hit against enemies
can deal up to 30% of their life in damage,
if you're lucky.
This is great for hunting powerful bosses.
And with Witch Bane,
you can break your enemies' concentration,
preventing them from casting spells
as often as they would usually do.
You could also choose to become a Gemling Legionnaire,
enhancing your abilities
by embedding gems directly in your flesh.
Integrated efficiency will give you extra skill slots,
Thermatological Infusion gives you extra maximum resistances
as you socket more and more support gems.
Adaptive Capability allows you to use any color of gem
without worrying about attributes,
while Crystalline Potential adds extra quality bonuses
to every gem socketed into your character.
So those are the Ascendancy classes
for the start of Early Access.
But one thing we haven't talked about yet
is how you ascend in the first place.
Ascension in Path of Exile 2
requires completion of one of the Great Trials,
which you'll find as you progress through the campaign.
Each one is associated with one of the major cultures of Rhaeclast.
Located in the Vasteri Plains are the Marraketh,
a culture of rich tales and brutal traditions
who must do whatever it takes to survive in the desert.
The highest position in Marraketh culture is a Sekima,
and it is not a title given freely.
All aspirants must complete the Trial of the Sekimas,
a gruelling gauntlet that will test their strength,
will, cunning and patience.
To enter, a warrior of the Marraketh must prove their worth
by trapping the soul of a djinn in a coin,
and you are no different.
Once you have earned your coin,
it may be placed in the Relic Altar to begin the Trial.
In the Trial of the Sekimas, each room has its own challenges to overcome.
In this room, each rare monster you kill will send its blood
to the chalice in the center of the room.
Once the chalice is filled, you will be able to proceed.
While fighting monsters in the Trial, you will need to be very careful.
Each hit will not only hurt you, but will damage your honor.
The monsters are well telegraphed, so that you can avoid their attacks,
but if you run out of honor, you will fail the Trial
and need to find another coin in order to try again.
It is a good idea to make sure that you are well prepared
before challenging the Trial of the Sekimas.
After each room, you will be rewarded.
In this case, you have been given a key
that can be used to unlock chests later in the Trial.
Once you have claimed your reward,
you will be shown a map of the rest of the floor
and may choose how you wish to proceed.
Which challenges would you like to face,
and which rewards do you want to claim?
Some rooms are more dangerous,
afflicting you with debuffs that will persist for the entire Trial.
For example, entering this room will afflict you with spiked shells,
that will cause all monsters in the rest of the Trial
to have 50% increased life.
You will want to take care if you choose such a path.
There are many different challenges and rewards
as you journey through the Trial.
Deadly traps, waves of monsters,
and strange artifacts will test your honor.
As you progress, you'll be able to gain boons from the Djinn,
which will help you on your journey.
For example, the Sekima's Cloak will revive you once if you die,
giving you a second shot at a run.
One of the rewards you may find is Sacred Water,
an extremely valuable and treasured resource
to the Djinn and the Mariketh.
Trading it with the Djinn will allow you to receive many benefits.
You can recover honor, gain additional boons,
or remove afflictions.
At the end of the floor, you'll find a powerful boss
which will truly test your limitations.
In order to ascend, you will need to defeat him.
Having defeated the boss, you've earned the right to ascend.
But first, the loot.
The keys you have found may be used to open the various treasures
in the vault at the end of the floor.
We only have a single bronze key,
so we'll just have to open one of these small chests.
If you want to open the better ones,
you'll need silver or gold keys.
Let's use the Altar of Ascendancy.
Your first ascension will allow you to pick your class
and grant you two points to use in the tree.
Now, there are more flaws and many more rewards
that can be found within the Trial of the Sekimus,
but we'll save that for the section on the endgame.
For now, let's talk about the second Ascendancy trial,
the Trial of Chaos.
In Path of Exile 2, you can choose whichever trial you like
to earn your ascension.
Each culture on Wraeclast had their own methods to ascend.
If the Trial of the Sekimus is not your kind of playstyle,
or you're finding it too difficult, you could try another.
You can gain all your ascension points from just one,
or mix and match them.
It's up to you.
For early access, we will have two trials as options,
with a third trial coming later for the full release.
While exploring the Vaal jungle,
you'll discover the Temple of Chaos.
Before the Vaal embraced the science of corruption,
their civilization worshipped Chaos.
This ancient trial was once used by the Vaal
to test their high priests.
A high priest of the Vaal must show willingness
to risk everything to gain power.
Entry to the trial requires a token from a strange entity
known only as the Trial Master.
For those in which he sees potential,
he shall inscribe an ultimatum.
Many have attempted these trials in search of greatness.
Most have perished.
Will you be able to defy the odds?
Before you begin each chamber,
the Trial Master will offer you a reward and a choice.
Choose one of three tribulations to affect you
through the rest of the trial.
These modifiers might beef up the monsters,
curse the player,
or add environmental hazards like turrets or trap runes.
In this case, we will be picking shocking turrets.
As you enter the room,
the Trial Master will fill it with hazards
to test your commitment.
In this case,
you must destroy all the monsters that fill the room
while dealing with the lightning projectiles
from the shocking turrets.
After each room,
you will need to make a choice.
Take the rewards you have earned so far
or go double or nothing.
Increase your rewards,
but take on more risk.
Each tribulation you add is minor on its own,
but they quickly stack on top of each other
and can become overwhelming.
There are many types of chambers in the Trial.
Each will test your resolve in different ways.
This one simply requires you survive
for a certain amount of time.
Another requires you to escort the Stone Idol
through the level
as elevators full of monsters descend to attack you.
Should you be able to get through the first three chambers,
you will face your first boss.
The order of the bosses is random,
and combined with the tribulations you have selected,
the fight will never feel the same.
After defeating the boss,
you may claim your rewards.
Of course there are the items,
but you also gain the right to ascend.
If you already did the Trial of the Sekamers,
then you can claim two more points
to add to your ascendancy class.
Now it's possible to go much deeper.
There are more bosses,
rewards and risks to take,
but we'll talk more about that
when we get to Endgame.
So how about we talk about that now?
So far, we've only been showing you
footage from the campaign,
but some people would argue that the endgame
is where the game truly begins.
Something that happens almost every time
a new action RPG launches is people saying,
there isn't enough endgame content.
Well, we want to make sure that in PoE 2,
people don't feel that way,
and we actually only changed our development priority
for this recently.
The first three acts of PoE 2 already take around 25 hours
to complete if you're a new player.
This is already a pretty significant campaign.
On the other hand,
people spend hundreds of hours in Endgame each league.
We realized that finishing the rest of the campaign
for early access was actually a bad idea.
Instead of having acts 4 to 6 in early access,
we could concentrate on Endgame and make that great.
For new players,
a 25-hour campaign is already a huge game
with lots of content.
But for existing action RPG players,
what you mostly care about
is all the endgame challenges to overcome.
So several months ago,
we switched the entire development team's focus
over to making endgame content.
At the start of early access,
there'll be 50 bosses and around 400 monster types.
But the great thing is
that the rest of the game is like 80% there.
We'll be adding content to roughly double the size of the game
during early access and into release.
Now, in order to make the endgame happen
at the same character level
as what it would be after we added the rest of the acts,
we've added a second difficulty level called Cruel,
where you repeat the campaign
with all the monsters and bosses leveled up.
And of course, new rewards.
You can kind of think of it as like a new game plus.
It's also a lot faster to get through the content
the second time as your clear speed increases.
That will take you to around level 65,
where the endgame begins.
Once we add the remaining three acts,
we'll be removing Cruel difficulty,
so you'll progress straight from the end of Act 6
to endgame.
But what is the endgame?
To explain that, I'll hand over to Mark.
He can tell you all about it.
Hi, I'm Mark Roberts,
game director on Path of Exile 2.
Well, one thing that Path of Exile is known for
is having a lot of distinct endgame content
to choose between.
Each endgame mechanic needs to have its own
progression system, areas, bosses, rewards,
and player power that can only be gained from that content.
We are going to be adding a lot more over time,
but for Path of Exile 2, we decided to start with
seven distinct systems you can progress through.
This is the Atlas,
and it serves as the core of the endgame for Path of Exile 2.
It's infinite and expands in all directions.
Now, we are not going to spoil the plot too much here,
but corruption from the beast has blighted the land,
and your objective is to help fight it.
In the center of the Atlas, you will find the Ziggurat,
a temple in which the Val research the fundamentals of space and time.
Here, we can open portals to nearby locations,
and begin cleansing corruption and finding resources.
In order to power the portal device, we will need waystones.
Each waystone has a tier,
which will determine the level of the monsters that you will face.
To go to an area, simply click one that is adjacent to an area
that you have already completed.
Insert the waystone and click Traverse.
Portals will open, allowing you and your party
to travel to the area you have selected.
All the areas in the endgame feel distinct
from the locations in the campaign,
and we have dialed the randomization up to 11.
The monster packs you will face in each map are totally random,
and the combination of them can lead
to some very interesting combat situations.
There are over 400 monster types in early access,
and they have a lot of varied and interesting abilities.
Depending on which combinations you face,
you might find some serious challenges.
In order to cleanse the corruption from the area,
you will need to defeat all the powerful rare
and unique enemies in it.
Once you have done that,
the area will be marked as completed,
and you will be able to travel past it
to progress deeper into the world.
If you die, then the map can no longer be run,
and you will have to find another way around
to get to the areas behind it.
There are also all kinds of other random encounters
you might run into as you play maps.
One such encounter are Precursor Artifacts.
These are ancient, corrupting monuments
that irradiate the monsters around them.
The monsters that feed off the corruption
are drawn to their power.
If you defeat the monsters and cleanse the artifact,
you will get a powerful temporary buff.
Some of the buffs make you faster,
others rain lightning or fire around you,
and some even give you increased experience
or help you find better items.
You can also find Strongboxes.
These enigmatic chests guard piles of treasure,
but are always a trap.
Monsters lie in wait to attack you
the moment you open it,
and the boxes often have mechanisms
to unleash powerful spells or dangerous debuffs.
There are different types of Strongboxes
containing different items,
and you can even use your currency items
to craft them on the fly,
so you can optimize the content.
But be careful of opening one you can't handle.
Sometimes you'll discover monsters frozen in essences,
solidified crystalline corruption.
These dangerous monsters can be broken free.
If you defeat them,
the essence they drop can be used
to upgrade normal items to magic items
with a guaranteed mod from a category.
For example,
we could use this one on some boats
to ensure a movement speed mod.
Rarely, essences will also drop
that allow you to upgrade magics to rares,
adding the guaranteed mod.
This is incredibly powerful,
since it allows you to get a second deterministic mod
in your crafting projects.
Combining these with the currencies
that are commonly found in Rayclassed
for modifying items,
and we can get a very nice pair of boots indeed.
Waystones, like all items,
can also be crafted using your currency items.
Adding prefix mods will improve the rewards,
while suffix mods increase danger.
The more dangerous a map is,
the more waystones will drop.
Adding mods to your waystones is key
to progressing to higher tiers
and sustaining them,
but it will require you
to take on larger challenges.
There are a variety of factors
you have to consider
when crafting your waystones.
Some maps will have higher density,
some lower,
some have more magic and rare chests,
or monsters,
some are more linear,
and others more open.
Make sure you explore
and think about what makes certain maps good
if you want to maximize your returns.
As you cleanse corruption
from higher and higher tiers of the Atlas,
you will gain points
that you can spend in the Atlas tree.
This tree allows you to juice the danger
and rewards of all areas in the endgame.
You could increase the number of monsters,
the number of rares,
the number of precursor artifacts or strongboxes,
even the quantity of item drops.
As you explore the endgame world map,
you'll notice various different biomes,
from snow-capped mountains
to dense jungle valleys.
Most maps are restricted to certain biomes.
As you continue to explore deeper into the Atlas,
there are all sorts of things to discover.
These cities are constructed
by different peoples of Rhaeclast,
and have specific items that can be found there.
These strange structures marked on the map
don't appear to do anything for now.
Perhaps you'll work out how to use them later.
You might find unique maps
like Untainted Paradise,
an undisturbed island full of beasts
that give an extreme amount of experience.
You may even find a lonely man
just enjoying his retirement
who will give you a unique item for free.
In addition, you can find special areas
that would make a good spot to set up camp.
Clear these areas of their hostile inhabitants,
and you'll be able to claim them as your own hideout.
You can decorate your hideout as you see fit,
and invite various NPCs to join you there
to create your own personal base of operations.
A great tool for exploration are towers.
These mysterious precursor constructs
are dotted around the Atlas.
Completing the tower will reveal a large area around it,
allowing you to scout out your next challenge.
There are lots of things to find,
so keep looking.
Some sections of your Atlas
are influenced by corruption.
This adds extra modifiers to the maps in the region,
increasing difficulty and rewards.
Here, slaying monsters in close proximity to each other
will cause the vestiges of corruption within them
to merge together,
forming powerful and grotesque abominations.
You may have noticed while looking at the Atlas
that some of the areas have these icons above them.
The icon indicates that the area contains some kind of special encounter.
This icon indicates that the area has a powerful boss.
Because only one in four maps contain a map boss,
we are able to make them very powerful and very rewarding.
These bosses come from the campaign,
but have had their difficulty increased
with changes to AI and some of their abilities.
It's worth noting that because you can see where the bosses are,
you can choose to take them on or avoid them.
If you do choose to hunt bosses though,
then you will be rewarded with special points
for the boss hunting section of the Atlas skill tree.
The points here will allow you to specialise in boss killing,
giving you much greater rewards for defeating them.
For each different type of content in the endgame,
we are adding specialised trees
in order to make it so you don't feel the need
to respec your points
when you change between different types of content.
We will be showing you seven of these
by the end of this presentation,
so there is still a lot more to come.
Bosses are not the only icon you will see on the Atlas.
Let's take a look at one of the endgame systems,
Breach.
If you played PoE 1,
you might be familiar with Breach.
For PoE 2,
we have created sequels to several PoE 1 leagues.
While the mechanic is familiar,
the monsters, bosses, rewards,
and progression are all new.
A Breach is a tear in the fabric of reality.
Opening it will allow you to see the demons
and otherworldly monstrosities
that lie in wait on this other plane of existence.
By engaging with a Breach,
you'll create a bridge between their world and Rayclast.
In order to keep the Breach open,
you will need to kill the demons that pour forth.
The faster you can kill the monsters,
the more monsters you will fight,
and the more loot you will find.
You can also find clasped hands
that will open and drop more items
if you run over them.
These can be a good boost to the rewards of the Breach,
so keep an eye on them.
One of the rewards that you may find
while fighting monsters from Breach are tablets.
Tablets are special items
that can be used with Precursor Towers
to add more encounters to the Atlas.
Breaches will drop Breach tablets.
Clicking on a completed tower
will allow you to consume the tablet
to add more breaches to areas
within range of the tower.
This makes all the content in the Atlas self-sustaining.
Want to do more breaches?
Find the tablets, add them to your towers,
get more breaches, getting more tablets.
Soon, your Atlas will be covered in otherworldly domains.
In addition, like all items in PoE,
you can craft them.
Use your currency to add mods to your tablets,
allowing you to upgrade all the Breaches in range.
Tablets can have up to two mods.
These mods do things like adding extra rare monsters,
extra clasped hands,
or even mods to density of Breaches,
allowing you to keep them open longer.
Often, you will find multiple towers near to each other
with overlapping areas of effect.
This can allow you to really juice the mechanic
by stacking the mods from multiple tablets.
In your fight to hold the Breach demons at bay,
you may want to use the powers of their world against them.
Each endgame mechanic always has player power
that can only be gained from that mechanic,
and Breach is no different.
In Breach, you will find Catalysts,
items that can increase the quality of rings and amulets
by improving specific mods.
You can also find Breach Rings,
a special base type that can have its quality improved
by Catalysts up to 50%.
In this case, you could create a ring with around 170 life.
Breach Rings can become some of the strongest rings in the game,
giving you some good motivation to face the Demon Horns.
In addition, each endgame mechanic
needs to have a pinnacle endgame encounter.
While killing Breach monsters,
you may find Breach Splinters.
Collect enough of these,
and you'll be able to create a Breach Stone.
Using a vile technology called the Realm Gate,
you can use your Breach Stone to access their domain
and bring the fight to them.
In this twisted domain,
you will find nothing but a single massive Breach.
Triggering it will reveal hordes of Breach inhabitants.
And should you be fast enough,
you will be able to fight their leader,
zisht,
we that are one.
We that dreamed,
we in nightmare,
we that are one.
Fate relies truth.
This is just one of the pinnacle encounters of PoE 2.
We won't be showing the rest of them,
so you will have to discover them for yourself.
But rest assured,
this is some of the hardest content we have ever made.
All these encounters have specific uniques,
they can only be found from them.
But that's not all.
We still have the progression system.
Defeating zisht will give you points to allocate
into the Breach section of the Atlas Tree.
Allocating these points will make Breaches
and the Breach Domain even harder,
but will give you more rewards.
The small nodes will increase the difficulty of the Twisted Domain,
while the large nodes have more specific bonuses.
For example,
this node adds more clasped hands to your Breaches,
and adds a pack of magic monsters that can guard them.
Get some more points,
and you can allocate Waking Nightmare,
which will double the number of splinters you get from clasped hands,
and inflict you with a mysterious debunk.
In order to earn more points,
you will need to defeat zisht at a higher difficulty,
and some rewards from zisht can only be found
by increasing the difficulty of the Twisted Domain
above certain thresholds.
Defeating zisht at difficulty 4 will be a challenge indeed,
but there are many more threats in Breach last.
Ritual altars are sacrificial sites
built by the mysterious King in the Mists.
If you encounter this symbol on the Atlas,
then you know that the area contains ritual altars.
Ritual altars demand tribute.
Every monster you slaughter in the circle will feed the altar.
After the sacrifice, touch it to begin the ritual.
The monsters you just killed will be resurrected
by the King of the Mists' dark magic,
and you must fight to survive.
The tribute you have offered to the altar
can be spent to buy powerful items,
but they can be expensive.
To gain more tribute,
you will want to find more altars.
Each successive ritual you do within an area
will spawn the monsters revived by the previous ones,
in addition to the ones you sacrificed next to them.
By the end of an area,
you will be fighting a truly imposing number of foes,
but will have a significant amount of tribute to spend.
One of the rewards you can buy with tribute are omens.
These are special items that allow for metacrafting.
Crafting items that affect other crafting items.
Have an item with good prefixes but bad suffixes?
This omen will help you to remove the mods you don't want,
while keeping the ones you do.
There are a bunch more of these with different effects,
but we will leave them for you to discover.
Now don't forget that Ritual will also drop tablets,
which can be used to specialise into getting more rituals.
If you want to get to the pinnacle boss of Ritual,
then you will probably want to use them.
They can also be crafted to grant mods,
making your rituals more rewarding.
The pinnacle encounter of Ritual is
The King in the Mists.
Feared by the Asmiri people,
he is said to have brought eternal darkness to the Wildwood.
We won't show the encounter,
but just like Breach,
there are a range of unique items you can get for defeating him,
and you will gain points in the Ritual section of the Atlas Tree.
Some maps have been touched by insanity.
A mysterious entity has taken a special interest in you.
Step through the looking glass,
and you will find your nightmares coming to life.
When you touch a mirror,
the mists of Delirium will spread out across the area,
infecting your mind.
You must stay within the mist to maintain the nightmare,
which is as profitable as it is terrifying.
Everything you kill will increase the rewards that drop.
However, the deeper into the mist you travel,
the stronger the monsters are.
Be careful not to overstay your welcome.
Rare and unique enemies will become vessels for terrifying demons,
who will manifest out of them to unleash powerful attacks on you.
The mist also offers a strange crafting material,
Distilled Emotions.
By combining these emotions,
you are able to instill your amulet
with a notable from the passive skill tree.
This is like gaining an extra passive point for free,
attached to your gear.
They are also particularly great,
because you don't have to traverse the tree to get them,
allowing you to get off-class bonuses
that would normally be much harder to get.
Distilled Emotions can also be used
to instill your endgame maps,
applying Delirious to them,
and adding additional difficulty and rewards,
allowing you to further juice your endgame maps.
The tablets you can find from Delirious
can be used to further improve it,
increase pack size,
make the fog dissipate slower,
or improve your progress
towards the pinnacle encounter of Delirious.
Speaking of which,
every now and then you will find
Simulacrum Splinters.
The mysterious entity will create strange encounters
based on warped versions of your own memories.
Monsters and Simulacrums come in waves
that get progressively more difficult.
You will receive loot at the end of each wave,
and you will have to make the decision to leave now,
or continue on,
facing up against even tougher foes from the mist.
The bosses you will face
as you get deeper into a Simulacrum
are truly terrifying.
If you can complete a Simulacrum,
you will gain points for the Delirium section
of the Atlas skill tree.
Next up, we have Expedition.
Occasionally, while clearing Corruption,
you will encounter these Kalgurin settlers.
The Kalgurins have discovered ancient burial sites
with lost varicium artifacts,
and they want you to help dig them up
with explosives.
The Kalgurins have marked the locations
where the relics can be found.
Place explosives as best you can
to dig up as many as possible.
There is just one problem.
Corruption has brought the corpses
of their ancestors to life,
so you might have to do a little clean-up
before you can reclaim the artifacts.
You can also find Remnants,
the destruction of which
will further anger the restless dead.
Each one you blow up
will make the subsequent monsters
more powerful,
but also more rewarding.
Danig,
Rog,
Tujan,
and Gwennon
will exchange the artifacts
for useful items
and runic magic.
You can also find tablets
to increase the number of expeditions
and the rewards.
This one increases the radius of explosives,
while this one increases
the number of remnants you will find.
Eventually, you might discover a logbook.
These are special maps
full of buried treasure and relics,
essentially one giant dig site.
Here, you can create an extremely long chain of explosives
and go through a very high number of remnants,
but be careful.
Many remnants have mods
that can really brick your build,
so you will probably want to avoid these ones.
If you add too many remnants,
you could easily make the encounter
harder than you can handle.
There are all sorts of interesting things
buried under the ground in logbooks.
You might find dripping caves
and hidden pirate caches,
but the most powerful encounter is Ulroth,
the ancient undead commander
of the Knights of the Sun.
Defeating him will grant you unique rewards,
as well as points to spend
in the expedition section of the Atlas tree.
So those are the endgame systems on the Atlas,
but we are not done yet.
The trials we talked about earlier
have much more content
when you get to endgame too.
Just like the other endgame systems,
they also have progression mechanics,
unique rewards,
and player power
that can only be gained from them.
As you get higher level coins
for the trial of the Sekimers,
you will unlock more floors to explore.
Each floor has its own challenging brooms
and a floor boss that you will need to kill.
There are four floors in total,
leading to another pinnacle boss
at the end of the last floor,
which can only be accessed at endgame.
The trial of the Sekimers
is where you'll find duels,
which you can socket into your tree.
These are like passives
that you can craft with your currency items.
They can be really powerful,
as they allow you to stack modifiers
that may not be easily accessible
on the tree normally.
This duel gives lightning damage
and shock chance, for example.
There are quite a few duel sockets
on the tree,
so it's possible to gain a lot of power here.
There are also other types of duels
that don't provide any bonuses themselves,
but affect other passives surrounding them.
This duel increases the effect
of small nodes and radius by 25%.
With careful placement in the tree,
you could get a significant amount of power from it.
There are also unique duels available
with very interesting effects,
but you will have to find those for yourself.
In order to push further into the trial
and uncover the secrets of the Marakev,
you will want to take advantage
of its progression system, relics.
Relics are items that can be placed
in the Relic Altar as you start the trial.
They give special bonuses that affect the trial,
making it easier and increasing its rewards.
Of course, you can craft these
with your currency items,
making them even stronger.
If you can complete the entire trial,
overcoming all four flaws,
the final boss will reward you
with one of many unique relics.
These relics will be consumed
when used on your next run,
but can reward you with unique
and powerful items.
For example, this is the Last Flame.
If you use it,
you will have only one honor
for the entire trial,
so you will need to do
a completely hitless run.
The Trial of Chaos
also extends into the endgame.
As you gain inscribed ultimatums
of higher and higher levels,
the number of chambers
that you can go through increases.
In true Vaal style,
this allows you to take even more risks
for even more rewards.
At endgame, you can progress
through up to 10 chambers
with three bosses on a single run,
stacking 10 tribulations
on top of each other
will make this a significant challenge,
but it's worth it.
The Trial Master will tempt you
with items of the Vaal Empire,
such as Vaal Orbs.
Vaal Orbs are powerful crafting items
that corrupt your gear
with random mysterious outcomes.
Corruption prevents an item
from being modified further,
so it has to be the last step
of your craft,
but it's also the most impactful one.
For example,
if you use one on your body armor,
it might add a new powerful enchantment,
or it might re-roll up to half
of its modifiers.
Vaal Orbs also have the ability
to add a socket,
allowing you to bypass
the normal restriction
of how many sockets an item can have.
A body armor could get up
to three sockets this way,
allowing for a significant number of mods.
Vaal Orbs can even modify uniques.
Adding enchantments or sockets to uniques
can make them incredibly powerful,
but there is a good chance
that you will break them as well.
The Trial Master will also
occasionally offer you Soul Cores.
Originally formed by Chaos,
the Vaal sought to replicate Soul Cores
through human sacrifice rituals
and blood magic to power their civilization.
Soul Cores are powerful socketable items,
with mods that cannot be obtained
from regular runes.
Like all endgame content,
there is of course a pinnacle boss.
The final chamber will drop keys
to this mysterious door.
Some say this is where
the Trial Master himself resides.
Perhaps you are willing
to take the risk to find out.
Had enough yet?
Because there is still just one more thing.
The most difficult content
in Path of Exile 2.
While mapping,
you might come across this fortress
that has emerged from underground,
surrounded by an enormous maze
riddled with danger.
Is the maze preventing something
from getting in?
Or something getting out?
This fortress is of ancient origin
and its construction has similarities
to the towers and tablets
that you have been using
on your journey through the endgame.
It is clear from the entrance
that there are three keys required to enter.
Local factions are vying
for access to the fortress
in order to seize the power
they believe will be inside.
Each of the faction's leaders
have managed to get their hands
on one of the keys,
so you will need to defeat them.
Each faction is led by an Uber Act boss.
You can see one of them
inhabiting the city,
but in order to fight him,
you will first need to defeat
their two lieutenants
in the adjacent zones.
Be careful.
If you fail against
either of the lieutenants
or to kill the leader,
they will move on
and you will need to find them again.
Kill all the Uber bosses
and you will gain access
to the fortress.
We aren't going to spoil it
as we can't wait to see you guys
attempt it for the first time.
But is there a tree you get points in
after killing it?
Of course there is.
This is Path of Exile.
There is always another tree.
So these are your challenges
for PoE 2.
As you can see,
this project is crazy huge.
Way bigger than even we expected
when we started out.
But how do you gain access?
Well, during early access,
you'll need a key to get in.
To thank our existing PoE supporters
who have spent more than $480 US dollars,
we'll be giving you guys a key
for the PC version for free.
Anyone else who wants one
can get one by purchasing
one of the new early access supporter packs
that have just been released to the store.
If you just want early access to PoE 2,
then you can get a key
in the $30 US dollar early access pack.
The pack also comes with $30 of points
to spend in the MTX store.
But we also have a variety
of other supporter packs
filled with exclusive microtransactions,
points to spend in the store,
and even physical items.
The cosmetics can be used right now
in PoE 1 and in Path of Exile 2
when early access starts.
Most of this footage has been recorded
in Path of Exile 1,
since that's where you can use them immediately.
The Lord of Ogham supporter pack
contains a cosmetic armor set
befitting of the Count of Ogham himself.
There is also a matching back attachment
which has an alternate variant
depicting the influence of corruption.
Also in this pack,
you can find a portal
formed of the rusted armor
of the fallen soldiers
in the Red Veil of Ogham,
and the offspring of a vicious crowbell boss
found in the hunting grounds.
This one doesn't look so vicious though.
On top of that,
you'll receive the Iron Counts Zwei-Hander
to apply to your one-handed
or two-handed swords.
For those who are wanting
to decorate your hideouts
with fond memories and tales
of Path of Exile's history,
you will also get a series
of hideout statues.
This pack contains
the statue of Hillock.
For Path of Exile 1's closed beta,
each pack contained
a true New Zealand icon,
the Kiwi.
Following this tradition,
all packs in this series
will also contain
a new themed Kiwi pet.
The pet will loyally
follow you into battle,
but run away
at the first sign of trouble.
Become the ruler of the desert
with the King of the Faridans
supporter pack.
Show your mastery
of traversing the sands
of the Vasteri plains.
The body armor will allow you
to glide along the ground
with ancient sand magic.
Now, each armor set
comes with body armor,
boots, gloves, and helmet,
but the boots are covered in sand.
If you'd prefer to show them off,
you can turn the gliding off
if you want.
The accompanying back attachment
equips you with two powerful pillars
that can control
and manipulate lightning.
They will periodically
release their energy
in a powerful blast
while in town
and hover in a circle around you,
arcing lightning between them
forming a barrier of energy.
Replace the appearance
of any bow
with the Faridans' glory skin.
Or replace the appearance
of a spear
with the Tyranny's end spear skin.
This spear skin can be applied
to staves and war staves
in Path of Exile 1.
If you want to truly show your worth
as a king of the Faridun,
then you definitely need
your trusty, moving,
entire city fortress
known as the Dreadnaught
to travel across
the Vasteri plains.
In Path of Exile,
you can decorate your hideout
however you like,
and it's no exception here.
It comes with a variety
of thematic elements to use,
or use decorations
from elsewhere in the game.
Additionally,
you will get the Deshret's
Blessing level-up effect.
The King of the Faridun Kiwi Pet.
And last but not least,
a statue depicting
the Varl Oversoul
from Path of Exile 1.
For those who don't know
how supporter packs work,
each pack comes with
all of the cosmetics
from the previous tier,
so you will get all the items
from the Lord of Ogham
supporter pack as well.
The Thaumaturge of the Varl
supporter pack features
an armor set
and back attachment
themed around the Varl
and their pursuit of science
and progress.
You can find the
Soulcore weapon effect
in this pack,
which causes
Thaumaturgic energy
harnessed from Sacrifice
to spill from your weapon.
This pack also contains
Dooyani's Idol.
It replaces the default
appearance of any foci
to an ancient relic
once used by Dooyani,
and this can be applied
to shields in Path of Exile 1.
That's not the only
Varl weapon you'll find.
It also contains
the Wand of the Thaumaturge skin
and the Royal Sacrifice dagger skin.
You wouldn't think
to put sacrificial gems
on a Kiwi,
but the Varl did.
Thaumaturge of the Varl
supporters will receive
the Thaumaturge of the Varl
Kiwi pet
and the Statue of Dominus.
This is also the first pack
in the series
with a physical item.
When purchasing this pack,
you'll receive
a Path of Exile 2
logo t-shirt,
but if you don't want one,
you can opt out
and return for additional points
to spend in the store.
Becoming a Warlord
of the Kaorui supporter
will grant you
an armour set
and back attachment
adorned in jade carvings
and iridescent feathers
resembling power.
Enough to even impress
the ancestral gods,
specifically Tukuhama,
the Kaorui god of war.
Overkill, you say?
I think the Kaorui people
would disagree.
Why not drop
a gigantic totem
on rare enemies you slay
to crush them to a pulp?
Replace your crafting bench
in your hideout
with the Ancestral Canoe
crafting bench,
where Ancestral Chief
Mata will summon
a giant canoe
manned by Kaorui warriors
to aid in your crafting desires.
We must all start somewhere.
You'll also get
a pair of weapon skins.
Equip Akoya's
Failing Axe skin
to your one-hand
or two-handed axes,
or Tukuhama's Crusher
to your one-handed
or two-handed maces.
A true Kaorui warlord
is always accompanied
by their trusty Kiwi.
Equipped with armour
and harnessing
ancestral magic,
they make the perfect sidekick.
Once one of the most feared
beings in Wraeclast,
Malachi was slain
by a powerful exile.
May the statue commemorate
the virtue of exile's past,
present,
and of the future.
Of course,
it's not all about
dressing up in game.
You'll want to look good
in real life too.
By becoming a
Warlord of the Kaorui supporter,
you'll also get
a Path of Exile 2 hoodie.
Our final tier
of supporter pack
in this series
is the Liberator of Rhaeclast
supporter pack.
The Liberator of Rhaeclast
armour set
and back attachment
come made
with the finest materials
in Rhaeclast
and shattered glass mosaics
suspended in divine power.
Set up your base of operations
in the Beacon of Salvation hideout.
Why restrict yourself
to just one island
when you can liberate more?
The Beacon of Salvation hideout
comes equipped
with your own collection
of small islands
and personal operators
of boats
that you can use
to row between them.
Just walk to the piers,
click a boat to enter
and navigate as you choose.
Decorate each island
as you see fit
to best represent
your well-earned hideout.
Everyone in your hideout
can use their own boat.
Why not have some races?
You can also get
the Window to Twilight
portal effect,
a beautiful mosaic
piece of art
that shatters
and reveals a gateway
to your desired destination
as you approach it.
As you walk away,
the glass magically reforms
back to its original form.
Rule in style
with the Throne of the Ruler
map device.
Sure,
this map device
can create portals
to endgame maps,
but it also comes
with a throne
you can sit on
to oversee
your growing kingdom.
Look down
on the plebeians
running your maps.
Being the Liberator,
though,
is not just about
sitting in your throne all day.
If you do decide
to join the fight yourself,
you can leave
a High Priest in charge
as your second-in-command.
Liberator of Rhaeclast supporters
will also get a set
of varied weapon skins.
The Light of Divinity
Scepter skin,
the Deliverance
Crossbow skin,
the Justice Flail skin,
and the Redemption
Shield skin.
Once again,
you'll have
an accompanying Kiwi
and of course a statue
depicting one of the most
iconic events
in Rhaeclast's history.
The battle between
a powerful exile
and Kitava,
the Insatiable.
With the help of two deities,
Sin and Innocence,
the exile was able
to defeat him
once and for all.
This supporter pack
also contains
the Path of Exile 2 artbook.
This 215-page,
full-colour artbook
includes a huge amount
of amazing concept art
and lore
produced during the long
and exciting journey
of Path of Exile 2's development.
And finally,
Path of Exile has a tradition
of letting the community
participate in designing
game features.
For Path of Exile 2,
we'll be adding
the Twilight Order
foil reliquary.
By becoming a liberator
of Rayclass supporter,
once Path of Exile 2
is released,
you'll be able to select
any unique item
you have found
and be able to drop it
from the reliquary.
Once players have
submitted their items,
keys to the reliquary
will start dropping
and other players
will be able to find
foil versions of uniques
that you have submitted
along with a message
for the lucky player.
The more players
submit the same unique,
the more chances there will be
for the reliquary
to drop them,
so choose wisely.
Now, almost all of these items
are available to use
in PoE 1 right now.
There are a few exceptions
where the item class
clearly doesn't exist,
such as crossbows or flails,
and there are also
a few microtransactions
on weapon types
that are unavailable
in PoE 2 at the start
of early access.
Once classes that use
those weapon types
are added,
those microtransactions
will be available to use.
If you can't decide
which supporter pack
to choose yet,
you can always start
with the early access
supporter pack
that just includes a key
and some points to spend
in the store.
Then you can upgrade
to any of the following tiers
at a later date.
These supporter packs
will be available for purchase
throughout early access.
We'd really like to thank you
for your ongoing support.
Without you guys,
Path of Exile 2
could not have happened.
Now, I'm sure you guys
have a lot of questions.
Stick around,
because coming up next
we have a live Q&A
with Ziggy D.
To the post-show discussion
and Q&A.
I hope you all enjoyed
what you've seen so far.
It's been pretty exciting
for us here as well
as you guys have been
inspired already
just watching things
and already cooking
a new ascendancy class.
Yeah, for sure.
You've got to do design
whenever you can.
Yeah, yeah.
Absolutely.
There's been a few
fun moments here already.
But I'm your host,
Ziggy D,
and I'm joined by
Jonathan and Mark
to talk about
everything you've seen.
Honestly, it's so much.
I mean, we were really keen
to make sure
that when we went
into early access
that people didn't feel
like it was just,
you know, limping along
and kind of, you know,
just like a minimal amount
of content.
We really wanted to
kind of blow people away.
So hopefully people feel like,
yeah, there is enough content
because, yeah,
it was certainly a mission
to get all that stuff in.
Yeah, I did come here
expecting that there would be,
you know,
maybe a basic mapping
placeholder endgame
and your three acts
and, you know,
the half the classes.
But you've made a decision here,
clearly,
that's got to go
the core POE player community
in mind.
Absolutely.
So, I mean,
we have to make sure,
like, I mean, look,
Path of Exile's endgame
is kind of known
for the fact
that you get to choose
between different types
of content
and that, like,
you know,
some people enjoy one thing,
some people enjoy another.
And I feel like that choice
is like a huge part
of what makes it good.
So if we didn't have that
when we entered endgame,
then I don't think
that would be,
you know,
like,
that wouldn't be
a Path of Exile endgame.
So that's kind of
what we have to make sure of.
So we kind of said,
okay,
well, like,
what is the minimum number
of, like,
different endgame things
you need to be able to have
in order to be able
to actually have a viable
endgame that you feel
like you get different choices?
And that's how we ended up
with what we have here.
I definitely feel like
a lot of games nowadays
release, you know,
and their campaign's intact
and real good.
You get to the endgame
and it just falls real flat.
Yeah.
And it was certainly
a very important moment
for us when we were like,
hold on,
that's the wrong thing to do.
Like,
let's not make the same mistake
as everyone else.
Let's pivot.
And we actually did that
and, like,
it made a world of difference
and made the game
all of a sudden,
you know,
a hundred times bigger
with an infinite amount
of more content, right?
It was definitely hard, though,
because, like,
okay,
so we're, you know,
we're progressing.
It's like,
we would have made it.
We would have gotten,
you know,
all these acts in
if we hadn't have changed direction.
It's like,
to actually say,
you know what,
we're going to specifically
not finish this content
we'll be working on,
you know,
that we,
it's like,
pens down everyone.
We're stopping work on this.
We're going to move over to endgame
because it's actually more important.
Like,
that was certainly a hard one.
That would have been
some whiplash there,
I imagine.
For sure.
I mean,
it's like suddenly the whole,
you know,
like,
environment art team,
it's like,
you know,
they're all just like,
whatever you're working on,
just scrap.
You know,
not scrap,
but,
you know,
just stop it.
We're doing something else now.
Saving clothes,
yeah.
Especially for a lot of the developers
because you've got to also think,
like,
a lot of our developers
have just been working on this campaign
for,
what is it now,
six years.
I think it's even longer,
actually.
Yeah,
it's like,
it's just this epic journey
whereas none of them,
you know,
a lot of these people
haven't been working on Path of XL1
this whole time.
So,
some of us are like,
you know,
we're just churning out endgame
with every league
and doing all of that
but for a lot of these people,
a lot of these developers,
yeah,
it was quite jarring to swap over
but everyone embraced it,
you know,
we talked about it,
everyone was happy about it
and stoked about it
and it just ended up
coming out real awesome,
so.
I think it's landed well
and it definitely
kind of blew me away
when you,
even before I saw anything,
we were in the car
on the drive here
and you were just
info dumping
all of the endgame
and you're like,
oh,
we got this feature,
we got this feature.
I'm getting dopamine
just from hearing about it.
I haven't even seen anything yet.
But do you guys feel like
you're competing against yourselves
a little bit here
because Path of Exile
has kind of set the bar,
the original game
has set the bar
for what is available
to endgame
in a game like this
and it makes,
it's not acceptable really
to launch with just nothing
in terms of endgame now.
Absolutely.
I mean,
yeah,
like if you're not competing
with yourself,
then I don't think
you're going to make
good progress,
right?
So that's what you
really have to do.
Yeah,
but cracking that out
for beta even.
Absolutely.
I just think it would not
have landed nearly as well
without that
and I think
it's important
that our existing
Path of Exile 1 community
feels like
they're also served.
like,
yeah,
sure,
we're doing all this
stuff for new players
and that's really important
and that'll expand
the audience
but,
you know,
if we launched
and all the PeeWee 1
players are unhappy,
that wouldn't be good.
So,
you know,
we have to make sure
that they also feel
like,
you know,
they've got a game
for both them
and for all the new
players we hope
to bring to the genre.
And you definitely want
all those different axes
as well.
Like,
just having two,
right,
you'll get a lot of,
a lot of content
can be immediately divisive,
right?
Obviously,
that's the nature of it.
That's how it goes,
different players
who like different types
of content.
Yeah.
So,
if you're just like,
here's your one end game system,
well,
immediately then there is
a portion of players
who are just like,
I don't want this,
right?
And so,
having all of these options
is like,
ultra key
and that is what
Path of Exile 1
has taught us.
And again,
it's like,
I'd say lessons learned,
you know,
for the genre
and it is expanding
in other games and stuff
but,
yeah,
certainly as you said,
competing with ourselves,
yes,
PeeWee 1 has like,
you know,
40 axes,
and we've got,
seven really good ones here
and obviously more to come
but seven is a lot,
mind you.
Especially when it's all like,
you know,
like people have to learn
a lot of things again.
It's going to be very interesting
to see how long it takes
people to do the kind of
difficulty for Pinnacle content.
Oh,
yeah,
yeah.
It's like,
we have to,
it's honestly like,
we actually don't even really know
because like,
you never know what people
are going to find
in terms of builds and so on.
Like,
I'm hoping that it will take
people a while
to be able to work it out
but,
you know,
you never know.
Maybe end of day one
people just like,
oh yeah,
easy,
no problem,
mate,
you know,
could be what it's like.
A few people that are doing
that sort of thing,
I saw like a solid cell phone
level 100 in 24 hours
or something.
Jeez,
okay,
this is where we've got it now,
is it?
So,
I imagine there'll be a little bit
of a soft reset there for people.
Yeah,
for sure.
A relearning period.
There's stuff to learn.
And I mean,
PeeWee 2 has changed a lot
over the years,
so more than five years
of development now
and what was that initial pitch
when PeeWee 2 was first put forward
as to what it's going to be?
Because it was much smaller
in scope originally.
Yeah,
so when we started
it wasn't even a sequel,
it was just,
we're just updating
the character rigs
and over time
it kind of feature creeped
into a proper sequel.
But the thing that we were saying
is whenever we were talking about it,
and I guess this is the main thing,
is that we're like,
okay,
when we make an area here,
it needs to be
that there's like a theme for it
that feels unique
from everything else.
We're not going to just like
have recycled stuff
like within the campaign
that just feels like,
oh,
you know,
we just took this area
and modified it slightly.
You know,
each one's got to have its own stuff.
It's got to have monsters
that were like carefully thought about
that like,
you know,
fit in with the world
and it's got to have bosses
that are actually like
good tier quality,
you know,
and every area is going to have one.
And so those decisions
have kind of been things
that have meant that
like they really raised
the quality bar
to a level that took us
way longer
than we even really expected.
Like those things there,
just like they,
it's huge, right?
Like honestly,
I feel like we underestimated
significantly what it would take
to deliver that level of quality.
I remember really early on
a battle I fought for,
and I mean like way back,
was like,
if you think back to say Diablo 2,
which obviously still holds
a lot of,
you know,
power in terms of
design motivations
and philosophy
and stuff within the company,
you get things like
the super uniques
and POE 1 did them
and it's just like,
here's a boss
with one or two skills.
And I remember very,
very,
very early on in POE 2,
I'm like,
I want every single boss
to be memorable
and a thing.
I don't want a unique monster
that's just like,
dies in two seconds
and uses heavy strike
and has a fancy name.
And I remember,
I even got some push,
poor Caleb.
I remember getting some
pushback at the time
and thinking like,
you know,
I love the bosses,
my favorite part of everything.
And so I was just like,
man,
I really,
I don't want this.
This is just terrible.
And,
but of course,
that decision,
me pushing for that,
me wanting that,
turned into this
megalithic,
now we have 50,
aiming to be 100,
honestly,
probably later,
several more 100
once all the end games,
everything,
start to evolve
and more expansions
comes out.
And I'm like,
yep,
we maybe just made,
you know,
100 times more work
for ourselves,
but 100% bloody worthwhile
because I'd say
those bosses are one
of the main,
you know,
attraction pieces
of the game
and anyone who plays it
is just like,
holy crap,
those boss fights
are amazing.
So like,
you know,
obviously some are bad
and some are good
to different people
and all that.
That's how it all goes.
That's part of all the fun.
But it is true
that me pushing for that thing
literally created thousands
and thousands
of hours of work.
Now,
worthwhile work,
but it is again
that exact thing
of like,
the scope was kind of small
on numerous axes
and as we just raised
and raised the quality bar
to what we thought
was good,
it certainly went from,
you know,
what was it initially,
just reskinning
some character classes
and new rigs
or whatever
into this like,
mega scale
entire campaign.
Yeah,
everything.
Full standalone,
separate game.
Yeah.
Fun other anecdote
since we went out
of that territory.
It was originally
codenamed Project Chimera.
What?
I don't know.
It was this pipe dream.
I've never been a fan
of these codenames
by things like that.
It was this like,
there were times,
way back in the original Office,
there was all this like,
sometimes there'll be a feature
you can't really do
in Peewee 1
and it was always like,
ah,
we'll do it in Project Chimera.
That was like amongst
the developers
and people were like,
what the heck is that?
Now,
ironically,
there is a boss
in Act 3
called,
well,
it's got a different name
but it's called
the Chimera internally.
It is a Chimera.
It's a multi-headed beast
and you've seen it
in a few of the marketing
things here and here,
different trailers,
little snippets of it
and I think it's just ironic
that that was actually
the first boss asset made
before everything,
the first monster
because back in when
we used to just make
random monsters
and we'll find out
how to use them
and that was made
for that game.
It was used in the
original Peewee 2 trailer,
right?
It is the only incomplete,
technically,
only from a balance room
or it was the last boss
to finish in the entire
Path of Exile
to a game right now.
It sounds like there was
some sort of emotional demon
that you had to battle there
of the legacy
of the original idea
and you had to finish it.
We had a moment
with the monster game designers
where we're like,
oh my god,
it's happening,
the Chimera is finally
being finished.
Holy,
this is like,
yeah,
we were effectively like,
we need to celebrate
this boss finally being done.
It was like,
at the origin
and now it's at this,
you know,
point where we're about
to deploy early access,
you know,
not to say the end
because the end
is forever away.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's still the beginning
of a journey
in many ways.
Yep.
But on that note
of celebrating,
how do you guys feel
having now kind of,
for the first time,
I feel really like
laid bare,
kind of everything
you have,
you're putting it out there
and only being two weeks
away from everyone
playing it.
Well,
it's always scary,
you know,
coming into a release
and I think especially
for,
you know,
there's like,
a bunch of people
on the PeeWee 2 team
who have,
you know,
like they have,
this is their first game
that they're going
to be releasing
and that experience
is something that,
you know,
like,
yeah,
like it's tough
and honestly,
I think that even we
were feeling a little bit
cocky actually
about the fact
because,
you know,
we release,
content for PeeWee 1
all the time
and I feel like
we kind of felt
like we knew
what it took
to get a game released
but honestly,
like PeeWee 2
was just a whole
entirely different demon
as far as getting things
out right,
like it's just way
more difficult,
like when you actually
have to make everything,
like the whole freaking thing
right from the ground up again,
it's like,
wow,
there's way more stuff there
and like,
there's even things
like the passive tree
where it's like,
I feel like we underestimated
what it would take
to get something like that
to an actual releasable state,
like that was a huge amount
of work,
just like absolutely colossal
to get it to,
you know,
to get that kind of stuff
in shape,
like it's just been crazy.
So yeah,
like obviously it's nerve wracking,
you know,
coming up to a release day
but I think we do have something
that players are going
to really enjoy
and you know,
like it's always comforting
when,
you know,
I mean we had a live event
in LA recently,
you know,
people,
we got to the time limit
and everyone's like,
oh man,
we don't want to stop,
you know,
so I think people
are going to really enjoy it.
It's been a whole
different experience for me here
playing this time around as well
whereas before I was playing
a very buggy kind of
internal version of the game
that was very experimental
now playing,
you know,
almost what I'm going
to be playing.
Well I heard you still
managed to blow the count
up the elevator
with some kind of knockback bug.
I wasn't going to mention that.
Yeah,
we have to say,
we have to get that word.
I did send the Act 1 boss
up an elevator
with knockback,
it was good.
Intended mechanic.
I thought it was pretty funny.
He was in his like
big wolf form
and kind of trapped in there
so just barking at me
through the wood.
It's good.
So if you feel,
I'm sure there's a few
things to work out
over this next two weeks.
I hope the team can have
a little bit of a rest
for a day before they
get back into it.
Yeah.
It's been a lot.
So you've done that pivot
to the end game focus
and got so much for us now
to play around with
in the beta
and it seems like
originally I was thinking,
you know,
we might be playing
for a few weeks here
and then,
you know,
maybe going back over
to some part of Exile 1 stuff
but it seems like you guys
want us playing
through Christmas.
That would certainly be good.
Look,
there's enough stuff there
I think it will take people
a long time to get through.
And I mean,
obviously it's also
going to be the first time
people are playing
through a completely
fresh campaign as well.
I think that will take people
a fair amount of time.
So yeah,
there's,
and then of course
the end game as well
to explore.
I mean,
yeah,
it should be pretty significant.
I mean,
we've always wanted it to be
that Path of Exile 2
leagues,
you know,
are going to be,
like how P1 leagues are
where you play them
and you play them
for like,
you know,
a reasonable amount of time
and then,
you know,
sure,
you get done with them
eventually
and then you've got
the next content
that comes out.
So yeah,
in order to be able
to realize that
you have to have
enough of a base
to make that happen.
Yeah,
people are definitely
wondering like how
invested they can get
in the beta.
So I definitely want
to ask a few questions
kind of around that idea.
So firstly,
is there going to be
wipes and resets
and will there be
something before launch
as well?
So we are going to be
having new like leagues
effectively throughout the beta
whenever we launch
something significant
because,
you know,
we want to make sure
that all of the,
you know,
effectively that people
are able to play through.
But that stuff
will be merged
into an early access
league.
And effectively,
after we go into
full release,
that league will stick around.
Now,
I can't promise
that everything
about your character
will function exactly
like how it did
in that thing.
I imagine it will be
a glorious kind of
snapshot of all of the
broken stuff I have.
But effectively,
we can contain all that
stuff in the sort of
early access league.
And then if you still
want to play those
characters,
you know,
like then you can go
right ahead and do that.
But,
you know,
the action is always
going to be in
whatever the most
recent league is.
And then,
of course,
after that point,
there'll be a standard
that everything goes into,
which,
you know,
all our economic sins
will forevermore be
archived in the standard.
So,
yeah,
that's,
you know,
no doubt what will happen.
Well,
it's nice that it's,
A,
not going to be affecting
what will be the standard
league.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Also that people will be
able to kind of get
invested in their
characters.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
there's even something
kind of cool about the
idea of making something
that will be like that
little historical piece.
Absolutely.
A little collectible.
And I'm sure there'll be
some handful of legacy
things that only exist in
early access leagues.
So,
you know,
I guess we'll have to
see where it comes to
unique balance.
You talked about like
the,
you know,
playing for a week or
how long are we
expecting?
Well,
we sort of remember
and a lot of the,
you know,
a lot of the P.E.
1 players will be
thinking very differently
to people who are
obviously going to
experience this as a new
game,
but it is a new game,
right?
You don't have all
these predefined,
hyper refined builds
to play to immediately,
you know,
go through things.
You don't have people
coming in with like
fully detailed 7 million
line,
but with build guides
of exactly what to do
with what items.
the discovery is
going to be there.
The discovery takes
time and the discovery
is like honestly
ultra fun for me.
I love it.
Now,
those things will
emerge after time.
Of course,
they do completely
fine,
but you should remember
like there's a lot of
game to play here
to discover,
to learn,
learn about the world,
the new narratives,
the new world building,
the new unique items,
the ascendancy classes,
the massive passive tree,
which is bigger than
P.E.
1s,
the end game systems,
the bosses.
It's not going to be
this like,
you know,
even,
personally when a P.E.
1 league comes out,
for example,
I play for like a month,
sometimes a bit longer,
sometimes a bit less.
It ultimately also depends
largely what's going on here
and how much I need to
invest here.
So,
you know,
and there are other people
who play for more like
three and whatnot,
but there's certainly
going to be a much longer
time period you can play
this for while still
discovering new stuff
and not feel like you're
finished,
you know what I mean?
Now,
of course you see that
subjective,
everyone can pick their
own point when they finish,
but if you want to see
everything and do everything,
you're going to be
investing a lot more time,
especially these first time
rounds and then obviously
with every league,
there's more to discover,
but you get faster at doing
all these parts over and
over and over again,
you'll get more efficient
over time,
that's how the game works.
So,
yeah,
I'd expect a lot of time
to be sunk into this
to fully explore it,
to start with,
like a lot,
you know,
not a week,
not two weeks,
you're going to be
going far,
far longer than that
if you want to see
everything,
but you know,
it's up to you,
play at your own pace,
see how you want to go,
learn at your own pace,
that's the beauty of a
new game as well,
which we haven't been
able to experience
with Path of Exile 1,
you know,
or other games for so long
is actually discovering
the entire world,
and yeah,
there's some familiar
mechanics at the end game
and stuff like that,
which is awesome for people,
but yeah,
I certainly want to really,
I'm very excited to see
people discovering the new
things and getting so
excited about it.
I can tell you're amped
for watching people go
through that discovery
process,
maybe even diving at
yourself a bit.
100%,
I mean,
I love sitting there
in Path of Building
as many of us do,
but I am very excited
for that,
that new discovery
process for a while.
I think you were saying
how much,
you were part spreadsheet,
I think I'm like,
I think I was saying
I'm like maybe 60%
spreadsheet,
40% discovery,
and there's my play
archetype,
you know,
so.
Coming up with our
player profiles,
teamy spikes and
things like that,
for both of the
exiled characters.
The discovery part of
me is ultra excited,
and I,
and I'll mind you,
that's coming from
someone who kind of
knows all the content.
I'm still,
because there's
something different
about making it
versus actually
playing it live
with the players,
seeing them discover it,
Unique's being linked
in chat and on Reddit
and all of that is
just so,
so,
so cool.
So we're going to
get a massive dose
of that,
and it is like
genuinely exciting
to just see how
people are going to
think,
you know,
what's worth one
chaos or what's
worth ten chaos,
what's worth a
hundred.
If chaos is even
the metric.
Is chaos even the
currency that people
have said already?
We were arguing
about this earlier.
I'm pretty sure that
one C spam in chat
might turn into one E,
because like,
you know,
one exalt,
given that exalt is
now.
I think it'll be
chaos.
People probably,
people don't
appreciate,
by the way,
like,
so when we say
we've increased
that,
you're going to
be getting
multiple exalts
in Act 1 in
Peewee 2.
Like,
we actually have
increased that a lot.
It isn't just like
an idle,
you know,
I can see exalts
becoming the new
kind of like chaos.
Yeah,
I actually think it
will be.
I actually agree.
But,
yeah,
we'll see.
That's my point.
But it's a new
economy,
right?
Like,
who even knows?
The market will
have to...
But I like they were
already arguing about
this.
It's good fun.
So,
do you have some
kind of like beta
release roadmap for
updates and things
like that for people
to look forward to
with that?
I mean,
we certainly did
have one six
months ago.
But now that we're
sort of getting to
release,
it's like,
oh my God,
like,
you know,
we have to look at it.
So,
I mean,
look,
I don't think it'll
be any less than
six months.
And I think it
could easily end up
being more.
I certainly don't
want to...
Look,
2025,
I think,
really want to
be full release
in 2025.
I don't really
want to be spending
more than a year.
That would be
pretty crazy.
But I mean,
honestly,
we have to get
all the content
finished and all
that sort of stuff.
We always feel
like we underestimate
these things.
And of course,
we have to learn
what we need to learn.
We have to get the
game to the point
when it is really
fun.
We have to make
sure that all of
the things,
we've got the
difficulty right for
all the players,
we've got the
economy right,
all the stuff.
I mean,
there's a lot of
things that we're
going to have to
sort out.
So,
I kind of have a
feeling that the
first few weeks,
at least,
are going to just be
a scramble of
like,
oh crap,
someone worked
this crazy thing
out and we found
this thing.
That's always scary
because it's just,
when we add content
to PeeWee 1,
it's like,
at least the kind
of base of stuff
that we have is
kind of well-tested
and people know
what's going on with it.
But here,
it's just a complete
new world.
We're the kind of
game that has a lot
of ability for players
to do stuff that
we wouldn't anticipate.
We have just the way
support gyms work
and everything like that.
So,
there's certainly
a lot of worry
that there's just
going to be builds
that are completely
ridiculous that we
just never anticipated
combining certain
things in different
ways we don't expect.
With hundreds of
support gyms,
it can be like that.
So,
that's going to be
an interesting one.
It will happen.
It is inevitable.
There's nothing
we can even do
about it because
you'd need
hundreds and
thousands of
hours of testing
to be able to
do that with
what can only be
done with
hundreds of
thousands of
players.
But that's also
the magic of it
all,
which is awesome.
That's why I was
asking,
are you literally
really doing 12
classes in 36
sentences?
Like,
actually?
Yeah,
absolutely.
We know what we
want to do.
It's a bit unhinged.
It is a bit.
But,
you know,
we like a challenge.
I mean,
you know,
a studio that
produces a passive
skill tree like we
do clearly has a
bit of a glutton
for punishment
with regard to just
mixing it.
You totally could
have done six and
then,
I don't know,
added more later
in an expansion
or something.
Yeah,
I mean,
maybe we could have.
look,
this is the plan.
This is the plan.
I mean,
as you go through,
as people go through
early access,
it's going to feel
like there's just
expansion content
coming up pretty
frequently.
Just because,
you know,
we have all the
stuff that we've
kind of,
you know,
got a lot of the
way through.
So,
yeah,
there's stuff to come.
I mean,
look,
I'm pretty sure,
like,
I really want to get
the Druid out.
Like,
we announced it,
we've talked about it.
It's a lot of fun.
You know,
I'm keen to get that
out there as soon as we can.
You know,
the Huntress,
we've talked a bunch
about as well.
Those kinds of things,
I think,
we'll be,
you know,
we'll be able to move
towards those pretty quick.
But,
you know,
there's,
yeah,
obviously more to do.
The other thing you
mentioned,
talking roadmap-like things,
is we've always been,
you know,
it's hard to predict
because a lot of
what will happen is,
and what we leave
space for,
is reacting to
what the players want.
And so,
if you plan everything
long,
you're going to have
very,
very slow reaction times
to fixing,
you know,
or adding certain content
where they're,
you know,
maybe the issue is,
ah,
the campaign needs more
of this,
or this class needs
more of this,
or something.
So,
if you're planning,
then you're going
to be delivering
on what they want
solved,
like a year down the line
or even longer.
And where we like
to remain very,
very dynamic
and like,
you know,
you want to be able
to fix that stuff.
Like,
oh,
well,
this is the main problem.
Like,
sure,
obviously you need more
than a week,
sometimes,
most of the time.
But,
we want it generally
to be that the next
releases,
expansions,
updates,
whatever,
can alleviate
as many of those
problems as possible.
So,
yeah,
you try not to get
too strict with the planning
has generally been
our philosophy
because,
especially when it comes
to actually having
the live service product out
because that is
very,
very important.
Otherwise,
you're never going to
seem like you're doing
what people want
and what are you doing
if not that?
So,
that actually is a good point.
I was going to ask,
what do you folks,
what does a team want
out of the beta?
Because,
obviously,
it's a good way
to market the game,
but it's also,
you know,
key to shaping the game
in the future.
Like,
the actual beta.
It's not just early access.
I think one of the most
important things,
I think it's going to be
really good for the
development team to get
back into a live
mindset and,
like,
get it back into the idea
of,
like,
everything we make
is shipping.
People are seeing this.
Like,
get back into this,
you know,
like,
actually getting back
on that and,
like,
being able to sort of
see directly,
like,
okay,
we make something,
it goes in the game,
people like it,
don't like it,
like,
that kind of stuff.
Like,
that really,
like,
that has been our studio
for,
like,
most of its lifetime.
Obviously,
before we released
Peerwee 1,
it wasn't,
but after that point,
I mean,
we are a company,
like,
we are a company
that likes to think
that we can do live
service better than
anyone else.
Like,
that is our goal.
And so,
like,
getting back into that,
again,
you know,
for the entire,
for everyone in the studio,
so that everyone's
working on things
that are going to be
releasing within,
you know,
certainly in less time
than,
you know,
than three months away,
is,
I think,
really good for us again.
I look forward to just
being able to do that
because these long-term,
like,
really long-term things
that span over years,
it's like,
you go so long
without proper feedback,
like,
stuff kind of gets made
and then,
like,
you know,
it's not really
in a real game
and so it doesn't
get tested properly.
And you absolutely
lose perspective on this stuff.
So,
I think that that's just
going to be really great
to get back to that again.
Yeah.
Honestly,
as you said,
it is early access,
it is a beta period
and I'd say,
you know,
personally speaking,
the thing that,
and we mentioned it briefly
about the character balance
and the builds that are broken
and all that,
that's obviously
pretty useful to me,
right?
Yeah.
Plus,
we have other systems
in there,
like,
you know,
the checkpointing system,
right?
You have to kill the boss
in one life,
you know,
these are things
we haven't mass tested
and obviously other games
have and they work
and that's awesome.
There are other things
like,
you know,
the end game system
is a little bit less forgiving
and that if you die,
you fail the map,
right?
These things are things
that we obviously need
to test and iterate on
in the future
by adjusting the difficulty
and stuff like that
and you,
especially as you get
towards this point
of,
you know,
the end game,
like,
okay,
Act 1 has been tested
like crazy,
right?
And you get less
and less testing
as it goes on
because you get
less people,
you know,
they've just been around
for less time.
And so,
yeah,
it's going to be
a huge amount
of iteration
and feedback
and from the players
and us just,
you know,
re-evaluating all the stuff
and the thing is
we're always dynamic
about that stuff,
like,
we'll just change things
if it's wrong,
we'll redesign it,
we'll come up
with a new way.
Jonathan's a firm believer
of if A doesn't work
and B doesn't work,
then we'll find C,
we'll find option C,
we'll find option D
and we'll keep changing things
and we'll make it work.
So,
yeah,
it's going to be a lot
of that iteration
on our design decisions,
how forgiving,
because,
like,
the game is pretty hard,
you know,
it can be pretty hard.
And so,
when you're on that fine line
of, like,
you know,
things are difficult,
it's not too easy to know
if you've tilted
one way or the other,
so,
you know,
finding what everyone agrees
should be the common
correct difficulty
is something that I will
obviously be paying
very,
very close attention to.
It's a pretty hard thing
to nail down
when you are making the game.
Mm-hmm.
And,
so,
we've seen that a lot
where you folks have been
pretty willing to change
and then re-change
and re-change again
some of the core features
like flasks
and the waypointing system
and portals
and keeping that kind of mindset
going into the beta then.
Of course.
I mean,
look,
we're always willing
to change stuff.
Like,
that flask thing,
like,
the most recent change
to that was,
like,
ultra-recent.
Like,
I don't,
have we even had,
like,
a closed beta of that yet?
No.
I think we haven't,
yeah.
But,
I mean,
I think it's way better
than it was.
Like,
it's,
things have improved a lot.
And honestly,
like,
that's one of those things
we've been wanting to do,
something to sort out flasks
for ages.
Yep.
And it really came about
because,
when actually looking at
what new players
were having trouble with
when they were playing,
flask piano was actually,
like,
even from the very beginning
of the game,
actually ended up being
one of those things
that,
like,
people just had problems,
just like,
just the manual dexterity
required to,
like,
hit all your different flask keys
and then,
like,
know,
you have to know
when one of your flasks
has run out
actually was,
like,
just a weirdly large amount
of mechanical complexity
right from the very beginning.
And then,
even at endgame,
I don't think it was really
that satisfying either
because you ended up with,
like,
you know,
just,
like,
having to press all these
buttons all the time
and obviously it's all
utility flasks that people
are using at endgame.
And then we kind of tried
to band-aid this in POE1
with the,
you know,
some of the flask automation
stuff that was added there.
But there was still this idea
that you're still more powerful
if you don't automate.
So,
therefore,
you know,
like,
it's like,
you know,
there's that trade-off there.
You're just more powerful
if you get mage blood,
really.
Sure,
sure,
I guess.
I mean,
it's all automated
and you're very powerful.
Yeah,
sure,
all right.
But,
you know,
so the point is,
effectively,
the charm stuff that we're
doing effectively means
that you no longer,
the game is making that
decision of,
like,
you know,
that stuff will be
automated.
You no longer have to do
that,
like,
crazy flask piano to get
the best,
you know,
the best out of your
character.
And I think that is
definitely a step in the
right direction.
And the other thing as well
is it actually makes
the crafting more
meaningful,
I think,
on the flasks.
Because when you've got,
like,
five slots,
then,
like,
the individual mods
and the individual stuff,
like,
seems to tend to not matter
as much.
I mean,
obviously,
you know,
people want instant recovery
and things like that,
but,
you know,
like,
now it's like the actual,
it's much more meaningful,
like,
on your life flask,
the choice between,
do I want instant or do I
want way more life?
Like,
that kind of stuff actually
can be a lot more meaningful
once you've only got one.
So,
yeah,
I think it is a lot better
personally.
flask since we're on the topic.
You have,
locked in effectively,
the fact that there's
a mana flask there now.
So,
there's always going to be
a mana flask slot.
And,
how does that tie into
your design for mana?
And,
are we always going to be
using a mana flask slot?
Or,
if we solve another way,
what does it do?
You can absolutely solve
another way,
and then you'll just have
a flask slot that isn't
doing anything,
for sure.
But,
I think it kind of has to
work that way,
because we really don't want,
yeah,
because,
like,
once you sort of start
getting into changing that around,
I feel like the system
sort of starts to break
with regard to,
like,
you know,
the feeling of,
like,
I know where mana is,
I know where my health is,
like that kind of stuff.
That being said,
you know,
we've always got uniques
and stuff like that.
I believe there's already...
Yeah,
there is a unique
that allows you to equip
two more flasks.
But the thing is,
then that's a build choice
that you're making,
so it's a little bit different,
and that's fine.
But,
yeah,
I think the system
as it works now,
just,
yeah,
it's a lot easier.
So,
it does sound like
on the mana side of things,
then,
edition number 475
is how it works.
And,
we've finally got it right
this time.
So,
you know,
the,
and,
yeah,
I think it works,
and I think it's good,
so I think that Leech
will be more common.
I'm not going to have to,
like,
crack out the Leech diagram
showing the different buckets
and things like that.
I was saying,
I think that Leech might be,
no,
I think,
I was going to say,
Leech is one of the topics
in the studio
that has wasted
the most designer time
of anything in the industry.
But I actually don't think it's that.
I think the actual worst offender
is what stats should Dex give you?
I think that that is,
like,
that one has wasted so,
there's so many arguments about that.
I feel like that one's never come to the fore.
Like,
we know about the Leech one.
But no one is happy about it giving accuracy,
but no one has a better idea
than what accuracy that it can give.
And,
like,
everyone's going to come up and chat a bit.
I bet they'll be,
like,
saying,
oh,
you know,
it can give this or this,
whatever.
But,
there's,
like,
yeah,
seriously,
there's been endless arguments about that topic.
It's,
like,
it's outrageous.
Yeah,
you've got me thinking about it now.
Yeah.
I mean,
speed would be good,
but then,
it's probably too much.
Something like Dex,
you just can't.
Yeah,
Dex talking speed.
We can get all the designers down here right now.
Yeah,
I know,
we'll just have it out again.
We'll just have it out again.
The longest Q&A of all time.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's already going to be that.
Sometimes you're just,
like,
you start the day,
you're like,
here are the problems we need to solve.
And then you're like,
oh,
no,
it's 3pm,
and we're still discussing Dexterity.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's like,
all right,
just make it accuracy again.
Exactly,
exactly.
And that is literally how it comes back to accuracy every time.
This is okay.
Yeah.
Rewinding a little bit,
we can't forget our roots with Path of Exile 1,
of course.
So,
for the POE 1 enjoyers,
what is the plan for POE 1 during the course of this beta?
Is there going to be leagues launching?
Is it on the back burner?
Yeah,
there absolutely will be leagues launching.
Now,
I can't,
I don't know the exact date,
but the plan is kind of late February.
Yeah.
But,
I mean,
look,
it's,
we'll see what happens.
I will admit,
unfortunately,
we did have to steal a few POE 1 resources just towards the end here,
which has kind of been a bit unfortunate.
I really wish we didn't have to.
But,
yeah,
as I said,
we kind of underestimated some of the stuff.
But,
everyone is going to be going back to POE 1 again for the February,
for the February league.
And,
you know,
we're going to make sure that we can,
we can do that.
Like,
one of the things that was a big problem for our studio,
when we had a long-term project and a short-term project.
Yeah.
Is that,
you know,
you've always had that thing of like,
it's always,
you always want to work on the short-term thing.
Yeah.
So,
now that we've got two short-term things coming up,
actually,
it's going to be a bit easier to prioritize in some respects.
Funnily enough.
You know,
it's like,
it's all,
it's just like,
it's all that stuff is then,
you know,
is like coming up soon.
So,
but we'll see,
we'll see how it goes.
But,
yeah,
we need to get that POE 1 expansion up next.
Yeah.
Obviously,
you know,
I just want to always make it clear that,
the reason why things can't be so planned out is,
again,
we're just releasing this game.
Yeah.
Obviously,
we pivoted to end game and then that needed more resources.
And then,
of course,
combined with the fact that,
you know,
things obviously change.
There are unpredictable things in the environment.
We can't necessarily guarantee.
And then,
of course,
you have,
you know,
Christmas coming up and all of that,
right?
There's so many variables to consider.
And,
but we also don't know how much time is going to be invested necessarily or need to be invested into live operations for post-release.
How many problems are going to go wrong?
How many builds are there?
How many of the uniques are broken?
How many,
you know,
and where do all these resources go?
There are like just millions of variables here to consider.
And so,
like,
it can get very,
very difficult,
especially at this time.
But once you release,
you have a bit of a grace period.
So to speak,
we're more like a period of extreme amounts of fire where we're putting out fires everywhere.
But we have a,
we have a period where we're fixing everything.
You get everything stable.
And then we're going to be like,
all right,
let's recalibrate,
figure everything out.
And what is our plans?
And then establish all of that based also on the feedback we get from that,
you know,
period where everything's on fire.
Not to make it sound like it's going to be bad,
but that is the inevitability is that there's always problems.
Hopefully it appears good from a player perspective,
but there's always going to be,
there's always going to be like,
oh my God,
people found this.
And you know,
like,
yeah.
We don't have to see all the fires.
Yeah.
Like ideally,
ideally the best thing is when we're able to fix some kind of exploit before people even hear about it.
Yeah.
And when I say exploit,
I'm just talking about some broken thing.
Like if we,
like,
so we obviously normally have to worry about like the whole mid league nerf concept,
but it's like,
if you can,
if you can deal with something within like an hour or two of it happening,
then it's like,
you're kind of okay.
Because,
you know,
no one had a chance to kind of like everyone,
everyone didn't swap their build over to it or whatever.
Yeah.
But yeah,
we're going to be really on the ball for Pee Wee 2,
just because there's so many things that are new.
Wow.
I mean,
look,
we have several bosses with several elevators.
How many of them can be pushed up the elevator?
You know what I mean?
I'll try it out.
When I say fire,
I'm talking about bosses getting pushed up elevators.
Like that's not okay.
I am liking my mercenary flashbang knockback is very fun.
Right.
Yeah.
You need to look into that,
by the way.
The whole flashbang.
I feel like you're going to nerf my build.
Yeah.
Stay away from my grenade up.
He's finding fires already.
Yeah.
No,
no.
These are the fun things.
Discovering that stuff can be very fun for the players.
It's just internally.
It's like,
oh no,
what are we doing?
It can get a little bit panicky after release,
you know,
and it,
there's lots of things going on.
You're like,
oh geez,
what do I solve first?
But obviously,
you know,
it's the same as PeeWee 1.
We're good at it at this point.
Got some experience.
Yeah.
New belts.
You aren't going to be torturing us with like releasing beta stuff at the same time as PeeWee 2 league launch,
PeeWee 1 league launch is like.
Yeah.
The plan is to keep them separated a bit from each other so that,
you know,
you get a chance to play with both teams.
Don't make me choose.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
we saw a cinematic.
Mm-hmm.
To put it lightly.
It was pretty,
that was quite epic.
And,
and I know it's been cooking for quite some time.
Mm-hmm.
And,
that was pretty exciting,
but we've also seen just a lot of story stuff happening,
you know,
on a much higher level than previously now.
So,
stepping up your storytelling game here a bit.
Yeah,
so we're really wanting to make sure that the storytelling in PeeWee 2 is much better than what it was in PeeWee 1.
Like,
you know,
there's a lot more kind of,
I guess,
like,
that kind of like stuff with the,
like the introductions to boss fights and the outros and things like that.
Like,
all that stuff,
we've just got a lot more storytelling going in,
all of those,
all of those things.
We do have the intro cutscene.
There's also,
can kind of like light,
like between the acts,
there's these kind of like more kind of motion graphic type cutscenes,
just kind of established things.
And,
there might be some more surprises later on in the game as well.
Not in early access,
unfortunately,
later on that,
that we can,
that you can see as well.
But,
ultimately,
we just want to make sure that,
like,
I think a lot of people who got through the PeeWee 1 story had no idea what was happening by the end.
And so,
effectively,
we want to make sure that that is not the case this time around,
that people really are able to absorb things.
Guilty.
One thing I will say,
though,
is that it's ultra important to us that we don't break the feeling that,
like,
when you're playing a second time,
that it,
like,
that it feels,
we don't want it to feel annoying the second time.
Yeah.
We were talking about this this morning.
Yeah,
yeah.
We don't take the control out of the player's hands.
Exactly.
So,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm a personally,
a believer of the fact that if you just change,
if,
when you change the camera position for a cutscene,
immediately it feels way more annoying.
Like,
cause there's this whole,
this whole thing of like,
like,
if you click on an NPC and like the camera changes position,
that kind of thing is like,
you know,
like that can be cool.
But then the,
the,
if,
if you're like,
you're playing through the,
you know,
second,
third,
fourth,
fifth time,
you want to just be able to go to the NPC and click,
click,
and just get past without feeling like you've,
you've had to sort of worry about anything.
So,
yeah,
like effectively we want to make sure that it's still,
that we still have that,
you know,
because ultimately,
we're a game you expect people to,
people to play through many times.
So ideally we can kind of deliver both the situation where the first time you play
through it,
it feels like an amazing story that you're getting,
that you're taking seriously,
that you're understanding that you,
you know,
there's like all those sort of touch points and,
little,
you know,
things just all through while also maintaining the fact that if you know what
you're doing,
it's like,
you don't have to go talk to some quest giver just to get a quest.
Like you could just go do the thing,
you know,
without having to talk to someone about it first.
So,
you know,
that kind of stuff is really important just to make the,
that,
that stuff work well when you,
when you know what you're doing.
Yeah.
You said something this morning that stuck with me where you said like part of
exile is a game where the player's meta knowledge is allowed and encouraged.
Absolutely.
You're allowed to cheat.
There's quests.
There's what the character knows and there's what the player knows.
And in our game,
what the player knows is,
is needs to be sufficient as far as like being able to progress the storyline.
If you can,
you're not,
you don't want to have it.
So you just talk to NBC just to find out something you already knew as a
player.
Yeah.
Like if you know,
you kill this boss,
you get the next area's waypoint.
So you just like kill it,
log out,
log in.
I love doing that.
Yeah.
So you explained to me the other day,
the kind of the context for the beast and how that leads into the cut scene
in the beginning of Pee Wee 2 from Pee Wee 1.
And that I think helped put it in a lot more perspective for me and made me
appreciate and understand what's going on.
Yeah.
So effectively what you're seeing in the opening cut scene is effectively the,
a new,
a new seed of a beast that is going to be,
is growing.
Now in Pee Wee 1,
you know,
the beast,
the beast was killed.
And then what happened in response to that is a bunch of all of the,
the gods in the world were able to,
you know,
were able to effectively rise again.
And you killed a bunch of them,
but there are more,
you know,
in the world.
And effectively,
you know,
we,
we don't want to spoil too much about the storyline overall,
but effectively,
obviously someone here,
you know,
the count is wanting to harness the power of the beast once again.
Um,
and then we have the mysterious figure there who is saying,
you know,
uh,
no,
don't do this.
This always turns out badly.
Uh,
you know,
comment in chat that I loved that was like,
stop opening Eldritch boxes.
Exactly.
Why do people keep doing this?
Yeah.
I,
I would.
Yeah.
If someone handed you a mysterious orb,
wouldn't you press the button?
I mean,
I'm going to try,
but who knows how many hours it's going to take me.
Indeed.
So,
um,
we had a fun moment earlier where you were watching it and you were like,
Oh,
we really need to,
need to rename that passive.
Cause he's a Karooey and,
and it's a wolf.
It's called a wolf.
Great wolf's howl.
Great wolf obviously being in it.
So he went out there.
Is a mite history.
You started telling him.
I stomped out of the room.
And I was like,
we need to rename that notable.
He's Karooey.
And then I was kindly reminded that actually he was,
uh,
an orphan who,
an orphan and was adopted by a isomite and raised.
And so,
yes,
there is a mixture of Karooey and isomite background.
And I was like,
it works.
You were wrong.
Fair enough.
I walked back in here or sad and yeah,
whatever.
My bad.
It's fine.
The name is good.
He looked so chastised when he came back in,
but that just like points to,
the fact that I feel like you're doing a lot more with the characters here.
For sure.
You even mentioned that ascendancy stuff is going to have an impact story wise.
So,
um,
like with,
that's why we just think a lot about this kind of stuff.
So the,
uh,
the,
the acolyte of,
and I always get this name wrong.
The acolyte of,
is it Chalula?
Chayula.
I always say this wrong.
Um,
so,
uh,
the acolyte of Chayula,
for example,
um,
so that we have this sort of storyline with the origins of the monks,
where there's like an order of monks who,
uh,
worship a,
thing they call the dreamer.
And,
uh,
the dreamer is actually,
Chayula.
So,
um,
and they don't know this.
They're effectively worshiping a breach demon.
So,
uh,
the acolyte of Chayula is effectively you embracing the fact that I'm
worshiping a breach demon.
I'm just going to go all the way.
And,
uh,
you know,
I'm in too deep now.
Yeah,
exactly.
We're just gonna,
we're just gonna do it.
So,
uh,
yeah,
there's a lot of thinking like that that goes into these things.
Like,
you know,
what is the history of these people?
Like,
you know,
because I think a lot of that stuff inspires,
uh,
interesting mechanics as well.
So,
for example,
on that one,
you've got that into the breach skill,
which kind of means,
you know,
you're always in a breach all the time.
You can see the like,
you know,
things going on like that.
That stuff is,
I think that just,
there's a lot of cool inspiration there.
So,
uh,
coming up with that storyline stuff,
um,
for,
for that stuff,
just,
I think just,
yeah,
there's a couple other little,
little things that I think is cool as well.
And hopefully people will notice and pay attention to.
So there's one of the bosses that was shown as,
uh,
uses a lot of time or chronomancy.
And,
um,
you are a sorceress and you ascend to chronomancy and you then go to fight that boss.
Um,
if you,
for example,
try to use time freeze,
uh,
the boss is like,
yeah,
there are,
no,
that doesn't work on me.
And there's a dialogue line.
And if you cast temporal chains on them,
he's like,
you know,
just puts it back on you.
And it's like,
yeah.
And so there's interesting things like that.
And it doesn't like change things on a grand scale,
right?
It doesn't make a certain class not viable or anything like that.
But there's this interesting little quirks and quips everywhere.
Different bosses have different intro lines,
depending on what class you're playing.
Um,
they have different skill lines sometimes,
depending on what class you're playing.
Yeah.
Um,
we've got different dialogue all through the campaign for different classes,
like the,
um,
the sorceress was obviously from the Mariketh.
When she goes back to the Mariketh,
there's kind of a little backstory there about how she was banished originally.
Um,
so,
you know,
she needs to find a way that,
to be,
she needs to be accepted back into their culture again.
Uh,
you know,
like we've got things like,
uh,
you know,
the character we talked about earlier.
Um,
so the warrior,
you know,
was an orphan.
Um,
you know,
he,
uh,
he was brought up by actually one of the NPCs in act one town.
So obviously there's a whole different dialogue there because he's effectively,
his adopted son,
you know,
we've got things like that.
Um,
there's,
there's a lot of thought that's gone into,
you know,
just trying to make it feel like all these character classes have some level of
involvement with the world,
you know,
that didn't just come into existence the moment that you.
There's,
um,
other little things.
So like more on the narrative side,
you,
obviously we saw the world map,
you have the icons that show different things that are in each act,
like all the things you want to explore,
find and,
yeah,
awesome.
But each of them also has a little bit of a kind of little bit of text on them,
as well.
And like,
for example,
the,
um,
there's one in one of the first areas in the game.
That's just like a camp of iron count guards.
And,
um,
you know,
we showed it in a trailer when the,
when the Ranger class trailer we did,
um,
you know,
whenever it was,
you saw the Ranger shoot some of the,
kill some of them because they were trying to like hurt a child,
you know,
and the child was just trying to get some food and the Ranger just like snipes them
with arrows and kills them ruthlessly.
And so you read this thing and you're like,
you know,
you hear whispers of an iron count,
uh,
scouting party that was slain by a rogue archer or something like that.
So you get these little things where we like connecting a lot of little dots.
And even that you absorb a little bit of interesting little information.
Um,
you've got other things,
for example,
when you enter an area,
it don't,
not only says the name at the top.
Now it has a,
almost a subtitle text.
That's giving you a little bit,
a little bit of history.
These little things like somehow make the world building feel so much better.
And when you approach certain landmark rooms and you walk into them,
you'll get a banner at the top as well,
which says what it is and gives again,
a little bit of a thing.
And all these little micro,
uh,
narrative delivery mechanisms,
like make you feel way more immersed in the world and way more aware of what's
going on and way more connected to your character,
way more connected to the bosses,
to the NPCs.
Um,
it's,
yeah,
there's a lot we're doing now that we certainly never did before.
We didn't even think of before.
Um,
but yeah,
it's,
I like that a lot.
Cause like as an action RPG gamer,
I don't really care too much about plot,
but I do want a really cool world to be blowing monsters up in.
Basically that's like,
I want the characters to be cool.
I want the baddies to be cool.
And I want like the things happening around me that like,
in,
you know,
build out a bit of that story without me having to stop killing stuff.
Yeah.
And it sounds like there's more of that going on as well,
which is great.
There's the baddies being cool.
I mean,
that's how we almost designed an ascendancy class in here just before when we
were watching that trailer earlier.
So what you were,
you were saying a shadow,
you came up with a shadow ascendancy.
Yeah.
We were,
well,
internally we had some developers watching the trailer yesterday,
getting excited about,
and then I was like,
I want to play that.
I want to play that character.
I want to be that character.
That's awesome.
That like kind of Val Thormaturge type character.
And so like,
cool.
All of a sudden it's like,
we should make that a class.
And then we had another guy like suggest it should be a shadow.
And so now I'm like,
Oh yeah,
we're definitely,
come on.
We have to do a Val Thormaturge shadow ascendancy.
Like that's going to be cool.
And you can do awesome things now.
Even when I,
I know it's hard to see because you hide it under all the armor,
but you can do things like,
you know,
with our character classes,
just due to the upgrades and models,
where all of a sudden now the character can have tattoos added to them and stuff like that is completely feasible in the future.
And like,
I would,
I want to do a lot more of that stuff.
Like for the,
there's little things that for the war bringer,
I think was the class name on the warrior.
When you take that ancestral totem node,
all your totems now have like an extra blue glow to them,
kind of like they're enhanced by this ancestral magic.
And what we also want to do is has,
add tattoos as well that like glow blue when you're using certain skills and all that.
So heaps of little things that again,
connects all the culture and all that stuff together and make you feel like,
you know,
it's believable as opposed to,
and this is a character as opposed to,
this is just a mechanic.
And,
you know,
it makes picking an ascendancy more epic.
I know that there was a part in the trailer that was like not fully finished where you ascend and it doesn't really do anything,
but I know you want it to be like a cool moment where some power goes.
Yeah,
absolutely.
We just hadn't finished the VFX yet.
Even the,
uh,
another one,
the blood mage,
when you like,
you know,
play the blood mage and now you can add a surge on your character.
Whenever you cast spells,
you're getting like almost blood bending kind of vibe going on and like,
drawing it from their veins and sending out a fireball.
It's cool.
Yeah.
It's real cool.
You can have like the tattoos get tattooed on them as they,
as they ascend and things like that.
I mean,
that just makes taking an ascendancy way more cool,
which is,
it's already,
I think I almost feel like ascendancy is more important than the classes for
players kind of like feeling the vibe of what they want to do with their
character.
For sure.
Cause I,
I mean,
the classes are pretty open.
You can play whatever skills,
whatever weapon.
Sure.
You're on a passive tree at a start point,
but you know,
by high level,
you kind of go wherever you want to go using jewels,
especially getting off class stuff.
You can kind of be whatever you want with the base class.
Yeah.
So eventually,
yeah,
the ascendancy is what becomes more of that important identity.
Feature.
Cause that's what you have actually chosen.
That makes you distinct.
That another different class wouldn't be able to actually have.
So,
yeah.
Yeah.
So you want to make that super,
super cool.
And on that note,
I,
I know I was definitely confused.
I know people were definitely confused and a little worried about ascendancy
and what's happening with that.
And people were like watching the,
like the second trial and being like,
Oh,
what if I don't like this?
it's just another lab again.
And,
but I want you to like lay it out as like simply as possible.
Like how,
how do you ascend?
Yeah.
So effectively in the full game,
there's going to be three ascendancy trials for early access.
There's two.
And effectively you can use any of those ascendancy trials to be able to do
your ascension.
You choose.
Yeah.
You choose which one.
And effectively if you,
as you get to higher level,
like higher level keys for those trials,
that will unlock more points.
Like if you do it at a certain level break points,
that will allow you to get more points for those classes.
So if you want to just play the entire,
just,
just only the trial of the chaos God with,
you know,
to get all your points,
then you can just decide to do that.
Just play at a higher and higher levels and you get more points as you go
through.
You know,
if you want to do a mix,
that's fine too.
Personally,
I think people will want to try out all the different content.
I mean,
you might think that you,
but even within the trials,
there's,
there's choices,
right?
Like I know that there's always contention around traps,
but because in the,
because in the trial of the Sekimers,
you can choose which rooms you want to go to.
If you don't want to deal with traps,
you just don't pick those rooms,
right?
Like,
don't go to the gauntlet rooms.
You can just go to other things.
Do the combat ones.
Do the combat ones and that's fine too.
So effectively it's like,
you always get to choose like what you're doing there.
Like,
it's funny because like,
I know traps are so contentious,
but also there are other people who just enjoy that stuff.
So,
you know,
you want to have something for all those people too.
there's these like path of exile,
divisive content,
but lots of choice and you can choose what to do and what not to do.
And then we're embracing that here now.
And that is clearly leaning into that.
Now you have,
you have,
I mean,
such a competitive advantage in that you have so much content and even with Peewee 2,
that's still going to be the case.
So you can lean into that,
like making content that is spicier,
but divisive.
For sure.
And now you're like separating trees and having these things be a little able to be focused on a lot more.
And you're doing that with the trials,
with the ascendancies.
So,
and you can like,
you can kind of do all of them and drip feed yourself smaller.
And there's also stuff that you're going to be getting from those like specific rewards and everything that might incentivize you to do that.
But of course,
on the other hand,
if you don't want to do that content,
we have open,
full open trade,
right?
You can just trade for the rewards and that's fine too.
So,
you know,
like that's always part of the,
yes.
Like the rewards there,
for example,
like jewels drop throughout the world.
But if you want to get more jewels,
you go and run Sanctum.
Now,
if you want to get the radius jewels,
you,
well,
Sanctum,
I can't,
it's a trial of the second mode.
So just for anyone who isn't a Path of Exile 1 player,
this is effectively a sequel to Sanctum League that we did in Path of Exile 1.
So it's mechanically very similar,
but it's obviously,
you know,
America,
like America trial now,
and,
you know,
we've changed it.
A lot of things about it have changed and all like the content is new,
but it is effectively the same overall mechanic,
you know,
in terms of that sort of roguelike mechanic that we have.
And it's the same with the other one.
You have ultimatum and POE 1 being the theme.
And of course now it's redesigned and it's evolved into a trial of,
of chaos.
So yeah,
a lot of people in chat would have been spamming ultimatum.
And for those who haven't played,
we'd probably be like,
what?
I don't understand.
Yeah.
Effectively,
the trial of the cast of chaos is a sequel to ultimatum,
which is,
and we just have to get used to the new names,
which is very hard.
But yeah,
anyway,
the point being,
of course,
and Val orbs drop in the world as well.
And if you want a larger dose of Val orbs and,
you know,
you don't want to trade,
go feel free to run some ultimatums.
Thing is,
cause they're all item generated keys as well.
It's not like you have to do it right then and there.
You can trade the keys away.
At any point you can also buy more keys if you want to farm more of that
thing.
And if you just want to do it later,
just stockpile a bunch of them,
run them all at your,
at your leisure.
You know what I mean?
It's like you have the freedom.
They are itemized,
tradable as,
as a lot in path of exile tradition,
but as,
as is everything,
right?
We don't,
the only,
the only thing you can't trade is gold.
So we're like the exact opposite of most games where it's like the gold is
freely tradable and the items get locked.
We're like,
the gold is the only thing you can't trade and every other item is free and
open.
Yeah.
And that's because you've made gold be this like way to be like,
you're playing the game.
So you have access to this.
And absolutely.
You don't want to trade that away.
Effectively.
Yeah.
Um,
so how,
uh,
on the ascendancies and the trials,
how hard do you foresee getting your ascendancy to be while leveling?
Do you expect people to fail out and attempt these things multiple times?
And what does that look like if you do?
Well,
I failed the first time I did this.
It is important to know that that first itemized key,
um,
is a quest key.
And we have special rules around it that if you do fail,
you can just repeat it,
right?
You changed that recently because,
uh,
that was something that I didn't actually realize you'd changed.
Uh,
I guess it was a little bit too harsh to require to get in,
another one.
Yeah.
You weren't the only one failing it.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
so pretty much you get to reattempt it.
And,
um,
you know,
for something like ultimatum,
just to immediately start thinking of exploits.
It's like,
I can just do three of the waves,
then intentionally fail and then repeat them.
Well,
we've thought of that.
Don't worry.
You can't.
But,
um,
yeah,
the first ones are repeatable.
You're not going to be like,
you know,
Oh,
what the heck now I have to just play to the whims of random generation to
ascend like that.
Yeah.
So it is,
I certainly don't think you'll do it on your first attempt.
Um,
I did not to brag.
You did?
I did.
I did pass.
I was clenched though.
Yeah.
Okay.
Especially in that boss fight.
I was watching,
I was watching him do the boss fight.
You came by right as I was doing the boss fight.
But you had some like kind of powerful boons there to be perfectly honest.
I got 60% move speed.
Yeah.
That was part of my strategic choice.
I was watching you from,
I'm like,
how is he so fast?
This isn't the peewee too we just lied.
I was like,
what was Dodger?
I was going across half the arena.
This game is supposed to be slow.
No.
So yeah,
it was good.
It was good fun.
I quite liked it.
I'm,
I like mostly like Sanctum.
I'd not,
I don't want to do it all the time,
but I did quite like the trial of Sekima,
but knowing that there's other choices,
so I can do ultimatum instead or something like that.
It's fun.
100%.
So you've got these,
you've got these like two roguelike dungeons that are going into the beta
that launch,
but they've done very differently.
One's got the honor system,
which is like a separate health,
but it's based on and scaled by your health,
which I noted is quite interesting.
And your defenses now,
it can be fully mitigated and everything.
Fully scaled by your character.
You go in in a tanky character,
you'll be tanky in the dungeon,
which is really cool.
And then with ultimatum,
and just because people will ask,
in ultimatum,
there aren't any traps.
Yes.
No traps in ultimatum
and no honor system in ultimatum.
If you just want more of a pure combat experience,
then that's your choice.
And then there's going to be a third one as well,
which is secret for now.
So once act four goes in,
then we'll have a third trial.
So, you know,
people sort of broadly know that the crew are in act four.
So it's the question of how would the crew ascend
is the question there.
Yes.
And if there's any other things that have been called trials
associated with the crew at some point in the past
and how likely that is to be related.
I'm just thinking now,
we're just thinking of that Vile Thormaturge class before,
and I'm already thinking,
like,
oh,
it'd be so cool if you ascend in ultimatum.
We want the trial master to say different lines to you
because you're,
like,
choosing the way of the Vile.
I'm just,
I'm,
you can't,
I can't stop thinking about all this stuff.
I did hear a few of his lines
in some of the gameplay Jonathan was showing me.
It was quite good.
I love,
I love that he's back,
the trial master.
Yeah,
he's cool.
A little salty sometimes that you're taking this power,
it seems.
So,
we have,
we have the unique rewards from each of them.
We got like the,
like you said,
the jewels are global,
but there are unique jewels,
and then there are,
um,
unique socketables from the other one.
Yep.
And is it,
there's something planned to be unique from the final third trial
that will be added later?
Of course.
Uh,
yes,
there is already.
I know what they,
I'm not going to say it,
don't worry.
Keep some secrets.
Fine then.
Again,
again,
I value the discovery,
right?
I'm certainly,
if I accidentally say it,
it is certainly by mistake.
But yes,
don't.
And that Vile Orbs from the ultimatum in particular,
um,
is,
they seem like they're a lot more important,
a lot more powerful.
I mean,
I certainly think that like,
some of the stuff is a lot better with how they work.
So,
um,
yeah.
So one of the things that we wanted to change was that implicits on items are truly implicit.
Like you can't get rid of them.
They stay there.
And so that means that when you do a Vile,
uh,
a Vile Orbs,
the mod that you get there now is an addition to whatever implicit already had,
um,
which is obviously good.
And then the next one being that,
yeah,
you can get plus,
plus one socket above the normal limit,
um,
which is,
uh,
you know,
also kind of powerful.
Um,
so especially with the soul cause.
So in,
um,
in,
in the,
uh,
trial of the trial of chaos,
you,
uh,
get,
soul cause that you can't get from anywhere else.
And those effectively are,
uh,
mods that are typically a bit beyond what you would normally get,
um,
uh,
like in,
on regular items.
Um,
whereas runes,
which kind of drop everywhere,
those ones are just kind of normal everyday mods that you would expect to find.
Resists and things like that.
Yeah,
just resists and damage and that kind of stuff.
So effectively the soul cause is,
um,
you know,
is,
is kind of the more end gamey,
uh,
socketables that you might want to be using.
And,
um,
yeah,
obviously being able to get,
um,
plus one socket,
I mean,
it's something that everyone will want.
Um,
but on the other hand,
there is that risk of,
uh,
you know,
just bricking your item.
So,
uh,
you know,
that's a,
the deadly gamble you have as your final crafting step there.
It's what they are.
Val orbs are more forgiving though.
They are.
Yeah.
But like,
you know,
if you think about,
um,
we,
we talked about enchantment.
Yeah.
So some slots you might value the enchantment over a rune or a socket slot,
right?
That probably,
especially towards end game,
I'd say that's probably going to tilt that way because,
you know,
well,
maybe a soul core contests with it,
but you know,
the whole point is that there's,
you know,
choice there involved,
um,
you know,
and then there,
so there's enchantment.
We just talked about the socket.
Um,
there's obviously always the case of doing nothing,
um,
which happens,
but you know,
for,
um,
just say regular rare items,
uh,
it will re-roll like one to three modifiers at ran effectively do a chaos orb on one to three modifiers,
not all six.
And as much as that can often be a downside,
because if you're using on a very good item,
um,
obviously it's going to take away the good ones.
Um,
but if you're using it on a mid item,
you can actually turn it very good.
Now I've had this happen.
Like I,
when I've been playing,
I've got like,
ah,
it's just,
you know,
life defense,
defense,
double res,
and something else that I don't want.
And,
um,
I'm like,
ah,
I'll just start valing everything.
Cause why not?
You know,
I've got my val orbs and I val it and it re-rolls that bottom mod into a tri-res,
and now I've got a tri-res,
double defense,
life helmet.
And I was like,
yo,
awesome.
So even that,
which is,
can often be perceived as a bad outcome.
Now it isn't going to completely break your item.
And so,
for example,
if you have a weapon,
you know,
you've got your three damage mods,
um,
and you've got some bad suffixes,
it could even be an option,
you know,
like,
or hopefully it doesn't just remove all three damage mods,
you know,
whereas before it's like,
if it bricked it,
it often was almost always a brick,
right?
Like that item is now dead.
So.
And then you told me about a new unique,
uh,
yeah,
result,
which I don't know if you want to spoil it.
100%.
Yeah.
It's cool.
It's so cool.
I'm surprised you even got that pass with that one pass,
Rishi,
honestly.
I mean,
he got it made.
Okay.
Great.
We discussed it.
I,
you know,
I agree.
I messaged it to him thinking he'll be like,
no way,
this is unacceptable.
He was,
he was all for it.
It didn't turn into a dexterity chat.
And so,
um,
yeah.
Um,
pretty,
what it effectively does is it just takes the mod values and it multiple,
it,
it goes up to,
uh,
I can't remember exactly the values,
but let's just say it's,
it,
um,
it changes all the values to between 0.8 and 1.2 of what they were multiplied,
but it doesn't care about the minimum and maximums.
So for example,
if you had a thousand life calms heart,
you can use this to get,
again,
this is me assuming it's 20% variance,
but I,
cause I can't remember what we balanced it to,
but you'll be able to get a 1200 life calms heart,
for example.
Now that's obviously giving up the enchantment and a socket.
Um,
just thinking about sockets on calms heart.
I can't remember what we did,
but whatever.
Um,
I think you can actually,
uh,
do that,
which is interesting,
but,
um,
uh,
ultimately it's like,
yeah,
now I'm choosing,
am I,
do I want the enchantment?
Do I want an extra,
you know,
100 something,
200 life,
whatever that ends up being?
Um,
or do I want the socket?
so it's quite an interesting choice and adds an extra access of corruption to unique items.
That is,
I think,
corrupted divining of uniques.
Yeah.
Effectively.
It's divining them,
but with,
um,
higher maximums and lower minimums.
Surely there's going to be some broken things like max res or something like that.
I mean,
we'll guess we'll find out.
Cross that bridge when it comes to it.
Yeah.
It's fine.
So that was all just talking about the trials,
how you actually get your ascendancies,
but what about the actual ascendancies themselves?
How are they,
uh,
how are they cooking?
Um,
well,
they're fun.
They're cool.
Yeah.
Um,
we certainly try to get,
what we've tried to do is for the,
the class,
we've tried to have one that's a bit more out there.
Yeah.
You know,
something that isn't just,
you know,
like if you think even about in Pee Wee One,
you've got the dualist,
you can go like champion or slayer or,
um,
holy words.
I don't remember,
but you know,
the drill,
um,
and the,
oh,
gladiator.
And the problem is like,
okay,
they're all just about like hitting stuff with weapons and they haven't,
there's nothing really out there.
They,
they,
sure,
they all sound cool.
Like don't get me wrong.
And they can be cool and they do have differences,
but there's nothing that's like kind of crazy.
Um,
so all of a sudden now when you're like,
you know,
sorceress,
you're using all your elemental skills and now you can just like go into this
thing that can stop time.
You know,
it's a little bit more,
uh,
crazy.
And you've got the,
the mercenary and you can turn into a gemling legionnaire and effectively fuse
gems into your flesh to like,
you know,
mutate yourself.
You know,
it's like not just talking about crossbows and projectiles over and over and over
and over again.
It's like doing kind of whack stuff.
So I really like that.
That's awesome.
And we're going to make sure every single class has one thing that is like
definitely out there.
Um,
and then one thing that's,
you know,
more predictable,
more to the expectation of the trope,
you know,
for example,
the dead eye to the Ranger.
And,
um,
but yeah,
lots and lots of,
uh,
cool interactions,
just cool and playing with different mechanics.
And we've tried to make them like,
for example,
none of them call out a weapon,
right?
None of them.
So you,
we're trying to make sure that they're broad.
enough to be that you might be a Ranger going a dead eye,
but playing a caster,
right?
Playing spells,
like keeping all of that open,
that flexibility,
that kind of crazy,
you know,
for the Johnny players,
as we call it out there,
who want to just completely experiment and figure out,
you know,
the most broken,
weird stuff,
you know,
and you get things with that when you're still like,
okay,
I'm a Ranger.
Uh,
and I'm using a Quill Rain in one weapon set,
specced into a bunch of prod speed,
attack speed.
And in my second weapon set,
I'm using a spellcaster staff with a bunch of projectile stuff.
And I'm invested into more spell damage side.
And you've got a whack tree.
And all of a sudden,
now you're this like dead eye,
archer,
spellcaster,
mage hybrid,
doing all kinds of wacky stuff,
or like even,
or let's say the same build and experimenting with a bunch of triggers.
And so you're using your bow as a,
as Quill Rain,
as a higher attack speed delivery mechanism for,
you know,
laying down a bunch of either CCs or slows,
or building up crowd controls.
And then you're using the caster stuff.
And like,
you get some pretty out there things going on.
And the important thing is it's not like just like,
uh,
benefiting only arrows or only bow attacks or anything like that.
It's broad.
And now,
you know,
it opens up the world to what you can do and same like the,
the gemling legionnaire on the mercenary is entirely just about gem slots,
skills,
support,
et cetera.
There's no,
you don't have to be anything.
You can be literally whatever build you want.
Um,
and yeah,
so that,
that's embracing that and making sure that people still,
even though we have all these classes,
you are,
we're embracing that path of exile.
You can do anything fantasy that we want people to be able to do.
And yeah,
if you don't want to go with the trope,
perfectly fine.
Yeah.
And you'll still be powerful.
It sounds like you're really trying to avoid that thing that we've had a
couple of times in POE one where like a certain niche is relegated to
on ascendancy.
Like that's the only way to go for it.
It sounds like that's not going to be the case here.
Well,
at least if we're doing our job right,
that should we,
yeah.
And with so many of the ascendancies as well,
got a lot of choices.
Um,
originally the plan was to like have all of the POE one ascendancies available
and it was some sort of weird split campaign stuff and all that.
Uh,
I don't really know at this point.
It's a bit confusing.
It's,
you mentioned dead eye though.
So it sounds like some of them are coming forwards,
but is it all just being redone at this point?
At this point,
yeah,
at this point they'll just be different,
right?
Like originally way back when we were planning on just keeping the
ascendancies as they were and putting them over.
But at this point,
um,
that wouldn't even be a good enough because like,
it doesn't fit the kind of like path of XL two way of designing this
thing.
So yeah,
I mean,
like we might have a class called the dead eye and it might have the
same themes,
but it'll be like different actual mechanics and different things.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
even the dead eye,
you got tailwind works differently.
You've still got an additional projectile,
you know,
like there,
there are things that certainly carry over.
Um,
but it's,
it's really easy.
And it's honestly been fun just looking at them going like,
you know,
now we have all these system changes,
all these skills and everything works like this.
Just what would the perfect class be?
Not like,
how can we retrofit and bandaid appear we won class to work?
It's just way better to look at it and go,
here's,
here's all the things we want.
Yeah.
So,
well,
yeah,
like when you only have now the life and mana flask and stuff,
it could,
obviously things don't work quite the same,
but then now you have the charm system and all of a sudden,
I actually do wonder if path of one would be cool with that.
Exactly.
Like stacking charms.
So,
so it's,
it's just,
here are,
you know,
12,
eventually 36 classes.
Um,
it's not really like,
here's the Peewee one counterpart and they're identical kind of thing
anymore,
for sure.
Too many things changed for that to even be possible anyway.
Yeah.
All right.
That sounds very epic.
Um,
we can skip over the flask and trinkets as we did cover that,
uh,
very well.
So,
uh,
moving into,
um,
skills,
I realized I was like,
had many pages of questions here.
And then I was like,
wait,
we haven't even talked about like skills here.
It's so much to,
so much to,
for us to discover over the course of this beta.
Um,
how has the list of skills been shaping up overall?
I mean,
it's certainly getting there.
look,
there,
there are even certain skills that won't even make it,
even just within the classes we have,
like there are still going to be more,
some more skills coming,
uh,
later on as well for the,
for these classes,
because,
um,
there,
there are more skills that we got,
um,
just about there and,
yeah,
but just didn't quite,
didn't quite make it.
Um,
so,
uh,
yeah.
And like getting a class finished in terms of the skills you need,
like,
um,
it,
it sort of seems very easy when you,
um,
okay,
we need like,
you know,
22,
when you actually come up with all of the things,
you know,
the,
the way they interact together,
um,
you know,
the number of prototypes you have to do that kind of don't really work and,
like you end up not being fun.
Um,
and then of course the support gem stuff,
like you need to make sure that every skill has enough viable supports so that you can actually even recommend to people to do.
Yeah.
Uh,
then you need things like the,
uh,
you know,
the passive tree support for all of them.
You need to have,
um,
all of the,
uh,
the,
the stuff with like buff,
uh,
the buff gems for each character class as well.
Um,
you know,
you need to be thinking about uniques for the,
for the type of,
uh,
you know,
for the,
uh,
that can work with these things.
It's just like,
there's so many different elements to actually make skills work.
And,
uh,
once again,
it's another area I think that,
um,
was underestimated to some degree,
uh,
before,
and,
you know,
like it does take a,
um,
you know,
to actually get that finished,
it takes a lot.
Um,
so,
uh,
yeah,
that's been,
um,
a total struggle.
And we,
we didn't think we would have to have only six character classes initially,
uh,
at the start of early access,
we were thinking we would have eight,
um,
uh,
to begin with,
but,
uh,
yeah,
when it actually came down to actually getting to actually finish something,
uh,
you know,
like it just ended up being too much.
Um,
so,
uh,
you know,
now obviously we've got a bunch,
I mean,
we've got a bunch of work on more of the classes that we've done,
you know,
there's things there,
but,
um,
it's that finishing work of like making sure that all the systems in the game come
together to support,
um,
you know,
the,
how that,
how that works.
Um,
that requires a lot.
Doing all of that as we're still discovering how we want those systems to work,
you know,
like the changes to support gems and all that,
as we're also making support gems,
as we're making character classes,
just can cause things to slow down quite a bit.
And then we have to recalibrate and all.
Yeah.
Like it is,
it was an extreme amount of work that we certainly,
uh,
predicted poorly.
Um,
but that was also because we are making all these cool systems,
all these changes,
uh,
changes to all these systems,
which are having like immense benefits as well.
So,
yeah,
I would say it's pretty safe to expect that,
you know,
as much as you can't play them on day zero,
um,
a lot of some of those other classes that we have shown in the past,
and some of the skills and stuff,
there's a lot there,
like just not to make it seem like it's shallow or anything,
but we will be adding those classes in for sure.
Yeah.
The thing that keeps like surprising me is,
um,
well,
when you click that old gems tab,
when you're doing an uncut,
there's quite a lot of skills in there,
but you initially kind of box yourself away,
where you think,
okay,
so I'm playing the mercenary.
So I'm just looking at the crossbow skills.
And then I was like,
well,
what if I go look at the elemental skills and then I find a flame wall and I'm like,
Oh,
I can shoot my projectiles through that.
Okay,
cool.
I like that,
but that's like surface level because you also have the weapon swap thing and you can actually viably do with the automated weapon swapping.
It's not like toxic where you have to push the button a bunch of times.
And you've got the trees that like customize whenever you do it automatically on the fly.
So that's like,
all of a sudden I'm like,
Oh,
well,
why can't I use a sword on the other hand?
Yes.
You absolutely can do other stuff.
That's actually a very cool mercenary vibe sword and crossbow.
So,
um,
yeah,
I mean,
that stuff is like,
is,
is crazy.
I mean,
like in the,
in the,
actually there was one in the,
the,
uh,
community guys recorded where they were using,
um,
a bell,
the,
the bell skill with the quarterstaff with the,
um,
uh,
the rapid,
the rapid shot,
uh,
mercenary skill.
And when I saw it,
oh man,
you know,
it's like,
it's like a whole other thing.
Um,
yeah,
like that,
I didn't even know about that,
about that particular combo,
uh,
until I saw it in the,
some of the footage they recorded.
I started,
uh,
yeah,
I started thinking about that too with like multiplayer.
I was like,
so I was throwing my gas grenades,
which you can blow up with your explosive grenades.
But then I was throwing it at a boss that was doing burning ground and they were blowing up instantly.
I'm like,
oh wait,
so it reacts to the environment.
Well,
it's obviously going to react to my friends doing burning ground then.
Oh yes.
It's my flame wall friend.
And this,
and this is the reason,
like this conversation here is the reason why there's going to be crazy builds that we don't anticipate.
Because like,
like,
like the,
the,
some of the stuff that can happen between classes,
I just have no doubt we will not have discovered.
Yeah.
Like how much co-op have you really been able to test?
I mean,
we,
like we,
we do test party play all the time.
Like it marks,
marks,
marks like,
I'm the support character player.
Now I'm like freezing armor,
breaking,
putting down clouds slowly,
you know,
I'm like,
holy,
there's just a lot going on all of a sudden.
I'm not just standing there.
Like I got buffs coming out of me.
You know,
it's like,
you know,
you're like,
I'm actually doing all this active support and like different conditions to synergize with the group.
And how can it's like,
okay,
you're doing that skill.
Okay.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to just do this and enhance my armor breaking and go ballistic armor breaking.
And you just spam your thing that consumes it,
you know?
So you get a lot of that stuff going on for sure.
Where,
um,
I,
but you know,
it,
it's kind of honestly the terrifying part as well,
where it's like,
you know,
what do we have?
We had the whole like vulnerability curse with,
with gas cloud ticks or something.
And it was like literally applying armor break,
like every frame.
And so you have the monsters going,
tink,
yeah.
And then you have some other thing and you have some other guy consuming it.
And again,
Oh my God,
quill rain just don't even how many bloody synergistic things with quill rain.
You can do a lot with that.
All the lightning arrows on the ground.
And cause they can,
you know,
lightning things hit them and explode.
And all of a sudden now you're just,
everyone's running around with quill rain,
spamming lightning rods everywhere.
And yeah.
And frost wall somehow frost wall,
we had about 15 abuse cases.
And I mean,
that's historically accurate.
Yeah.
Kinetic blast frost walls and all that.
It returns.
Sounds like it's coming back.
It's,
it'll be fun.
It's cool.
Even finding all the stuff so far has been really fun.
But yeah,
I generally play multiplayer.
Most of the alpha I've done is being in multiplayer,
play with other people.
It's good to get a lot of that testing in there as well.
Cause not a lot of others do it.
That's really good.
And then yeah,
try and see what we can break just for good fun.
Honestly,
the thing that's like hard is to then like,
cause you get this thing,
which is quite interesting where you have a staff is both the player and a
developer.
And I'm off the like,
don't you,
you better not keep that X that,
you know,
something that's,
I wouldn't say exploit,
but you know,
something that's OP,
a secret,
right?
You better tell me because the exact reaction you had earlier.
You were saying people weren't telling you about their build.
Exactly.
Like you get a situation,
someone doesn't want to tell you about their build.
That's cause they're like,
Oh,
Mark will nerf it then.
You're supposed to be making games.
Exactly.
I legitimately had a Monday meeting and you know,
whatever.
I was like,
I swear if I see any of you at the top of the ladder on day one,
we're going to have a talk.
Exactly.
I know you've hidden something from me.
No,
I did tell you about my flash bangs and I good,
but maybe it's fine.
I just don't,
I just wanted them to check.
That is the thing that is hard.
No one knows if their thing is actually,
look,
there's a line that gets crossed.
Yes.
Yeah.
But sometimes you don't know,
is it just,
I found something cool and it's powerful or have I found something cool and it's broken,
you know,
and,
and those things,
I mean,
we have to make those decisions of course.
And a lot of the time,
what is reported is just fine.
And it's like,
yeah,
you've,
you've got a good weapon and you've got the right,
you've got this combat.
You,
you're strong.
If it's,
if it's supported by items,
then it's like fine to be very powerful.
But if you're just like,
I just pick these skills and no matter what weapons I'm wearing,
I'm just like completely ridiculous.
Then that's a different situation.
Cause now it's just a thing that anyone can do at a moment's notice rather than actually requiring like,
you know,
Oh,
I have to find the big,
you know,
this combo of items and things like that.
That,
so that's a much different story.
Um,
yeah.
We've had a lot of good testing,
a lot of good feedback,
a lot of good,
um,
people reporting that stuff,
especially in the last month,
it's like coming in a lot.
Cause as the systems and everything's kind of stabilizing,
you start to get a lot more of that.
And people are understanding what the,
uh,
difficulties meant to be and what the power of characters is meant to be.
As all of that came and started to stabilize,
we got a lot more of this coming in and we are kind of getting more understanding,
but again,
you'll never find them all,
but,
uh,
you know,
it's fun,
good,
fun journey.
Support gems have changed a lot.
How have you found the changes to them being now having no levels and,
uh,
the restriction of having only one support gem on your character of a type,
but having a lot more of them.
I really like how this works.
Like I think that it adds so much more build diversity and interest,
um,
to have to be making the decision of like,
you know,
where is this going to go?
And the thing that's been important though,
with that system is it's required.
It requires a lot more support gems to exist because you need,
because you don't have one on your character.
You need,
you need tons of them.
And like,
you need like,
you need a lot of different ways to increase damage and a lot of ways to
support different mechanics.
It's like,
if you're going to have something like freeze,
like,
you know,
if you're going to have a freezing skill,
you need to be able to support that and augment that in like many different ways.
And there needs to be more options than what you can even like.
there needs to be in order to have choice.
You can't just have five.
Here's your five freeze things.
And that's all you do,
right?
There has to be more than that in order to be able to have it.
So you actually have some choices as well.
So,
uh,
that kind of stuff has meant that you just need a lot of things going on there.
But I think that,
um,
the choices that you end up with as a player of like,
you know,
where do I put my model projectiles?
Where do I put my PS?
Where do I put like,
I think that leads to a lot more interesting decisions,
um,
with how you build.
And,
um,
uh,
you know,
like,
uh,
yeah,
I think that,
that to me is where a lot of the,
why it just works so much better.
And we were certainly hesitant about the whole,
um,
you know,
you can only have one support per character thing because it sounds bad.
If you just hear about it as a player without actually playing it,
like your first reaction is you just hear that and you're like,
oh,
it's just a restriction.
And it is arbitrary in some sense,
right?
There's no,
like we can't justify it thematically really.
Um,
it's just a,
it's just,
it just is what it is.
And so that,
I really don't like that kind of thing usually because,
um,
if I'm going to,
I want the theme to match the mechanic as much as possible,
but in this case it just made the gameplay so much better that,
um,
like it just had to happen.
Um,
so arguably if you,
if you need to like,
if you end up in a situation where you like,
I have to put the support on every slot.
Exactly.
That,
that is less choice.
And that's the reason why the gameplay is less choice,
less interest.
And also you may as well just bake that now into the skills and or
100%.
And so this is the thing.
It is actually much worse to have that because it,
it results in this outcome,
but like,
that's a kind of more subtle argument that's like,
you have to kind of make to people if you want to kind of convince them
that this is actually the right way.
Um,
because when you tell people,
Oh,
there's this restriction,
it doesn't sound like what they're getting out of that is more choice.
It sounds like they're getting less.
Um,
but the reality is it is actually more choice because you no longer have
like mandatory,
uh,
like here's the,
here's the five mandatory things you have to put on the skill.
Um,
it's like,
it's actually much more going on.
I think it's much better helped realize my experience on the mercenary
that you,
uh,
your vision of,
having like all of these skills available to you and them actually being worth
using.
For sure.
Because if you had all the same support gems,
I feel like you just pick the one that does the most damage.
And you make it do the most damage.
And that's the only skill you use.
And I mean,
the great thing is,
is now it's completely reasonable to have a skill in your character that you
just use occasionally,
right?
Like every five minutes you might have a situation where you need to use
that.
And that's actually fine and completely reasonable.
Yeah.
So I'm playing a grenade or,
and I would be like,
okay,
I should only use this grenade normally is what I would be like in part of
exile.
Cause this is the best grenade or maybe this one that does like interacts
with it in some way,
the obvious combo.
But now I'm actually like,
well,
there's a reason I could use those lightning ones to apply a shock because I
have all these shock support gems that I'm not using anywhere else.
Cause I'm using the damage and the LMP on my big damage dealers.
I can use,
I can put the shock things on there and I can actually have a shock set up.
I can incorporate that into my build.
I can incorporate poison into my build to strip their armor and whatnot.
And that actually is something I can support.
And maybe you only use that occasionally when you face something that's got heavy
armor,
you know?
Yeah.
But it's like,
it's like that,
that kind of stuff I really want to be viable.
And that situational stuff I think just makes the game way more interesting.
It's,
it's really feeding into the flavor of the mercenaries like this,
like prepared kind of fighter who has all these tools at their disposal as
well.
Like,
you're like,
I have this grenade for,
if I get into this situation,
this grenade for this one.
It's like,
good.
I love it.
A couple of questions here.
People definitely been asking about like vile skills and transfigured gems and
stuff like that.
I feel like this sort of thing doesn't make sense at launch.
Yeah.
Because ultimately if we were going to add something like that,
it would make sense to add it just as another skill.
So at this point,
there's no real reason to do that.
Like that kind of stuff comes in where we want to have a specific reward system
somewhere that wants to be able to do that.
And so we don't really need to do it right now,
but you look,
we might decide to bring that theme back and,
you know,
in a reward system.
Yeah.
I think for vile skills,
especially it's a,
it's a cool flavor.
Yeah,
for sure.
But I think the transfigured thing is also interesting.
Like,
you know,
if you're looking to be able to like,
the reason why transfigured was nice is because it's like,
we got to sort of iterate on a bunch of different themes around the same
skill,
which obviously at this point we don't need to do that because we've got,
we're already still adding the skills,
you know what I mean?
So all the iterations of it are like less of a necessary thing.
But yeah,
I mean,
I'm just like,
I'm sure we'll be doing more stuff like that in the future.
Like we absolutely will be.
Do you know how many skills roughly you have,
Sasha going to end up with?
You know,
I actually don't know the number off the top of my head,
but what I will say is,
is that we initially,
I think when we announced like what the full game would have,
we said 240.
I'm pretty sure we're actually nearing that.
I feel definitely,
it's going to be way higher than that.
Yeah.
Cause I think we're nearing that now when we've only added half the
classes.
So I think that that means that there's going to be a lot more than that.
I know a hundred of them or whatever,
like some little utility skill or whatever,
but there's,
even if you discount for those,
it's still many major skills.
Yeah.
You got what?
Like,
cause there's 20 to,
there's 20 to 25 for each of those,
for each class.
And so just with six of those,
I'm terrible at math in my head,
but I feel like that's 120.
Well,
let's,
let's say it's just a bit over 110 or something.
End up around there,
120,
something like that around.
Yeah,
I think probably 120 around there like that.
But then you've also got all the buff gems as well.
And like each character class has nine of those.
So that then sort of adds up.
So you've already reached probably 200 just by the time you've got to there.
Um,
and then,
uh,
and then it doesn't even count things that really are skills,
but like are not,
you don't get them via a skill gem.
Um,
so like we're talking about all the ascendancy little skills and there's like uniques that have little skill things on them.
Well,
all,
all staffs,
wands and scepters have a skill back in.
Exactly.
We're not even counting that,
right?
Like,
cause the staffs,
wands and scepters have skills built in.
Yeah.
Uh,
and then those are like,
that's another,
how many of those?
There's like 20 of those probably.
Yeah.
I mean.
Like if you add them all up.
I don't know who remembers all these things.
No one has counted recently,
uh,
but,
there's a bunch.
Countless,
countless skills.
Um,
ascendancy classes with skills.
Yeah.
That's tons.
And those skills,
those skills,
by the way,
ascendancy class skills are fully supportable.
Yeah.
That's wild.
Cause I remember you did the thing with the fault attack where you can support that.
you can support the fault attack.
Um,
and you can support any skill that comes from something.
That one caught me by surprise.
I was like,
Oh wow,
you can actually link those up.
Yep.
It's a,
yeah.
So you're,
you're going to end up with quite a lot going on there.
I was even surprised when I was like,
Oh,
I can add,
you know,
additional accuracy to herald of ice.
And it like provides a buff to my character.
I can like add buffs through support.
Well,
you know why that is though?
Because,
uh,
those,
those things like heralds are so hard to find like a good set of supports to
recommend.
So we're like,
damn it,
we have to come up with like tons of these now.
They're like really difficult.
You can like create a custom aura.
absolutely.
Absolutely.
So yeah,
it's,
um,
that,
that actually means it's,
it's actually nice because,
um,
part of the,
it means that you get the feeling of having more aura effects on your
character without having to have the spam of actual auras that,
um,
every,
many characters had in here we won,
but you get to kind of have all that stuff as well.
Um,
so,
uh,
that's,
that's been really nice.
Thanks for the,
uh,
invisible or MTX.
Well,
it does remind me though.
Um,
so with all the,
this is very off topic,
but with all the,
uh,
very good teasers you've been doing for like new 3d art for uniques and
stuff like that,
have you had any thoughts about,
uh,
reworking,
um,
the transfer skin transfer?
Yeah.
Um,
honestly,
it's not an hour thing about stuff we're thinking about,
you know,
like it'll work the same way it works for now at least.
Um,
but obviously,
uh,
skin transfer and PeeWee too.
There's a lot more cool base art.
Yeah.
That's going to make people actually want to use it.
So yeah,
it'd be cool to see something for that in the future potentially.
Um,
so onto the end game,
which was,
I feel like a big bulk of the announcement for sure.
Yeah.
Um,
so just as like an overview.
So we have the end game versions just for beta launch,
by the way,
because it's going to be a lot more later.
Yeah.
We don't have the,
we have the end game pinnacle versions of the two,
um,
trials.
Yep.
So as like fully farmable content,
they don't have trees though.
Those ones.
They don't have trees,
but they do have a progression system of some kind.
So you've got the relics in,
um,
in,
in the sanctum,
uh,
sequel.
And then,
um,
for the trial of chaos,
you have,
um,
the,
uh,
the inscribed,
ultimatums have getting mods,
uh,
from,
from the end.
So when you kill the,
um,
final,
uh,
the,
the final boss of that,
uh,
which is,
you know,
alleged to be the trial master.
Um,
then,
uh,
you,
um,
alleged.
Yeah.
Then,
uh,
you know,
he'll drop,
uh,
items that can,
um,
then have mods on them to make the trial itself harder.
And there's also some pretty interesting ones on there that we actually were going to put in the video,
but it was starting to get a bit long,
um,
which was that,
you've got the thing which I,
uh,
where you've got the,
the,
the bets that you can make of like,
you know,
uh,
put up,
you know,
13 exalts and then,
uh,
you might get double that back if you're able to complete the thing.
So those are some of the mods that can spawn on there.
Um,
and,
uh,
as well as mods that make the actual trial harder as well.
So,
um,
there's things like that as well.
So yeah,
those two have those kind of like different outside the outstriks.
Cause they're not really part of the Atlas.
Like you'll get keys for them while you're playing in game,
but technically speaking,
they're kind of like,
they,
they go,
they scale to end game,
but they're not like sort of part of the,
the whole Atlas,
um,
like play them there.
Yeah.
So their own distinct.
Exactly.
So there'll be three roguelike dungeon things that will be.
Sure.
Um,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't say three roguelike dungeons.
I will say there'll be three trials that have various mechanics that are,
you know,
different.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
then,
then of course you've got the,
um,
uh,
for kind of what I guess would say sort of,
um,
I don't,
we actually need a name for what,
what are we calling,
what are we calling the things that are icons on the,
on the,
cause they were called leagues,
but they're not really.
Yeah.
It doesn't really make sense to call it a league.
Exactly.
That is what we call them internally.
We just call them as like,
there are four leagues that you have that appear there.
It doesn't really work.
Um,
uh,
I don't have a good idea right now.
Yeah.
We probably have actually named it.
I just don't remember what it is.
And then you've got,
uh,
the kind of boss hunting kind of element as well.
Uh,
and then the kind of,
I guess what you would say is the pinnacle of the kind of boss hunting thing is then,
you know,
you've got the cities with the lieutenants and then the Uber act bosses.
And then above that,
you have the pinnacle boss who,
uh,
we don't want to spoil.
Um,
although I did,
uh,
show you a little bit about it,
just in private,
uh,
before.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
that's,
uh,
that one's going to be,
that one's going to be hard.
Like,
uh,
I know you're,
you're cooking up some pretty difficult mechanics there.
Um,
yeah,
it's fun.
I asked the,
that's the fun stuff.
Yeah.
Cause now you don't need to worry about if people can't progress through,
it's not a progression blocker.
You can just kill them.
Yeah.
It's a progression,
it's a progression blocker to,
uh,
difficulty,
to the higher difficulties though,
because yeah,
once you,
once you kill that,
of course,
then you get the increase of the difficulties and then it's like,
okay,
now try it again,
but way harder.
And then,
you know,
like,
and then there's four,
there's four levels of difficulty for each of those,
um,
for each end game system like that.
So yeah,
like apart from the trials,
the end game trials,
everything has like its own distinct passive tree and progression through them is also by doing them.
Yes,
exactly.
Yeah.
So we really wanted to prevent the situation where you feel like you,
um,
allocate points for a certain piece of content and then you feel like you can't do the other content because you're kind of wasting the points that you've got.
Yeah,
the lock in.
And,
uh,
we kind of,
band-aided that in POE1 by adding multiple Atlas trees as a way,
but I think the solution is much better where effectively you can progress all of them and you can either do like,
you know,
just all in a one for a while,
or you can just like,
you know,
do each of them as you come to them and,
just add them kind of piecemeal.
Um,
um,
but either way,
however you want to do it,
um,
you know,
you,
you can make progress,
progress on your character.
Um,
well,
I should say in your league,
uh,
for all,
for all of those.
Um,
because,
uh,
the,
the progress and all that stuff is of course,
um,
you know,
for the whole league,
not just for a single character.
Yeah.
And previously we use the Atlas tree,
I would say very much so to make sure that we were doing the type of content that we wanted to do.
Yeah.
So now it's not so much about finding the content because that's what the tablets are for.
Now it's more about,
um,
improving your ability to,
like,
uh,
sustain effectively.
Like you,
you,
you're,
you're going to want to have those points to sort of get sustainability for the next level up.
And we want to make sure that there is sustain if you're doing,
you know,
engaging with those mechanics well.
Yeah.
Um,
but effectively you do have to actually like to,
to get sustain at higher difficulties.
Um,
you will need to be able to,
you know,
be making smart choices in terms of allocating and like using the tablets correctly and that kind of stuff.
Um,
like it is part of that sort of story of all of that.
so,
um,
yeah,
that's the,
that's,
that's kind of the main thing with that.
Yeah.
This idea of like sustaining the content you want to do by doing it is a little different to how it's been in P1 a lot of time where it's like you had to fuel it by going back to maps.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Get your old juice.
I mean,
you're still doing maps ultimately,
you know,
in terms of like,
but yeah,
but,
but effectively,
like,
so long as you're doing the content that you,
um,
uh,
that you,
that you want to do,
you should,
and,
and as well,
and making it harder.
Um,
you know,
so your build has to be good enough to be able to,
to be able to sustain it.
Then,
then you will be able to sustain that stuff.
And,
you know,
uh,
like if you want every single map to have a breach in it,
that's absolutely doable.
Um,
by,
uh,
you know,
using the tablets correctly.
Yeah.
So the,
um,
atlas passive trees and the trees for each of the distinct types of content is about scaling the reward and difficulty primarily.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Um,
and what does,
I saw like on the breach nodes,
it said like increased difficulty.
What does that mean?
Um,
it's somewhat arbitrary and asymmetric,
but,
um,
it will feel like,
for example,
some of the difficulties will actually change the boss's skills and how they work.
Um,
generally that will increase like the level of the area,
right?
So you get the general,
uh,
monster and life scaling.
Um,
but,
uh,
arguably to a player that's arbitrary as well,
cause they don't know how that scales.
Um,
uh,
and another context here might be more of certain monster types,
less of others and stuff like that.
Um,
it is generally,
uh,
that,
yeah,
so the small nodes will increase difficulty of the meta content,
whereas the large,
the notables will increase the reward of the in map content.
Um,
but when I say difficulty,
that is reward as well.
So,
an example of how this works is like,
um,
let's say the boss has six uniques it could drop,
or five or six uniques.
Um,
it can drop three at difficulty zero.
Then at say,
um,
difficulty one,
it can drop,
you know,
maybe has increased level or higher item level,
um,
some rarity.
Um,
you know,
now also that when I say rarity,
also do note rarity does increase the grade of items,
not just making them yellow or orange.
It does make them better yellows or better or,
uh,
no,
not better oranges.
Um,
it does affect,
yeah,
it affects other things about items than just the rarity.
Yes.
Um,
and so,
yeah,
when I talk about just getting rarity here,
I don't want people to,
and PeeWee1 players in particular to think,
ah,
they're just going to go from yellow to more yellow.
Um,
so anyway,
and you know,
maybe the next tier will add a unique to the pool,
like a more,
uh,
you know,
what we hope will be more valuable unique.
And then the next one can do a bit more rarity,
something else,
maybe introduce a different unique perhaps.
And then the last difficulty introduces something ideally,
you know,
without giving away exact specifics of them,
more in the line of a,
um,
modular unique item,
say like megalomaniac or like,
um,
forbidden flesh and flame from PeeWee1.
So a unique item that is like ideally very powerful,
very chase.
Um,
but,
uh,
has a lot of different combinations.
Watchers eyes,
another good example,
right?
So a new series of jewels,
um,
is a good example.
There are other uniques that are modular and stuff,
and that comes in at the last tier.
And so you want to really be getting to that hardest difficulty.
So you can be getting these like,
farming for these extremely good,
powerful,
unique items.
Um,
but of course you have the thing if you're never ready for it.
If you try it and you're like,
oh,
this is too hard.
You can always just respect the nodes.
You can unspec them away and,
uh,
then not,
you know,
like,
uh,
just effectively decide,
like,
I've got these points,
but,
um,
I'm not,
yeah,
I want,
I want to go back and do this later.
And so that ability to effectively configure the difficulty like that,
I think.
So if you're maybe target farming one of the base,
one of the uniques,
the difficulty zero drops,
you might want to just be like,
I'll do that.
I'll do the difficulty stuff later and I'll just farm it at this difficulty.
So,
and I,
I think that's a much better way than the,
than some of the systems we've used to scale that in the past.
And the nice thing is,
of course,
the difficulty is that we can effectively get what,
use whatever scaling levers we want to make that more difficult without
necessarily having,
like,
because we could have been like,
Oh,
you know,
you increase the difficulty.
It's like 200% life or something like that.
But by effectively being a bit more vague about it,
we can actually like specifically tailor the difficulties of the different
tiers,
like,
you know,
with more specific changes.
Yeah.
This like multiple projectile thingy shoots has more projectiles.
Sure.
And that kind of thing.
So,
you know,
we just,
whatever we feel works best for making this particular fight more difficult.
It seems like there's a lot more for players to kind of discover
experimentally there as they progress.
For sure.
In what way they're getting harder.
And that,
um,
it's going to be different for different players too,
where like a different build is affected by a difficulty change more so than others.
Potentially.
And,
uh,
that,
that's an interesting question as well.
I think where how much are you guys pitching these sorts of distinct end game pieces of
content at being like completable by the same build or by encouraging players to make a
different build that's better at certain.
So this is,
this is a very difficult one.
Um,
and,
uh,
it's something that we've discussed a bit recently is like the harder you make the
hardest content,
the less builds will be considered viable by the players because,
um,
effectively like a build's only viable if it can defeat like,
you know,
the,
the pinnacle boss at difficulty for,
like,
that will be kind of the general perception.
So we have to be really like,
I actually don't know necessarily what the right answer here is.
Um,
like we,
uh,
have the ability.
I mean,
maybe you feel like you do,
but I don't think I,
I wouldn't say I'm a hundred percent confident on it,
but like,
you know,
I'll,
I'll have a go at it.
Look,
there's going to be iteration here because what we'll see is like,
you know,
if we find that like,
um,
you know,
there's only like some particularly abusive,
like only the most abusive stuff is possibly able to defeat the hardest content that we might have to dial it back a bit.
Yeah.
Um,
but it's kind of going to be a bit of experimentation and it's very hard at this point to be able to pitch that because we don't have the,
um,
crazy history.
you know,
Pee Wee 2 does not have the history of Pee Wee 1 to be able to,
to know kind of what,
like what is the right life value to have on a difficulty for pinnacle boss?
Like,
how do we even know that at this point really without,
you know,
that being said though,
like the bosses are a lot more skill based and tactical,
right?
Like at the end of the day,
uh,
the gear is to some degree necessary because no one can really make no mistake for some amount of time,
you know?
So you do have that thing and you do need to mitigate certain things,
but like a lot of these are like very dodge roll tactical,
um,
or using certain skills or mitigation tactics or whatever you do.
There's heaps of different things to bypass the things that make them hard for sure.
But I would say it is very much,
a lot of skill is involved.
Um,
especially when it comes to some of these with dodge rolling,
like I'm trying to emphasize that quite a bit,
um,
or blocking,
you know,
if you want to do a different way about it,
um,
not to say you must block,
but yes,
dodge roll is a pretty key mechanic here.
And I'd say we're certainly upping the emphasis on using and using it well,
as you get into these higher tiers,
but gears,
always a way in combinations of uniques and passive tree and build is always a way to go.
I'm not good at dodge rolling.
I'm going to gear around that skill check and become strong enough to defeat the boss,
you know,
or another skill,
like some sort of skill that helps you block using skills in the mix is fine.
Yeah.
But I would say pretty generally you can take,
I'd say any decent character,
you get pretty damn,
you gear up all the way.
And as long as you're good enough,
that is a way to defeat them.
I would say there's no real hard requirement on doing something crazy niche or out there or complicated.
You're certainly not going the route of like,
Oh,
this boss is fire immune or something.
no,
map-esque Atlas,
which I know you're particularly fond of,
Jonathan.
Yep.
What's the,
what's kind of the idea here?
Like,
is the layout the same for everyone?
Is it the same across the league?
So it's the same for all your characters in the league,
but the layout is different for everyone.
It is random.
Oh,
okay.
So you're going to have to find stuff.
Like,
it works like Delve in this respect,
which is obviously a league that I was particularly a fan of.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
I'm just a really,
I,
what I really wanted is I wanted a feeling of exploration in the Atlas.
And it's something,
that we sort of tried to do with the Atlas and Peewee 1 with that feeling of kind of,
you know,
having the connected areas and exploring,
but it never really,
it didn't feel like exploration quite in quite the same way that this does.
Yeah.
So that's the feeling I loved.
And it's,
it's one of the reasons I love Delve.
And so that's,
you know,
kind of,
kind of where this was coming from.
And at the same time,
it's sort of solving various other problems that we've always had where,
like,
one of the things that's really cool to do is to be able to have things like,
okay,
like in this area,
you've got like this item drops and like that kind of thing,
you know,
like I guess in Peewee 1,
you had div cards,
but yet there was always a problem where if you have differences between in-game areas in a system that works like Peewee 1 does,
then effectively that's the only map people,
like whatever the best map is,
that's the one everyone will run continuously forever.
So effectively,
we wanted to try and make sure that you actually like had an experience that had more variety while still retaining the whole,
like,
I get to play the content that I want.
So ideally with the,
with the Atlas,
we kind of get that we've got in Peewee 2,
we get to kind of have both of the best of both worlds.
We get to make sure that there is some variety,
you know,
you feel like you're exploring,
but because once you've run a map,
that's run and now you have to,
you know,
move on and find another one.
It's not just like the,
you know,
like just play one map again and again and again,
but yet the content,
you know,
can be added to it.
You can do things,
if you like the,
you know,
particular maps,
because there are biomes and you can see them from far away,
you can be like,
okay,
I know there's a particular desert map.
That's great.
So I'm going to go for deserts and that's fine.
You can do that kind of thing.
So,
you know,
like you've,
you've both got controllability,
but also,
you know,
the ability for us to kind of make more variants.
You get a lot more very high satisfying spikes.
Yeah.
Well,
like for example,
you get more variables where you just have,
okay,
there are like four towers really.
You've got a good tower cluster and you've got really good maps in,
in that range.
So like,
you know,
there are maps.
So in,
in PathXL1,
for example,
you know,
the range is effectively say,
how do I quantify this?
Like say 350 monsters up to 700 monsters.
Yeah.
Whereas the range here is like 300 monsters up to like,
1500 monsters,
you know,
much,
much more drastic range.
Now those numbers are arbitrary,
but it is approximately the representation of the range.
Obviously you then modified and add more to it and all of that.
So you will have some maps that are like extremely good with Delirium.
Um,
um,
and some maps that are like way better with something more like breach.
Yeah.
Because Delirium enhances the monsters of the map.
Whereas breach entirely adds the monsters.
And you will even have things where there are maps that are like way more magic monsters,
way more rare monsters.
And so you probably want that with,
you know,
pick your league of your choosing and whatnot.
You have all these variables that are at play.
And so you all of a sudden find a really good set of towers with some really good maps and radius.
And then you'll get really good tablet modifiers.
And then you'll get really good maps with really good prefixes.
And you want to just combine all of us and to,
and you obviously instill them all and you corrupt them all.
And there's the corruption influence.
We didn't show that.
And so then there's a corruption influence on them.
And it's like,
yeah,
okay.
Like it is possible for this on one map to be many,
many mechanics stacks to the point of craziness.
Hmm.
So it sounds like the,
the juicing is definitely there.
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
that's,
that's important,
right?
I mean,
like that's part of the PeeWee experience.
Yeah.
For a hundred percent.
But,
uh,
how,
um,
how much control do you have as a player though,
over min-maxing your just exploration of the Atlas map?
So effectively,
um,
can you do better in some way?
Um,
so effectively what you're going to be wanting to do is the towers are where you go to like
see areas around.
And then there's the,
the,
the structure of the connections is quite open.
So like you can beeline for things,
um,
pretty well.
Like if you,
like you can certainly see a lot more maps than what you play,
if you know what I mean.
Um,
so,
uh,
because of that,
um,
like,
you know,
choosing what you want is,
is,
is easy to do.
And you can kind of see the towers in the fog.
Yes.
You can see the towers in the fog from a distance,
which means that,
um,
you know,
you don't like a lot of the time it's like,
go to a tower,
you'll see some maps you want to play.
You go play those.
Then it's like the next tower is just a few other maps away.
Go to that tower,
see the,
see the next area and so on.
I'm guessing that's like a certain range out.
You can see.
Yeah.
The fog kind of lift,
uh,
in 3d kind of,
the fog's actually a 3d thing and it like,
it like rises slowly as he gets away from where the thing is.
So that's how you kind of get the towers to.
Oh,
so you,
you might see a cluster of towers off somewhere.
Yeah,
absolutely.
You can see that.
It sounds like this is like potentially an infinitely expanding map that is going to be by the end of someone's league quite big.
Yes.
Um,
so we haven't,
we actually need to add a search feature.
I don't know if they've done it yet for finding specific maps that haven't been run yet.
We have a few things.
There's a button you can press and it like goes to your last map round one that goes back to a home,
base and one that goes to some of the special,
uh,
you know,
more iconic things you find.
But,
um,
this,
we certainly need more,
um,
a hundred percent.
So that is something we will be working on.
Hopefully it's there.
Who knows?
And,
uh,
so way stones have a tier,
but they don't have specific maps on them anymore,
which obviously shrinks that whole map pool thing down substantially.
Um,
it'll make,
it'll make the maps dash tab a little easier to manage.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
that's good.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
the,
have you thought about like what sort of,
I don't know,
economic consequences that have for like how players progress through maps?
Is it easier to do when you don't have to collect all of these individual maps to get the completion bonuses and stuff like we do currently?
Like we have that whole,
you know,
hunting down over a hundred maps to get completion for.
I mean,
yeah,
now you're hunting,
you know,
you're hunting certain valuable maps,
you're hunting towers,
you're hunting content,
you're hunting,
um,
you know,
the,
the warlord,
the faction leaders to,
to get the pinnacle.
Yeah.
You know,
you're hunting,
uh,
unique maps,
very different thing for sure.
Um,
as opposed to,
and then the item is all about,
I've just got a key.
I just want good modifiers.
You know,
there's not really all that whole other variable to it.
So there's still a lot of,
a lot of interesting choice and axes.
Um,
but we've taken it from the item and put it on the actual world map.
but it's cool.
It also makes you just feel like you're traversing a world,
you know,
you're not instantly like finishing the campaign,
very grounded.
And now I'm in space,
you know,
like public.
I was going to ask,
I only literally just thought about that.
I was going to ask about that.
So,
you know,
the mapping system was always this like extra dimensional kind of unknown thing.
It's pretty interesting,
but it is a little weird.
So we wanted to start with actually like,
at least,
I mean,
look,
I'm sure we'll get to the extra dimensional beings eventually,
but,
um,
uh,
at least to start with,
you know,
we,
uh,
have a bit more grounded initially.
Yes.
So,
you're on the planet,
right?
You're on the planet.
We haven't gone to the moon yet.
Well,
even then we were saying like,
can we at least,
at least before we go to outer space,
go to the moon first.
Whoa,
actually,
well,
how many moons are,
we don't know.
There's,
there's a whole complicated thing we need to figure out there.
Oh,
I feel like there's a delve,
but up league coming.
All right.
So we've got this,
uh,
one in four maps is boss maps.
And then the,
that means the other three are not boss maps.
Yes.
What does a non boss map look like?
How do you win it?
So effectively what you need to do is,
um,
kill the,
uh,
kill the rares,
um,
in the map to,
to remove the corruption and finish it.
Um,
once you get down below 50 monsters,
it will point out,
uh,
any rares that are remaining.
There'll be a little marker just so you know.
I was worried about that.
Honestly,
I wouldn't expect that to even be necessary most of the time because the layouts are kind of designed so that,
you know,
like,
if you generally speaking,
you want to clear the maps to find the rares anyway,
because those are the one,
you know,
those have good drops.
Um,
and effectively,
um,
the,
the only reason that you would need that marker thing is just occasionally you get some slightly weird degenerate layout where there's some side bit you didn't notice or something like that.
And that's like,
that's where you have to go.
So generally speaking,
you'll be able to make your way around and kill them all.
The goal of the player is you're cleansing corruption from the world.
You're bringing water back,
um,
you know,
stuff like that.
So you even get the thing on the map where you're like,
you know,
there's some corruption-y looking stuff around the map.
When you complete the map,
that gets purged away.
Um,
you know,
so you feel like you're reverse painting the map a little bit.
Oh,
we're cleaning up.
It can actually be quite satisfying as you're like changing all the nodes from one color to another and you're like,
yeah,
this is fun.
I'm like,
you know.
Ultimately,
what we wanted to do is,
um,
we wanted boss combat in PoE 2 to matter when we have it.
Yeah.
And so in order,
like if you have a map,
uh,
boss every area,
then if we made it so the boss combat mattered enough,
like in order to actually balance it that way,
it's,
it's too much.
Like it actually is like,
you know,
you,
you spend too much of your time fighting bosses.
Yeah.
Um,
so effectively if,
if that's what you want to do now,
you can do it because there's bosses there.
You know,
like when I say one of four maps is a map boss,
that doesn't mean that one of four maps you play is one.
Um,
because you know,
obviously you can pick what content you're doing by exploring around.
You can chain the map boss.
You're picking your path and your path.
Yeah,
exactly.
So effectively if,
if you want to hunt the bosses,
then that is the thing you can do.
Um,
if you want to just like do some mindless grinding for a while,
uh,
you can do that too.
And what it means is we can actually make the bosses way more rewarding.
Uh,
they can drop way more items than they were going to because of the fact that there's not one at the end of every area,
right?
And then,
and the,
the fight is substantial.
You get a lot of drops.
Um,
so,
uh,
that actually is something.
And they get their own tree and they,
what?
Oh yeah,
I don't know.
Right.
You mean the boss,
the boss killing tree.
Yes.
There's a tree for boss hunting.
Sorry.
I thought you meant every boss had its own tree.
I was like,
geez,
did you do some design?
Well,
I wasn't looking at it.
Not yet.
Josh was like,
wait,
no,
stop.
It's too much.
That's like a year three feature.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll keep that in mind.
Um,
yeah.
So there's actually like a,
I do love that there's a boss hunting cause I'm super into that.
There's a boss hunting tree that you can fill out as well.
So how do you get points on that?
Like,
yeah.
So effectively,
I mean,
well,
you can,
um,
you get a lot of points for the core tree.
There's a core tree that affects all mapping.
Um,
that a lot of things like pack size,
quantity,
rarity,
and you've got multiple keystones that,
um,
all work can work together and all can do.
So I think there's three of them.
Uh,
one plays on like corrupted maps.
One plays on like prefixes and suffixes.
And I can't remember what the other ones,
the other one does right in this very moment.
Um,
but you obviously get that core tree and then you have,
you know,
a boss tree and then obviously all the different league and pinnacle content
trees.
So you get those points by just completing maps.
It just has a,
you effectively get a quest.
Um,
and effectively it's like you complete 10 maps.
You get your first two points and then like complete X maps and one,
you know,
but of certain tiers,
like at least tier one,
at least tier two,
at least tier three.
Climb effectively where it's like,
as you get up the higher tiers and clear maps of certain tiers,
that's when you start getting points for the Atlas.
And like may I say the third one,
I,
I can't remember the exact specifics.
It's like complete this and defeat a boss or,
and then later it's defeat at least five bosses at something.
And you know,
so killing bosses get generated.
It sounds way better for a fresh start.
So I'm not having to like go and get that estuary map that I missed or
something.
It's like,
Oh yeah,
for sure.
I'm just,
I'm just doing content.
I'm just doing good content.
But it is kind of the analog of that in a way,
because like,
it's that feeling of like,
I've got a system to progress through.
Like I just need to,
I need to meet these objectives and I'm getting,
and I'm getting from that,
you're getting the,
you know,
the Atlas,
the Atlas passive points and so on.
Cool.
Um,
so yeah,
that's kind of the idea.
Yeah.
So you can really like focusing on map blasting with the bossless maps and,
or,
you know,
or on bossing content if you want to,
or on breaches or on.
And you can always put a breach on a map with a boss,
right?
You can do both.
Yeah.
Like they can have,
they can have,
you can have,
you can have every type of content in one map if you want.
Yeah.
Is like a boss map,
a kind of like a distinct thing from like a regular map in terms of like the,
the layout or the thing you've done?
Technically they are separate,
but generally speaking,
um,
like similar.
They're basically the same,
but they're pretty similar.
So they'll be like a boss history and a non-boss history.
Yeah.
There are,
there are some cases at the moment where there are some maps that can't have a
boss.
Um,
and it's just,
we haven't done the,
you know,
the,
the one that would go here is not in early access yet and that kind of thing.
But effectively,
um,
you know,
as I said,
generally speaking,
it'll be one in four.
Okay.
Excellent.
Um,
so I think,
I think that covers,
did I miss some things from,
you've got like the,
all the smaller,
contents like the strong boxes and essences.
Yeah.
So initially we actually had a design where everything,
um,
like even all the smaller content,
there was still going to be icons for it on the tree.
I was around the Atlas.
Yeah.
But we actually found that it meant that when you were actually exploring,
it didn't kind of,
it felt like there was nothing random to find.
So we wanted to make sure we also have kind of just completely random stuff.
Yeah.
Like it doesn't have a progression system that you just run into randomly.
Cause that's fun too.
And I will probably be adding more stuff like that as well over time.
That's just like,
just the,
I randomly encountered this and that was like not expected.
So that's all the stuff on the core Atlas tree.
Yeah.
So you can kind of like see more of that if you want to.
Great.
And,
and often mods on the items as well.
On map.
Keep waystones.
Yeah.
Cool.
Yep.
Lots of different names.
Maps,
waystones,
same thing.
Yes.
So I've had to keep thinking,
kind of correcting myself about that.
I was like,
yeah,
I don't know.
I mean,
internally we cut,
we definitely call them maps all the time.
The thing is,
is that the only reason why it doesn't make sense thematically is because a map does imply
it's of a specific location,
whereas a waste can take you to anywhere.
Yeah.
So that's the reason why the name change had to happen.
But I think that probably even players will probably just call them maps.
I bet.
Just cause you know,
if that's the period.
So we've got,
we've got the breach delirium ritual expedition,
those like leagues that maybe need a new name.
Yep.
Is there another one that you're just both personally really keen to bring back in the future?
I mean,
you know,
like I've always wanted to have a delve again,
but I kind of got a bit of that wish with the system.
Yeah.
It's also a very like,
like content heavy league to make because you need to make tons of encounters and like doing it properly is a huge thing.
But I mean,
I look,
I love incursion as well.
It's one of my favorites.
Like I'm keen for that.
I don't know if there's anything new other than that you're really keen for.
There's a lot,
especially because there's a lot I can do with,
we can do with all this new art,
new monsters,
right?
Like for example,
if you just take Legion,
Legion had all those five civilizations.
We've now got an entire new array of vile monsters,
vile bosses,
et cetera,
that we can use as a baseline.
We've got way better consistent direction on what's going on there.
You know,
heaps of stuff,
new animation and the capacities are just like out of control.
But then you've got,
okay,
incursion.
We've got,
you know,
awesome vile artwork we can use there and make that all awesome and nice.
New corruption mechanics that we can extrapolate on.
You don't want to have a roof as the boss anymore?
No,
you're not just going to have a floating roof.
The Omnitex is just a small floating roof.
Oh,
you're keeping with the theme of vacuum cleaners.
Wow.
Standing and then the brood.
Mistakes were made.
Now we have minimum,
like that's a world where you had super uniques with one or two skills.
Yeah.
Right.
I don't,
there's only so much you can do with a floating roof.
So anyway,
and then,
um,
I don't know,
even like bestiary coming back with something because we've got all these awesome bosses,
way grander in scale.
And you can do these more grand hunts for them as opposed to just like,
Oh,
I'm like in a city and there's a rare spider,
you know,
you can just get way,
way more epic and way more,
um,
you know,
involved in with all the new art and so much stuff to like bestiary too.
That's like hunting big beasts and preparing for them and tracking them.
That'd be pretty cool.
Exactly.
I definitely take some mercenary action to that.
It'd be a good fit I feel.
Hmm.
All right.
Well,
there's lots for us to look forward to there.
You have some kind of like penned already for adding to the beta.
I mean,
we,
all plans can change,
but,
uh,
there are absolutely,
I mean,
look that we've,
we've,
we've done things like commissioning art assets and so on.
Like we've got,
uh,
stuff coming along.
It's just a question of like,
you know,
when we actually get there,
what's it going to look like?
Yep.
All right.
Um,
let's talk about crafting a little bit because you've done a lot there and it's,
uh,
pretty fundamental to the game,
I think.
Um,
so what's the core of what you're trying to do with crafting in part of exile two compared
to part of exile one?
Uh,
kind of noting that you've really kind of stepped back from the idea of like reforging
an item many times or scouring it.
So,
um,
we really want to make it so that you're,
you're,
you're finding crafting items all the time.
You're using those crafting items way more often than you were in POE1.
Um,
that,
you know,
you're like the,
the,
the game of,
of like picking something up,
like seeing what I could modify it to,
like then actually equipping those items is just happening way more often.
And there's so many subtle changes around this,
like in terms of,
um,
uh,
just like the way that,
the way that the base mod scale and items and the,
you know,
like things like that,
like all the stuff to kind of make it so that,
um,
as you find new base types and new things,
like you've got a reason to craft them,
you know,
part of that is making sure that,
um,
you know,
you've got enough of that currency.
Um,
you know,
it actually took us a long time to even get comfortable with the idea of making something like an exalt drop that often.
Yeah.
Cause there's just this thing in your cemented in your mind of like,
um,
you know,
Oh,
this is,
this is rare,
right?
Like it's an exalt.
How can it possibly drop like,
you know,
multiple times in act one?
Um,
you know,
like it just,
it just seems crazy.
Um,
but,
uh,
with the way like removing scouring affected so much of the way that we craft,
like,
I know,
I know that you noted earlier that,
um,
you can,
uh,
there's so many more things you're allowed to craft now that you weren't allowed to before.
you can craft relics.
Yes.
And the reason why that's allowed is because without scouring,
um,
like those crafts become one time things,
which means that it's actually okay to allow for that stuff.
And I think that's opened up a huge amount of stuff.
You know,
there's just,
yeah,
there's so many more types that can be crafted.
It adds so much more valuable value to the dropped.
Exactly.
So,
um,
that stuff has just,
I think opened up a huge amount there.
And,
um,
it also has,
and this wasn't necessarily an explicit goal right at the beginning,
but it's also made that the,
the,
the game of like,
I'm just going to click,
click,
click again and again as my crafting session is no longer really the meta.
It's a spam.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like everything kind of is something that you want to be able to use.
You are still reforging and meta crafting things.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
We've still got stuff like that,
right?
We've got a noles.
But that stuff is higher up.
Like that,
that's kind of more of a,
of a later game thing.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
cause you have to think about it after each time of like,
will I improve this?
Will I make it worse?
Yeah.
Um,
something that,
um,
omens can do,
is also very interesting.
Like there's some pretty powerful stuff there,
but once again,
we introduced that stuff later on.
And so effectively we want to,
uh,
you know,
I guess for lack of better,
democratize crafting at early levels,
like make sure that,
uh,
everyone's able to do that stuff,
um,
while having the more advanced stuff be kind of a little bit later.
We certainly had a goal at one point where I was like,
we're talking with Rishi and I'm like,
if,
if it's every single time we're doing alpha wipes or getting the stuff to play,
I am like,
if I am not seeing and hearing about people using exalts during act one,
then we have failed.
And we need to drop more of them.
And so we ended up like,
I would say honestly,
in the last month we have like over like eight to 10 times the amount of
currency dropping,
you know,
and you know,
there's the cool things about it as well,
which are the subtle things like a boss is way more likely to drop the
higher tier currencies and stuff.
Cause again,
rarity affects that as well now.
So you're like way more incentivized to go and kill bosses to get them.
And there's,
there's heaps of awesome stuff around there,
but we're actually now finding people are exalting gear,
um,
during the campaign,
throwing it on weapons and building weapons from scratch.
You find a very good transmute,
org,
regal,
exalt,
you know,
that process is like transmute,
um,
org,
regal,
exalt is like a thing that you're doing often.
Yeah.
And like,
enjoy,
and you know,
like when you find good bases and you do stuff with that.
I can speak to that experience.
So I've played probably six ish hours,
most of the way through act two on my mercenary.
And I've found maybe six or seven exalts.
I took a ring from like a one blue stat ring that had a nice role,
maybe a nice life role or something,
and crafted it up to six property rare.
And I crafted a crossbow that I found with good sockets that had a good damage
role in it.
And I took that to six properties with multiple damage mods.
And I'm like,
each time that power is going up.
And I was,
I was,
I was doing that.
It feels good.
I felt like the bottleneck was regals,
which was actually kind of interesting because I don't know if that's intentional,
just luck,
because I did really have to think about which blue items were good enough to take to a rare.
Yep.
So that I could then put my exalts on them.
So you get more of those by disenchanting rares.
Yeah,
they are farmable.
So they are farmable,
which is,
um,
completely intentional.
We want to make sure that like,
if you don't have enough of those,
like,
so you get,
so generally speaking,
it's like,
you're going to want to keep,
uh,
like,
I feel like once you get like more than like five or six transmutes,
then you stop disenchanting blues and start selling them instead.
And the same thing can be true also for,
um,
for regals where it's like,
okay,
once you've got more than a certain amount,
then you're like,
okay,
I can stop having to disenchant this stuff and kind of switch over.
But the nice thing is,
is like when you don't have enough,
there is a way to get them,
um,
which I think is really important.
And the same is true with the socket currency as well,
where it's like,
you know,
when you don't have enough,
if you can start salvaging,
I know you were telling me you were buying stuff from the vendor with sockets in order to salvage it.
I surprised them with my,
uh,
yeah,
yeah.
With my methods.
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
uh,
that stuff,
um,
you know,
it's just really nice to have the,
for people to have the ability to,
um,
uh,
you know,
to,
to get that stuff when they need it.
And so it's nice that like all that really basic stuff of just like getting items to better tiers and is now way easier to get.
And that,
that solved a problem that we had,
um,
through quite a lot of the betas where people were saying they didn't feel like they had enough control.
Like they didn't feel like they had a way to advance their character when they needed to,
um,
to be able to solve specific problems.
And I think the socket thing really has helped a lot with that now,
because now we've got a way finally to be like,
okay,
if I need a bunch of fire resist,
there is a way to get that.
And I've got the tools to do it.
And I've got items I can use to do this stuff.
So,
um,
that,
has helped a huge amount,
I think of,
um,
solving those like,
uh,
you know,
issues that come up with your character.
And this is to confirm how you've solved bench crafting.
Exactly.
So we went through so many iterations of bench,
uh,
stuff.
It was like a huge thing.
We implemented tons of UI.
Like there was tons of wasted time there,
uh,
implementing crafting things.
The problem that we had was that the systems that we were making,
it's like we could balance them in the ways the players were happy with.
And,
um,
then the designers were very unhappy or we could balance them the way the designers were happy with and the players were unhappy.
And it's like,
when you've got a system where like you're fighting the players for what,
how the balance should be,
but you can tell that means you have a system that is bad.
Um,
but I think we were very like,
like I myself honestly was too slow to recognize the fact that a complete overhaul was needed.
Um,
and,
um,
then at some point we actually,
the socket stuff originally came from,
um,
the Valor,
like it was designed there.
Yeah.
And then at some point,
I don't know who came up with it.
I think it might've just been you,
um,
who said like,
why don't we just put Rishi thought of that?
Okay.
Yeah.
So Rishi thought of the idea of like,
Hey,
what if we just put sockets,
um,
you know,
in,
uh,
in early game,
what if you got them in act one?
What if you had rooms,
uh,
that would let you,
um,
get the,
uh,
the,
you know,
the baseball as the way of solving the remedial crafting problem.
And so then suddenly,
as soon as we do that,
it's like,
Oh,
like I'm happy,
uh,
you know,
players are happy,
everyone's happy.
Um,
so,
uh,
that means we have a good system that,
is working and,
you know,
and gets,
gets those good feelings.
So,
um,
that,
that I think was a real win.
Um,
and,
uh,
you know,
yeah,
I'm,
I,
I love how that system is feeling.
Yeah.
So the bench was achieving two things kind of in its way,
um,
which was,
uh,
maybe even three gear customization for one,
like you take an item and you can do something more to it firstly,
and then you've got the problem fixing of like,
Oh,
I need a bit more fire resistance.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
And then the third thing was like the meta crafts.
Um,
yeah,
yeah.
So you've handled those each in different ways.
Exactly.
You've got the runes,
which do the first two things,
the customization and the problem fixing.
So early on,
but I think the customization is even,
it's the,
uh,
um,
sorry,
what do you call them?
The soul cause,
like the runes are more about the kind of like,
I need to fix resistances.
Whereas the soul cause are more about like,
I want to customize my items in different ways than what I would,
um,
otherwise normally be able to do.
Um,
and then of course you've got the omens to solve the meta crafting problem.
So we effectively moved all that stuff around.
And essences of course,
yes,
of course.
Um,
so,
um,
yeah,
essence is what they allow you to do is get two deterministic mods.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
cause you can upgrade to a blue and the,
but you can also upgrade from blue to,
um,
to,
to rare,
um,
with an essence as well.
So that lets you kind of get some of that stuff.
And then plus some of the omen things you can,
yeah,
there's stuff you can do there.
Um,
that,
uh,
is I think going to be pretty interesting.
And that's just at the start of release.
Yeah.
Because obviously there's going to be more,
of course,
as we add more things,
you know?
So,
uh,
yeah.
Um,
so I was like,
I was worried that,
you know,
some of the changes you're making might move us away from some of the like deep impactful
crafting that we have,
but it sounds like you are still allowing like powerful meta crafting and the ability to make like a really good item.
For sure.
But you're also making sure that like the physical item itself that you find matters more.
Absolutely.
Mm-hmm.
And I mean,
like the,
the more subtle,
that's what it's all about,
right?
There's,
there's so much more going on.
I think just like,
just like clever things we've done with the,
um,
with the item system as well.
Like one of the things I love that we did is we've made it so that,
um,
so we've got blue and a yellow chests you can find now,
and we've changed the,
uh,
world generation so that if a dead end is generated,
um,
the chance that you get a rare chest there is,
is,
is way higher.
So effectively,
if a rare chest will spawn in the area,
then it will choose dead ends first to go there.
You feel better about it.
Yeah.
So like that means that we effectively mean that like,
like it makes the world feel like,
you know,
as far as item drops go,
they're like,
oh,
like,
it feels intentional,
right?
Like,
oh,
I went down this into this dead end room,
but look,
there was a rare chest there.
So I feel happy about it.
You know,
like that kind of thing is,
is,
is really cool.
Um,
so,
uh,
there's things like that,
but there's also the way that,
um,
yeah,
so we've alluded to it a few times,
but the,
the way that rarity now works,
um,
where the mods get better as rarity increases.
And,
um,
also things like the,
you get better currency rather than just,
yeah,
it means we don't have to have like the spam of items.
That's like crazy.
Like you actually feel like,
um,
the,
uh,
you kill a boss and it drops good shit,
um,
as opposed to just lots of shit.
Um,
so,
uh,
you know,
that,
that's the,
that's,
I'm a big fan of how this feels.
I think it's a lot better.
Um,
but it does mean though,
of course,
if you're a PeeWee one player and you see a boss kill,
like the number of,
like the,
the expectation of like,
Because a PvE 1 player sees, like, looks at the amount of spam on the screen to some level as the way of, like, knowing how good the drops were.
Now, of course, you've got item filters and everything.
We have quantity brain rot.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
That is a good way of putting it.
So, yeah, it really is more about, like, are the items actually good?
Like, ideally, you kill a boss and you pick every item it drops up.
You know, like, that to me is a win.
And I think we're basically getting it at that point.
Yeah.
And I quite like how the exploration systems in that as well, with the chests, dead ends and things like that, acts as a player leveler in some ways.
Yes.
Where, like, a player is struggling.
Yep.
The more you explore, the more stuff you'll find.
And that's true as well for the optional encounters around the place as well.
If you're struggling, go fight some optional content.
There will be stuff there that can drop and, you know, and you will definitely find more things.
Lots of guaranteed rare items here and there.
Exactly.
Like, this little boss here will drop a caster, a rare caster item and, like, heaps of stuff.
And the funny thing about that is that stuff, like, came about a little bit from the fact that we actually had a problem where people were just face tanking bosses and dying over and over again.
Yeah.
And they keep on respawning and they would never be like, oh, I'm going to go away and actually find some other stuff.
And so I was thinking for a long time about, like, well, why is it that in other games that people don't do that?
Like, if I'm playing Elden Ring and I die to a boss, like, you know, 10 times, I'm not just going to, like, just continue doing that.
I'm going to be like, oh, maybe I'll go do something else for a while.
So we realized that the map, like, the idea of just there's lots of stuff to find, like, is actually a really important part of that.
So in PeeWee 2 now, one of the recent things, and it's taken a lot of work from people to get this working, but now all of that, you can see all the sort of weird side encounters that have specific drops on the map.
And that means that, you know, if you're having trouble with the boss, you're like, oh, you know what, I'm just going to go do some other stuff.
And then you'll come back and you will be powerful enough to kill the boss much more easily because you do absolutely find the rewarding things.
Yeah, there's a little chest on there or a little campsite.
Yeah, yeah.
There's lots of little hard-coded drops from specific bosses.
The hard-coded drops, they only drop one time, so you can't just farm them endlessly.
But effectively, if you go do all that side content and you check it all off, you'll get some very rewarding stuff.
Yeah, you've got some pretty clever systems there.
And I definitely noted that I was using the map thing a lot to be like, oh, well, to be completionist about it a bit.
But also, yeah, just being aware of, like, oh, cool, there's some good stuff in this zone that I can come and find.
And I think we figured out that, like, some of that stuff reveals after you, like, find the waypoint in a zone, for example.
I think that's how it works, is that?
Yeah, it's either, there's a few, so it's like,
either because an NPC told you about an area, in which case it just happens to be revealed,
or at the very least, yes, when you get there.
Generally, it's just when you get there, you see everything.
But there's a few different conditions that will reveal everything.
It kind of depends.
Like, a lot of people just click through the dialogue, so they'll never know the NPC told them, but they maybe did.
I was checking my map kind of like when I went into a zone, and then maybe afterwards to see if there was anything interesting.
But, like, you never get to an area and don't see some, unless they are, like, very obviously hidden intentional secrets.
Yeah.
There's nearly something everywhere.
They might be there, they might not.
Yes, I found half of your key for your secret quest.
Oh, yeah, yeah, don't worry about that.
So, pivoting into economy and trading, the exchange from Path of Exile's one experiment recently,
we got a chance to actually try that live in the field, and it seems from the player's perspective it was a smash hit.
Definitely for us as well.
Yeah, okay.
Solved a lot.
Great.
We were 100% on board with that.
It's very good.
It was the least stressful league I ever played.
Same.
What normally caused almost all the anger and friction for me was, especially bulk trading.
It was horrible.
And I was just like, oh, this is like a dream come true.
Myself and so many other players, I feel like we're more engaged in endgame, we were able to do the thing we wanted to do more,
and we're just less aggravated on a moment-to-moment basis.
That's good.
So, do you take that then as a big positive for it going into Path of Exile 2?
100%.
And how do you feel like it adapts to the game being quite different in the end?
Because they are pretty different games.
Like, the economy works a bit differently.
I mean, honestly, I think it will just work.
I mean, look, we have no idea what the trade values will settle on and how that will end up.
Yeah.
Is it going to be chaos?
Is it going to be exalt?
Yeah.
But ultimately, I think that the trades, effectively, settlers was a test of what the economy will be like in POE 2,
and to some extent, because of the way that we did the gold and everything.
Yeah.
So, I'm pretty confident that that's going to be okay.
But obviously, you never know, right?
Like, when lots of people hit the economy, what can happen?
Hopefully, we don't cause horrible hyperinflation or have some horrible issue like that.
But I guess, you know, partly this is what an early access is to find out, right?
Like, whether there's any issues like that.
Was there any...
Economy testing.
Was there any surprises with that or with gold in terms of how things panned out?
Thankfully, not, honestly.
Like, we were worried, but thankfully, none of the, like, horrible situations came to pass with that.
And it ended up working just fine.
So, yeah, like, it went great.
Who'd have thought 10 years later, we'd be back here saying, you know what?
Gold was a good idea.
We just had to do it right.
Exactly, exactly.
Because I remember 10 years ago, we were like, this game's brilliant.
It has no gold.
Stupid gold.
But the funny thing is, I don't think we would have arrived at the way gold is now if we had had it in the first place.
Yeah.
Like, the non-tradability of using it as a sort of marker for how much play you've done.
I don't think that we would have ever had that way if we hadn't arrived from here.
So, I think that that path dependency kind of did matter.
So, yeah.
The paths we weave.
So, how likely then, based on just how successful it is, are you to want to expand the, like, exchanges capabilities to, like, other things, like maps or waystones or even gear?
Well, I mean, look, I'm interested in this, but I don't think it's necessary right now.
So, in early access, at least, we're not going to launch with any expanded stuff in that way.
But I guess I do want to sort of see how it works.
And I'm interested in potentially trying something like that in the future.
I just don't, like, the currency exchange was, like, 90% of the problem.
Yeah.
And so, fixing that, like, fixed a lot of the, you know, like, it seemed like there would be, we would need to do more initially.
And then maybe now it's seeming like maybe we don't.
But I still want to experiment with it potentially.
So, you know, I'm interested to see how it goes.
But, yeah, the currency exchange definitely helped a vast amount of it.
Those were the annoying drains most of the time.
They were, for sure.
They were.
Yeah.
Definitely.
Great.
So, we've had some, well, so this is a tricky question to answer, especially if we could just scroll down.
There we go.
Yeah.
So, what are you aiming for in terms of Path of Exile 2 is kind of, like, personal player economy and progression.
So, how much resources you're acquiring, how you're using them, but also how much are you getting from trade versus from yourself?
I mean, this is a tricky question, but, I mean, I think that really the feeling of, like, being able to trade is super important.
So, being able to get that stuff, I think, is good.
Like, now, not everyone wants to do that.
You need to be able to progress through the game well without having to do much trade.
But I do think that, like, you know, look, it's definitely going to be the case that if you're playing in a trade league, you're going to have the ability to…
It accelerates.
It accelerates you very significantly.
And that's the case, and it will continue to be the case.
Yeah.
Like, we are a game that embraces trade.
Yeah, well, I think the DNA of Path of Exile 1 is very much that, like, it is a game about economy and trade.
Yeah, 100%.
And for some people, getting rich is their main motivator.
100%.
So, effectively, yeah.
So, I mean, that will absolutely be a factor.
And, look, like, I think that the feeling of that will probably end up feeling quite similar to PvE 1 in that regard.
Yeah.
And I think that's what, you know, that's the type of game we're making.
Do you think it's…
That said, though, do you think it is, in some ways, better for a solo self-found sort of experience?
I mean, I simply do, simply because, again, as we talked about, we're dropping a lot more currency that we expect you to use on here.
Exactly.
As opposed to save to endgame for one.
And then, by endgame, like, we don't have Kerak mods costing, you know, that kind of stuff that all costs chaos.
And you don't have, like, the meta mods costing divines and all that, right?
They're all different items.
You're like, I want meta mod crafting.
There's a ritual.
I'm going to get it.
You know where to get them as well.
Right?
So you're not just, like, having to, I'm blocked behind this thing because I need so many divines and I can't get that because I'm solo self-found and farming divines is not exactly, you know, beyond trivial.
So, you know, there's a number of ways there where I'd say it is, honestly, a much better solo self-found experience.
But, you know, each to their own, that to be seen and, you know.
And there'll be a separate solo self-found mode, presumably, even potentially beta launch or in the future?
It is our intention to have hardcore and solo self-found.
I'll have both of them.
Right.
Cool.
Yeah.
I wouldn't play hardcore for your first round, honestly, because you're likely to die.
Like, once you learn the boss mechanics, it should be fine.
But first time, you know, it's going to be tricky.
Couch co-op hardcore and you get to see your friend die right next to you.
That's the true dream.
Actually, hang on.
Wait.
In couch co-op hardcore, do we still lock the camera so you can't walk away from your friend?
Ah, no.
We put you back to solo.
You put you back to solo?
Okay, great.
That's good to know.
It's like the other.
You have to have a mourning period of about 30 seconds.
Right, right, right.
But you're just like, all right, you can go home now.
We're like, yeah, go.
Yeah.
See ya.
What do you do?
Yeah.
That is a devastating moment.
So I did lose my place there.
Yeah.
I think we mentioned the co-op support and everything.
And we'll scroll down and take some of the additional questions here.
Excellent.
Thanks.
So will there be a penalty for individual party member dying when grouping up for bosses
on that note then?
It seems weird that the boss straight up resets when playing solo, but when playing in a group
nothing happens if a party member dies.
Tell us about the rules.
Yeah.
How else do we have?
Because I know you've changed them recently.
Yeah.
So, well, bosses are obviously harder for having more people.
Yep.
Less crowd controls.
Things like, obviously, more life.
And I'm not just saying double life.
More than double life, right?
It does get more than twice as hard or more than in players as hard.
So, yes, you could argue, okay, we have reviving as an advantage.
Well, yes, it does.
It does take time to revive.
And if your friend dies early and you're unable to revive them because you're constantly being
interrupted, well, you're not having a fun time.
You get a big stun or something.
Another change that we made recently is, of course, for each revive between each set of
checkpoints.
Every time you have to revive them, the revive takes longer subsequent times.
So, that's important because it just means that you can't revive spam anymore because
it's going to take longer and longer each time.
But then when you go to a checkpoint, that resets.
So, you're back to normal.
Now, in endgame maps, you cannot revive each other.
Death is a consequence.
Yeah.
I was going to ask, actually, about endgame maps.
What is the rule for dying in endgame maps?
Is it one portal deal now, not six portals?
Well, you still have six portals, so you can have your party members.
And you can leave and come back as long as you don't die.
So, you can take items out.
But a death will end that map for you.
Yeah.
And to remind people, if you log out or the server crashes or something like that, that's
going to happen.
Then the game pauses.
So, when you boot the game back up and log back in, you'll be still in your map, right?
And also, we also now have it so that if you just old F4 the game at a random time, you'll
actually, even if you come back the next day, because, for example, you might have rage quit,
you will appear back at the checkpoint you were at.
So, if you are fighting a boss, you die a bunch of times, you're like, ah, crap, old F4, you
come back, you're going to be right there at the boss checkpoint again.
That part is campaign specific, because there are no checkpoints in maps.
Yeah, not maps.
But for the campaign, though, and that, honestly, has helped a lot.
Like, there were so many, I think it really did cause new players to have problems in
POV1, where they felt like they just lost track of where the hell they even were when
they came back after a session.
If, like, they might have not got waypoints for certain times or things like that.
Like, you now can't have the situation where you log back in and you're like, oh, I'm
like, I forgot, like, three waypoints in a row, and now I'm, like, freaking miles away
from where I was.
Which I think happen to do players fairly frequently.
I'm glad in a world where everyone's becoming a Souls-like that you guys didn't do the running
back to the boss segment of gameplay, and you just kind of jump back in and have another
crack.
I appreciate that.
So, yeah, so effectively, like, that's nice to just have the save checkpoints to your
character, which I think is a nice one.
Were there any other mechanics around there?
Reviving?
Well, obviously in hardcore, you did, you did.
That's the drill.
That's irrelevant at that point.
So, yeah, maps almost embraces a kind of semi-hardcore mentality there where there is actual cost.
Like, we went through so many iterations here where it's like, okay, like, the moment that
you have to spend something of economic value to do the attempt, hence a map, a map item,
and especially if it's got breaches and all this content that's coming from precursor tablets,
all of this stuff is worth stuff.
So, you all of a sudden have heaps of stuff on the line, and then you don't want to be in
a position where you're like, nah, I need to bring in some people to do this because
I'm not going to risk that value.
So, that's why we just were like, in maps, no reviving.
It's just like, yeah, sure, you still can always bring in any context someone way more
powerful than you to carry things, right?
That's the benefit of multiplayer.
But feeling like you have to do this thing because then they can just keep reviving you
so you can get all the rewards.
It's like, we're trying to get away from all of that, otherwise you get this weird thing
where you're often always too scared to do the thing.
Now, you're scared, but everyone's scared, and it's fine, and you don't feel like, you're
like, okay, you have to go in with a sense of confidence to, like, I can definitely do
this thing.
And so, it's just a little bit less fear when it comes to all of a sudden doing that.
That's much better in the context of the fact that you can pause the game if your cat's
on fire or if the server crashes or something that you just paused and you can jump back in
as well.
You're failing because of your own faults.
Yep.
Now, it's worth noting in multiplayer, we do have a thing, of course, with respawn at
checkpoints as an option.
So, if a player dies and you don't want to, like, you don't want to die, you don't want
to finish the fight out, you can both choose to respawn at checkpoint, and then it will
just create a new instance.
You don't have to die to do it.
And you don't have to log out and do any shenanigans like that.
You can just press escape, hit respawn at checkpoint, it'll ask other players to confirm,
and then it moves you all to the new area.
Cool.
Excellent.
I didn't want to go super on it because we've definitely talked about it before, but
click-to-move versus WSD, it's definitely been asked about a bit.
So, there's been plenty of reports about WSD being amazing.
Personally, I've been using it a ton and really enjoying it.
I know you've said a lot of people around the office have, like, given it a try and adapted
to that, but it has raised the point for people that feel like they're still very much against
that for whatever reason, or maybe that they literally only have one hand and want to use
click-to-move still.
How does it stack up?
How does click-to-move still stack up now?
I think, honestly, it's fine.
Like, it's not been a problem.
There was a time where every time I'd go to sit down at a developer's computer, they'd be
in WSD, and just because it's a little bit easier to move around again or whatever.
But lately, I'd say now it's back to almost every designer's computer I sit back down
at to go play, they're back in click-to-move.
Interesting.
Yep.
It's gone full tilt the other way.
Interesting.
And I'm always like, ah, change it back.
I wonder why that is.
But even watching Octavian play on click-to-move.
He's a click-to-move player, yeah.
He's 100% click-to-move.
He is very proficient with that.
That'll be reassuring for, I think, some of the people that are worried about being forced
into WSD.
Even though it is, obviously, playing so well by all accounts.
That's very good then.
Yeah.
And Octavian's often doing the demonstrations for your live things too.
So you'll be able to see that even.
I have to force them to play WSD sometimes because I'm like, oh, I think the Mercenary
looks so much better with WSD just visually.
Yeah.
So, you know, I'll tell them to.
It does feel very good on the Mercenary.
Yeah, yeah.
They're kind of like stalking through, especially with that kind of like preparational tactical
play style.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's good.
Loving it so far.
We did already talk about the skin transfers.
Can we scroll down to any additional questions that we have?
I feel like, I don't even know how long we've been going for.
I mean, it's a while.
I'm feeling the physical fatigue creep in at this point.
Yeah, exactly.
We've been going.
We've been rolling.
Yeah, yeah.
People asking if there's going to be anything like challenges or challenge rewards in the
early access.
Not at first, no.
We will do it later, though.
Did I ask about races, events, and private leagues?
I think not initially, but we will do it later for sure.
Cool.
I think the, I'm not sure what happened because I think the issue was that the private league
interface was like on the POE1 site and we had to do some work and something like
that.
It wouldn't be far away, though.
It won't take us that long before we get to it.
I can't exactly remember either, but yeah.
Private leagues in particular wouldn't be far away.
Yeah, yeah.
So, I mean, we'll have them, just not right initially, potentially.
And I think I did miss this, actually.
So, cluster jewels are a thing or not a thing?
Are they being kind of replaced by those radios?
We replaced them with that almost like rollable timeless jewel kind of thing.
Yeah, that's cool.
At least for now, there's like so much passive tree there and the jewels accomplished the
kind of off-build thing anyway.
You hardly need to add the extra passive trees on your passive trees yet.
Yes, yes.
That's after launch.
We made the passive tree implicitly bigger.
The cluster jewels are in the tree already.
That's again, I talk about like year three features.
That's around a year three to year five feature as well.
Yeah.
We've got another decade of what we had with Path of Exile 1 to look forward to for Path of
Exile 2, hopefully, before we start worrying about Path of Exile 3, maybe.
Jeez.
Just start thinking about that.
Give us a little while.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I guess to just finish this off for today then, do you guys have a recommendation of
what is the best class to play in the beta?
I mean, that's a very hard one, honestly.
There's so many choices now.
There are.
So let me, well, okay.
If we're going by the numbers.
Oh, yeah.
If we go by player satisfaction reports per class, we break it down from the beta.
Yeah, I mean, this is good technical information here.
Then that means the monk is very interesting because the monk is the class that dies the
most often.
Yeah.
But it's also the class that when people play it, they have the highest satisfaction level
by a very, very tiny margin that compares to the others.
That's fascinating.
Yeah.
I mean, it is like glass cannon, you know, like it's very fast, but you have to retreat
and move in and out.
I fell in love with the monk playing it.
It looks like it's got a little battery.
Yeah, yeah.
That's interesting.
But I think if you're a new player, then the mercenary, if you're like used to shooters
and stuff, I think playing the mercenary could be a good win.
I really love that class.
I don't know.
I've been loving the mercenary, but to me, it feels like you need to really be considering
each engagement a lot more.
It's a bit more tactical.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I like it.
I really like that.
You don't have that ability to correct if you make a mistake.
Honestly, I mean, I go through favorite classes all the time whenever I change to play a
different class that becomes my favorite.
That's my current favorite.
So, you know, yes, it's whatever I'm playing tends to be the thing.
So, yeah, right now I'm doing a mercenary playthrough, so that's probably why I'm into that.
But, yeah.
I'm not sure if you've got a similar film.
You were talking about the numbers as well.
It was interesting that Monk and then Warrior had the highest satisfaction levels.
Yes, Warrior.
Warrior's next, by the way, technically, if you're looking for...
That's pretty good.
That's two melee classes.
Exactly.
That's a win.
Yeah.
That's something going on.
I mean, they were dying a lot more at the time.
It's such a change from, like, especially early Path of Exile 1.
It's gotten a little better in modern days, but still.
I mean, I just have a, like, real desire to freeze time, so I just want to be a sorceress
and just go through...
I don't know what skills I'll play.
It's good to get some sorceress love.
I feel like she's not been getting enough attention.
I don't know what skills I'll play, but I definitely just want to be able to freeze time.
So, it just feels cool.
All right.
So, you could be playing a crossbow build anyway.
Yeah, I might be a crossbow time freezer.
I don't know.
We'll see what's going on.
Yeah, all right.
I liked that I noted that our mercenaries were very different as well.
I was playing full grenade or you were combo.
I was doing the freeze shotgun.
Yeah, very cool.
Yeah.
Some sort of monk trigger build, obviously.
It's always just going to be fun to play around with.
Yeah, they have so many of those, like, stacking effects.
The wind and the ice coming off it, and the ascendancy showed some more as well.
Just see how far that can be pushed and how many spells can I get to trigger per second.
Monk does seem good for that.
All right.
Well, thank you very much for your time, both of you.
I don't even know how long.
That was a mammoth session.
I think we're coming up to one o'clock here.
So, you know.
There's still lots to talk about, but I think we just need some time to digest.
For sure.
So, thankfully, we didn't have everyone saying patch notes when this time.
So good.
So we should have a conversation.
There's no pressure on this.
So, like, wrap it up, boys.
Yeah, yeah.
Exactly.
So, you know, that's good.
Fantastic.
All right.
Thank you very much for watching, everybody.
I hope you enjoyed the Q&A.
That was a good day.
Oh, they want patch notes now.
Oh, patch notes.
Well done.
It's not a patch.
It's a launch.
Exactly.
Where's the launch notes?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
All right.
Yeah.
Thanks, heaps.
Appreciate it.
It's been an epic journey.
It's kind of surreal.
And it's only the start of another journey, really.
That's it.
Yeah.
Can't wait to play.
It's cool.
I mean, I'm going to go play more now, but.
Yeah.
That's true.
Sorry.
I've got to go fix bosses going up elevators.
I'm just pre-bug testing.
All right.
I assume we've faded out and cut.
Hopefully.
You never know.